Hello, free code camp viewers. This is sagar
bansal, Once again, I'm back with a new course,
which is called license to pen test the beginners
edition. Now, if you are in the industry,
you might already be aware that license to
pentest is one of my premium live programs,
but this may settle with something amazing.
We took the live classes, we took all of the
recordings and we compiled a list of the best
recordings which were made for beginners.
And that's how the beginner edition was born.
Now in the whole course, you will find students
asking various questions, but I think we did
not cut that out in editing because see those
questions were kind of important. They were
very interesting and it's, it's very interesting
to see how I have answered those questions.
And a lot of you guys will have the same doubts,
so I will let the recordings as it is without
any editing.
And let's get started with this course. Just
make sure that you checked the description,
because if there is any update for the course,
I will put that in the description. And don't
forget, this course has its custom labs, the
labs, which my team created when we were giving
the classes, all of those labs, you can download
them from the description. So just check that
right now before proceeding. So let's get
started. I will not take more than a minute
to introduce myself. I am one of the 47 board
members of EC council advisory board for ethical
hacking IMEA. I am the youngest CCISO as well
as LPD master credential holder, I have altered
more than 25 reowned programs, including CISSP
masterclass, CCSP, masterclass, CISON, , and
so on. This course is intended for people
who want to get into the industry. People
who already have seen the YouTube, they have
gone through every video.
They can find on YouTube, but that's not helping
them to get through the industry. Those videos.
They are good. No doubt they are good, but
at the end, they don't teach you how industry
really works. So this course is intended to
teach you those concepts, which are missing
on YouTube. And again, since this is a premium
program, you will notice the quality difference
within the first lecture itself. So I hope
you are super pumped up just like me, but
here's the problem. My lawyer says that we
need to give a legal disclaimer because this
course has some really cool shit. Here's the
disclaimer, free code camp, Sagar Bsansal,
Sagar Bansal group of companies, our partners
and affiliates, YouTube it's partners and
affiliates are not responsible for any of
the actions you take after completing this
course or watching this video. Any numbers
claimed within this video are for reference
purposes, only any trademarks use in this
video, are the intellectual property of their
respective owners, all the students appearing
in this video through camera or voice have
provided their consent to the author, which
is basically me and the video contains professional
penetration testing, knowledge and everything
has been done in a control simulated and woman.
So again, I will stress this point. Everything
we do is in a simulated environment. You want
to get the same environment. Cool. Just go
and check the description. I will put the
links there. You can download every single
machine we use from there. Let's get started.
Uh, so there is a pen tester machine, which
Kali Linux. The thing is that this Kali Linux
has got the virtual box. Um, you know, what
do you say that, uh, the Kali Linux has got
virtual box add ons installed. So you can
drag and drop things from your host operating
system to this. You can copy and paste things.
So that's why I'm sharing this gear. If you
got your own, that's fine. Um, there is a
beta server. So our website is hackerinthehouse.com
for this course, basically we just made it
whole website for that and uh, there's a subdomain
Beta.hackernthehouse.com. That's our first
target. Then we got something called media.hackerinthehouse.com.
That's our second target. Uh, we got more
targets like HR.hackerinthehouse.com. There
are some internal user machines, uh, like
a windows machine, which you are going to
hack.
So there is a whole entire, you know, enterprise
level architecture. Right? Um, any doubts
on that, that point? Like if you don't understand
what a subdomain is or something, I guess
you won't understand that. Yeah. Yeah. So
let me quickly open a paint and explain you
how this, this works. For example, this is
our company. Okay. Now in this company, there
are of course, a lot of, um, you know, there
will be a lot of, what do you say? There'll
be a lot of, uh, departments or actually sections.
We call them zones. Okay. So let's say this
is zone one. This is zone two. This is zone
three. Let's keep it that two zone three.
We will add more zones later in the course
as well. So these zones where exactly these
are, this is DMZ. Yeah. There you go. There's
DMZ. So this is internal. Okay. So this is
your internal zone. And let's say, this is
management.
Alright. Alright. So we got a company which
has been divided into multiple zones and that's
how any enterprise system works. Okay. So
you, are a hacker who is, let's say, uh, right
over here. Let's say this is your computer.
And I don't know why things are working quite
good, but anyways, um, yeah, so let's say
you got an IP address or whatever. Let's say
10.2.1 Dot then, whatever IP you got, that
is your personal IP in, in your computer.
That is your IP address. Now let's say this
company has got some IP address. Let's say
there is some IP address. Uh, we don't know
what that IP is, so they will give you a VPN
connection. Normally that is you pen test.
They always give you a VPN connection so that
you can be in their network zones. Okay. That
is, that is one of the ways they will give
you a VPN using this.
You will get an IP address, let's say 10.0.10.9.
Again, let's say you will get this address.
And the, this DMZ has that same address. Okay.
The same range, let's say 10,.0.10.0/ 24.
So any kind of IP in that specific unit. So
that is what they're going to give you so
that your machine is, is going to get into
the same zone. That is how it works. You need
to be in the same IP address zone to even
communicate with the machine. If you're not
in the same zone, you cannot communicate.
Is that making sense?
Ya making sense There are two kinds of IPs
there is a public IP and a private IP. So
when you say an IP, like, I'm sorry, when
you say an IP like 192, or if an IP is like
172 or an IP is like 10, okay. These are private
IPS. These are not connected to internet.
They, they, they do not. You know, there is
no matter if they're connected or not connected.
These are private. So normally what happens,
what happens when you connect to the internet?
There is internet, there is a router. And
then with that router, there are a lot of
computers connected in between. There can
be switches, hubs, etc,etc. But there is internet.
There is a router with that. router machines
are connected that router has a public IP.
Only the router has a public IP, and that
router will give a private IP to all the machines.
So you want a wifi, wifi hotspot in your home
or whatever, that, that hotspot, that wifi
that has a public IP, and that is going to
assign every one of your computer phones,
whatever it is connected to that a private
ID. Okay. Now that is how it works. So if
I show you, this is the command from NFI,
just say, IP can say, you can see that I have
a router, which has a wifi address, which
is a IP address, internal IP of 1921680.1.
That is routers internal IP. And this, this
router is giving my computer and IP address
of 1921680.112. And similarly, my phone is
having the IP address of 1921680.230 something.
That is, that is how it works. So this is
the range 1921680. something.
Okay. That is the range. This is the last
octave, which is the IP address, specific
IP for this. And this complete is the IP of
the computer. That is how IP is work and the
public IP. If I go ahead and go on Google,
and let's say, what is my IP now this 45.125.602.15.
This is my public IP. This IP is not for my
computer. This for my router, that router
is having the IP. Every device connected with
that router will have the same IP, okay. That
is how public and private works. So this in
this diagram, when you say a DMZ and he said,
this DMZ, normally a DMZ is a demilitarized
zone at DMZ is the area where a company will
put those application servers, websites, which
are on a public IP as well as on a private
IP.
So you, got a website as a company, you've
got a website, you need a web server. You
will put that web server in a DMZ area. That
DMZ area is publicly connectable that DMZ
area is the only area that will have IP addresses,
which are public Is that making sense? Are
we getting it? So if we can just go ahead
and say, yep. If I just go ahead and say sagarbansal.com,
this IP address 10424121220. This, this specific
IP address is a public IP. This IP address
is the IP of my server, which is running sagarbansal.com.
And that is in the DMZ area and all the other
computers we have in our company. So, you
know, for staff and all they are, of course,
in a internal area, restricted area, but just
not publicly available, there, there will
be some other servers or some firewalls, at
least some firewalls, which will be blocking
public access.
So, you know, people cannot connect with those
computers normally directly, okay. But in
a DMZ, anyone can go ahead and connect with
the machine because this is public IP. And
everyone knows this IP, you know, just by
doing a thing, you can find it and everyone
can connect with it because that's the purpose.
I mean, if, if no one can connect with a website,
what's the purpose of a website. That's why
that's publicly routable. So normally what
we do is let's say there's a machine in the
management area, or let's make it simple.
Let's say there is a machine here in internal
area. So, and there's a server web server,
then this DMZ, and let's say, we want to attack
this machine in the internal. We cannot directly
do it because our IP ranges are different.
So what we can do, we can have this DMZ machine
and be in that range. Then use that range
as a pivot, we call that a pivot, okay. Use
that machine as a pivot and then hack into
the internal network. So that is how we hack
a server. We use it's IP, address, route the
network from that to another machine. So we
need, we can do multiple ranges by doing that.
Um, any doubts there? I know that was a little
confusing, that pivot stuff, but when we will
do practical you come to light, but still
any doubt in the concept.
Okay, that's fine. That's that's clear so
far. So good. Right? So that is how any enterprise
network works. That's how we, that's how we
pen test. Now let's talk about the project
itself. You got these machines. Um, we are
assuming that this beta.hackerinthehouse is
in the DMZ area. This is a, this is a web
server. Okay. This media.hackerinthehouse
is in a production zone. So there's a DMZ
zone. There is a production zone. There is
an internal zone. There is a management, there
are four zones. So this isn't the, this isn't
the, what do you say beta.hackerinthehouse?
This one isn't the DMZ. And this was, uh,
this one is in the production zone. Now let
me show you my configurations here.
So you can see, I got some more machines,
ignored them. Uh, there's a pen test. The
machine, there is a beta machine. This beta
machine is in the DMZ. And then there is a
media machine. This media machine is in the
production, uh, production zone. Now what
these zones are, if we go to preferences and
network. Yep. There's the network. You can
see, we have created three zones and I like
to give them the name as a range. So range
100, 148, 155 is the three ranges at the moment.
Um, if I open them, you can see the IP address
in this range are 10.0.100.0/24, which means
any IP will start from 10.0.100. Okay. Similarly
in the second range, 10,.0.148 Similarly in
third range, 10.0.115. That is how the IPs
are going to start. Um, am sorry sagar, can
you just backtrack that just one more time
for me please? Right. If I go to file preferences
and then network, we have created three networks
three subnets, basically. Uh, the first one
is range 100 If I open that, you can see that
the name which I have given range 100. Uh,
the networks, Id is 10.0.100.0/24, which basically
means any machine in this zone will have the
IP address of 10.0.100./ you know, something.
So just to give you an example, let me power
this machine on. And then you can see
if I power this machine on.
Um, just one quick question. So are, are,
are all these ranges, um, accessible for all
the virtual machines or
any machine, which is in that specific range
is going to be, you know, in that network.
Oh, and what I meant is the virtual box has
all those ranges No you need to create them.
Got it. I think what he's saying finally is
you can give it an adapter that belongs to
any of the them, Yes. So that is flexible.
Right? Got it.
I have made this machine. This is machine
numbers 001 and you can see the IP address
there. Um, the IP address in the fourth line,
it is 10.0.100.10 right? That is the IP because
this machine is in that range in the range
of hundreds. Also, this machine is having
two network cards. The second one is 10.0.148.111
which is also in the range of 148. If I show
you this machine, media machine,
[inaudible]
almost done. This machine is in the range
of 48, 148. Plus this is having a third sub
net, which is one, uh, 115 I think we got
a mistake here. It needs to be 155. Anyways.
I'll fix it. I'll fix it later, but 115 Okay.
So here you go. These are two machines and
you can see, so 10.0.100,10.0.148. And 10.0.115
These are the three subnets we got and this,
this whole, uh, this whole enterprise at the
moment now how to create them, you go to file.
You go to preferences. You go to network and
you click on this plus button and it'll make
a Nat network Double click here you can give
it any name. So let me give range115 which
I think I forgot to create.
And here you can give CIDR. I just like to
change this to whenever I want. So 10.0. something,
um, let's say 115, don't do a slash 24. Um,
that is going to be actually a error and you
can enable the DSTP. That's really fine. This
will help to get automatic IPS. That's not
going to hurt. You can just keep that support.
IPv6. Really? Doesn't matter. If you want
to have IPv6 testing, you can hit that. I
want to just you at this level, um, just go
ahead and click on. Okay. And now you got
another range. 115. Okay. And how to I assign
this? Let me turn off the machine. First of
all, having a whistling noise. Everybody else
had it.
Yeah. I forgot what's wrong then. That's not
what it is that you can hear it. I mean, I
still don't understand it. I don't think it's
from you. It's from over here. Okay, cool.
Right. So if I go to settings of this machine
and if I go to network, then you can see we
have in Nat network adapter and in nat netwrok
you can choose all these different ranges
which we have created again. Is that making
sense now? Yes. Yes it does. So here we got
this 115 All right, cool. So now this machine
is in 148 and 115. This machine is in 100
and 148. So that is how, uh, the, the enterprise
is going on at the moment. Right? So our pen
tester machine that is in the bridge adapter,
which basically means it's connected to your
router, not the company's network, it's in
your network, your router plus adapter two
is on range, 100 now why range, 100
We assume that range 100 is a public range.
It is a DMZ area. Okay? Uh, that is what we
are assuming over second case. Let us assume
range a hundred is a VPN connection. So the
company has given you a VPN connection. You
are also in the same range of that DMZ area.
Okay? That is what you have to do. You, you
need to be in, in the range of at least first
machine, which you were gonna have, other
ranges. They don't matter. You can always
pivot so you can use the range of the machine
itself. You can pivot, but the first needs
to be in the same range. So that's why you
need an adapter. We are only having 100. There
is no other adapter here. You only have 100,
but we will be able to hack into 148, 115,155,
all of them. But at the moment we are only
in 100. So two adapters, one is built withit,
which is directly connected to my wifi to
get me internet. Another one is a Nat network
and range 100. Again, that, that is how the
architecture is going to look like. That is
how it works. Um, any questions there?
[inaudible]
Nope. All right. Let's get started. Then you
can always, you know, follow up later with
the recording. Of course there is no point
to follow up right now because that doesn't
make any sense.
So we are going to practice today on the First
machine, which is 001 beta server, beta server
is a website, and we going to be going to
try to hack it and practice. So this is the
Kali Linux there are two accounts on each
machine. Yes. Sagar we haven't, um, I think
you instructed me not to have these installed
so we didn't install it. We just downloaded
them. Right. I'm just saying that you should
be doing that after the lecture, because a
lot of time and that's going to be a lot of
time with everyone. Isn't it?
Okay.
Got it. Makes sense. I'll be giving the recording.
Of course. Okay. Makes sense. And if there
is some doubt, we can always discuss tomorrow
in tommorrow class or after the class I'm
free. I mean, I'm really free. You guys can
call me, No , makes sense, man. Makes sense.
Continue please. So there are two accounts.
The first, the, the non-root account is Kali
Kali, the root account as a root and licensed
to pen test as the password. So password is
licensed to pentest account is root I'm just
logging in as Kali. All right. And that doesn't
work. So, yep. There you go. So that is Kali
and you go full screen. You don't need the
browser. Yep. So this is our Kali Linux And
I'm going to show you the IP address here.
Oops. I have config and that doesn't work
because we are not root. So I'll make a root
license to pen test config. Excuse me,
[inaudible]
how what's going on. Why I've config is not
working
Yeah, now, it works. Okay. So you can see,
we got an IP address. 192.1680.109, which
is coming from my router. This has nothing
to do with the hacker in the house company.
This is my local IP. We also have another
IP which is 10.0.100.9 which is the IP address.
That is same in the same range of the DMZ
area. The DMZ machine, the beta.hackerinthehouse
machine is also in the same network. So that
is how this is working at the moment. Now
let us get started. hacking it first step
is always footprinting information gathering,
blah, blah, blah. Everyone knows that there
are two kinds of, uh, you know, we call that
reconnaissance. By the way, there are two
kind of reconnaissance. There is a passive,
and there's active what happens in passive
is that you directly do not interact with
the target. So, you know, just to give you
an example very quick, and I'll not take a
lot of time here. Um, just as an example,
you may go ahead and, um, you know, you may
go ahead and go on something like built with,
okay. And you may go ahead and go over there
and maybe you can just go ahead and put a
IP, address a URL and go ahead and try to
find something when you are doing that. So
for example, hacker in the house.com. Now,
when you do that, you are interacting with
the target, okay. Built which is a tool, but
you are interacting with the target. You use
the tool, you used it to interact with the
target. This is an active reconnaissance part.
You are actively interacting with the target,
but if you just go on Google and you know
that Google is a search engine, it has scrolled
the things itself. And now here you go ahead
and try hackerinthehouse and whatever you
get here. So we got to see these, by the way,
whenever you get here, this is passive information.
You did not interact with the target itself,
but if you are using a tool you're talking
to the target, you're scanning it.
You're asking it questions. That is direct
interaction that is active reconnaissance.
If you are using a search engine, a database,
whatever that already has the information,
you're just trying to retrieve that information
publicly available information is the passive
reconnaissance. Let us assume we will ignore
the passive information part here and this
whole topic, because normally when you're
working professionally with companies, they
will provide you a scope of work. You know,
you will get a scope of work that scope of
work, a work statement that will have a lot
of information about the tasks. Those tasks
are what you have to do, and you normally
don't need to do passive information gathering
Uh, but if you are interested, I got a video
on that. I'll send you how to do passive information,
but let's be creative. Let's start with active
part, which is actually the main thing which
we are going to do. So let us assume our mission
is to hack a website, a website, or a web
server, which is beta.hackerInthehouse. That's
our mission. How do we do that? Very first
thing always get the technology profile of
the target. So we've got beta. Let me become
pseudo.
Yeah, well let's, let's go ahead and say beta.hackerinthehouse.com.
That's the website. That is our target. First
thing always get the technology profile and
there's a very cool tool called whatweb you
use. Once you get the technology profile of
the website. Again, it will come up with all
the information. Here you go. The information
you have here is it is running a apache web
server. It is running. It is having a HTML5.
It is running ubuntu Linux Apache version
is this IP address is this, it is having jquery
with the version of this. It is running WordPress
with this version is running PHP with this
version. Um, I don't see any other information
there. Yup. PHP 5.5 0.9. That's all. This
is the technology profile of the website.
And just by this, you know, that it is, there
are two options.
There is WordPress and PHP, which an Apache,
which can be your target three options. You've
got WordPress, we've got PHP, you've got Apache
easiest. One let's say is what this, why this
comes with experience. But WordPress, if anyone
of, you know, what is wordpress btw, my website
is WordPress , right? So what is WordPress
is a content management system, CMS, okay.
WordPress is used to create websites to create,
to manage content. Basically it's a platform
which we use to manage the, the, you know,
uh, websites or any kind of data. It's a CMS.
And there are two kinds of, uh, websites or
web apps. There are always a CMS websites,
or there are custom coded websites. And there
is a 70% chance that your target will be a
CMS, popular CMS are WordPress ,Joomla or
Drupal open CMS. These are, these are some
popular ones.
Every, every one of those CMS has a tool specific
tool dedicated to them. Wordpress has a tool
called WAPscan Joomla has a tool called joomscan
can Drupal has a tool called drupscan. Okay.
Every tool has got a scanning tool. Every,
every CMS has got a scanning tool in case
this is a custom coded website. You got other
tools like Actionetics, okay? Or you got nesses,
you got aqualus. So there are, you know, very
expensive tools. Um, but they are general
tools, which you can use on any kind of thing.
You can use them on CMS, or you can use them
on custom coded sites, but for CMS, you got
specific tools as well. One of them is WAP
scan, which is for WordPress or a PHP. You
follow the normal network pentesting or a
normal process. Uh, what is that process?
You have a version number.
So you got a version number go on google research
about this version. Try to find a vulnerability.
If you find it when vulnerability in your
research, then find a exploit. If you find
an exploit, try it. If that exploit works.
Congratulations. If that exploit doesn't work,
try to find another one do the research again.
If you don't find anything in your report
mentioned that I did this, I did that. I did
this. Your system is secure. It can not be,
hacked just mentioned it. You know, that's,
that's what a report is. A report is it doesn't
means that you have to hack it and report
is you just have to do a pen test and tell
us that it is safe or not. And if it is safe,
then mentioned it,it is safe, but show your
due diligence show that you have done the
work show.
That proper screenshots that you have tried,
this, that this, and still, this is not hackable.
That's why I'm saying it is safe. You have
to justify that, uh, for the moment let's
ignore this and this Apache and PHP, because
their process is little different. We are
right now focusing on hacking CMS. Okay? So
the whole class is all about hacking a CMS.
Now, when you have, this is the, uh, this
is the information gathering phase. We got
the information. This is running this, this,
this, oops, let me cancel that. Yep. We got
the information. This is running WordPress.
This is running a ubuntu PHP Apache. Now let's
select that. We are going to test the CMS.
We are going to test the WordPress. What next?
Go on. google find a tools. So you can go
and Google and find a tool. And I mean, it's
very simple.
You need to learn how to Google, because even
if you talk about the LPT exam, or if you
talk about the real life, you need to learn
how to use Google. So just say how to test
WordPress or how to pen test WordPress. That's
a better, that's a better, uh, option, right?
How to pentest WordPress? You've got a lot
of videos. You can watch any of them. Uh,
but they will, of course mentioned that WAP
scan tool is there in this, in this post.
I'm quite sure you, here you go. The frist
tool is WAP scan. They have given you all
the syntax and you can follow this. Now I'm
going to show you how to do that. So let's
clear the screen let's use WAP scan-help and
always before using, before using anything,
make sure you learn how to use help WAP scan-h.
And this is the help menu. So they use it,
always read the usage, which says.
Would be scan space options. Now, what are
the options? The first option is URL. Then
just come down very down. There are some options
to brute force and here throttling. So you
are not, you are not because on a real internet
server, there will be firewalls which will
block you. So you may want to throttle the
speed of your attack or any kind of scan or
detection mode. If there is a firewall or
something or Passover or whatever, you can,
you can handle that. The main thing I want
to show you is an enumerate. So -e, that is
what I'm finding enumerate. So you can enumerate
a lot of information. Enumerate means you
will ask some questions or you will try to
gather some data from the target. Now, what
kind of data we can gather? We can find vulnerable
plugins or all plugins.
Now, what is plugin? Plugin is the softwares
which we install on WordPress. Wordpress is
like your windows. You got windows 10. That
is like your WordPress. Now you install a
lot of software on that to make it usable.
That is the plugin. That is how WordPress
works for websites. So popular plugins, vulnerable
themes that you can give teams to it to style
it. Then all themes, all right, popular teams
some other things like configuration backups,
etc user IDs. So you can find a user's real
usernames. That is what you can find and media
files. That is what you can find. These are
all the things you can find. Okay. So let's
go ahead and, and do it. Let's go ahead and
say, we will find -e and vulnerable themes
and when vulnerable l plugins, okay vulnerable
plugins vulnerable themes VP VT, let's go
ahead and clear the screen WP scan --URL because
it was written here, beta.hackerinthehouse.com
I make correct that -e. Now what we are going
to enumerate vulnerable themes. And vulnerable
plugins WP, WT presenter, let's wait for the
magic to happen.
And it's going to start giving us a lot of
information. It has finished. Let's go ahead
and start from the scratch Information. Number
1, interesting finding this website is running
this, this, this, we actually already know
that this is running apache & PHP due to wordweb,
but it is giving you the information. Information
number 2, direct access found, which is XML
RPC. Now XML RPC is an interface which can
be used to talk to the website, you know,
using command line. Again, that is, that is
a interface or using web queries. So you don't
need to go ahead and log into the website,
give your password, blah, blah, blah, and
then go to the dashboard and click there and
click there and write the code. You don't
have to do that. You can just use XML, RPC
interface to directly communicate with the
website over the command line or whatever.
Now, th th this is going to this is going
to help to brute force the website. You can
bruteforce, or this is going to help you to
give commands to the website, but you need
the proper password. Of course, it's one of
the important things. If there is XML, RPC
its going to help you. It's not a vulnerability,
but it's going to help you. Read me. File
is present. So read me, we'll have different
information like diversion information, etc,
but it will automatically give them version
information. So we don't really need that.
It's also saying that upload directory has
listing enabled, which is quite not good.
If I open this open link, you can see we got,
all the uploads. So you can basically check
the upload file here. 2020, let's say 03.
We don't have anything.02.
We don't have any things 01. Yep. We got some
images there. If I open this, we got a photograph.
There uploads directory is open. So website
data can be easily seen from the upload directory.
And this is not very good practice. This is
a vulnerability. We call it a information
disclosure. In case, in case this, this was
a sensitive data, and I will say, this is
a sensitive data, because you know, you, you
may be uploading some private data here and
that is available. So you have to see what
kind of data is there. If you find some sensitive
data, you will say this vulnerability is high,
you will, you will give it a risk rating of
high. Okay. It is risk rating of high and
saying sensitive data disclosure. That is
your vulnerability title. The risk rating
is high .In this case, this is not high.
You can see there is just two locals , two
local files. I don't, I don't see anything
else here. There are two local files in 2019
as well. I just see some images by the way,
like there is nothing else. These are simple
images, right? So this is not sensitive data
for me. So here I can keep it into low or
medium. Okay. I can say directory listing
enabled, or I can say information disclosure,
okay. This is what I can give the title. Not
sensitive information, but the saying information
disclosure, because this is not that not that
sensitive. And you can, you can give it a
risk rating of low or medium. So depends what
kind of data you get, but low or medium in
case you get some sensitive data like files,
you know, which for example, many, many people
will sell paid courses, okay.
Paid videos or paid files, PDFs, etc, books.
They will keep them in the uploads folder
of the WordPress. And that folder is public.
So as a hacker, I can just go ahead, open
the upload folder, download the content from
there and never pay them anything. I don't
have to purchase it because I can open that
up and get from the folder. So at that point,
because it is harming the business, it becomes
sensitive data. And then it is in the critical
or high. And that is how you adjust the risk
rating of this. Any doubts there?
No, it makes sense. Alright. Did you download
my video? Which one? Did you go to my website
and download my videos? No, I tried downloading
that actually. Oh, you did? Okay. Let me know.
Let me know what you get out of it. Oh yeah,
yeah. Oh gosh. All right. Next thing directory
to this thing, we got a vulnerability there.
Another one, a WAP Cron, reilly? I mean, this
WAP cron what exactly it is. Basically it's
a Cron job. So you can actually read this,
these or they say you can read these issues
and I'm quite not sure what this is, because
see, every, every website will have a different
finding and you cannot remember all of them.
You just need to go ahead and read the references
to know what exactly this is. And I think
this is a cron job, something so possibly
you can read it and you can find what it is,
but this is not a vulnerability.
This is just information, because if it is
a vulnerability, it will be a minus sign here
in the red color. This is a plus. This is
just a information. So you can read about
it. It may be something you can use later.
Wordpress version 5.1.4, you got one thing
there. And this is according to this website,
this is the latest release of this. So this
is a safe version. If, if this was vulnerable,
it will show here itself that this is, this
version vulnerable. You can attack it. Here
is a possible exploit on the internet, but
it is not. Theme is Hestia version is this
again? If the theme was vulnerable, it will
show you here. It will tell you that this
is vulnerable You should go ahead and do something
else. And similar thing for everything. It
Found some URLs there. That's fine. It may
find some plugins. It will tell you that the
plugin is vulnerale Now that that is what
we got. We did not got any vulnerable. You
know, we did not get any one vulnerale plugin,
no plugin found. We did not got ay vulnerable
theme, not theme found. Basically this website
is safe. Okay. This website is safe. That
is the conclusion still. We are going to hack
it. I will show you how to do that. But the
conclusion that is website is safe, just to
show you Another website. And I'm not sure
if I can scan my website, but let me try to
do that. I have some plugins which are not
updated from last two days. So let me just
check that. I'm not sure that we can scan
my website, but
Huh.
Okay. Let's wait. And this is the difference.
This is a real website on the real internet.
It's taking a lot of time. That was a virtual
machine that began like in one second, right?
This is a real website it's taking time and
it will take time. See, it's taking
So much long to find the vulnerable themes
and plugins. No plugins found vulnerability.
That's fine. But anyways, let's see.
Almost done. There you go. So in my website
also, it is completely safe and I was not
expecting this, but I think I fixed it yesterday.
There were two plugins which are outdated,
so that's fine. Maybe they are not vulnerable.
They are just outdated. You can see, in my
case, you can see, there are some other things.
There is no XML, RPC. Yeah. You cannot see
there is extending XML, RPC finding further,
you might see that there is an interesting
entry, which says CloudFlare, what is CloudFlare?
Cloudflare is a CDN, eh, you know, a content
delivery network. It helps you to speed up
the website. It's a service which helps you
to increase the speed. There is, there are
must use plugins. So the most popular plugins,
but that kind of thing, there are plugins,
which I'm using. There is the team called
ocean WP in, in the previous one, there was
a team called Hastia.
In my case, it is the ocean and nothing else.
It cannot find anything else. That's maybe
because of my firewall or something, Atleast,
I'm using a lot of plugins, like 50, 60 of
them, but it cannot identify them. Due to
firewalls or some reason. But the bottom line
is if there is a vulnerability, there is a
great chance. It will show you here. I mean,
not every website will have a firewall. Like
at least I would say 50% of the websites don't
have a firewall, a bigger, Wordpress websites
because people don't even know how to use
a firewall. Okay. They don't know. Even in
the enterprise networks, if they do have a
firewall, they will not be well configured.
And I have seen that every time. And that's
what we are testing. I mean, if it is well
configured, that's fine.
It is, it is safe. It has not been configured.
That's what we need to test. So that's the
result. Now, coming back to the previous scan
now coming back to the previous scan, which
is this one. So in this case, we found that
there is no vulnerable plugin, there is vulnerable
theme, which basically means the website is
safe. Okay. That's one of the point of views.
The last thing before leaving a website or
a target is brute force. Today, we are talking
all about bruteforce, by the way, We're talking
about how to brute force a CMS. That is the
whole lecture. We have a CMS, we will brute
force. What is brute forcing anyone
crack using any possible combination of letters,
words or characters. All right. And what is
a dictionary?Same thing, except this time
you only use the dictionary words, publication
case, Right
So what do you think is, is a better option
in case of a website? Should we be using bruteforcing
or a dictionary? You're definitely a brute
force. Sorry, go ahead. Okay. Do you want
to say something Bravo? Oh yeah. I was, I
was thinking it was dictionary. A better one.
Yeah. Bruteforcing It take longer, but brute
force are have more options. Right. Okay.
All right. So let me explain that. Let me
explain that, how this works. Udefinitely
brute forcing has got hundred percent chance
basically because in bruteforcing you're trying
every single password, zero one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, then
a to Z, then combinations, letter characters.
You're trying, literally you're trying every
single password in this world. The problem
is time in a pentest. You had like how much
like the, the maximum length of pen tests,
which I have done in my life was two months.
I guess, 60 days you cannot group force a
website with a password of 20 characters.
That's, that's what enterprises are going
to use like 12, 12, 20, 15. Those are things
long passwords. You cannot brute force those
passwords with a, within a 20, within a two
months time, it can take two years. And in
two years, someone will change it. You know,
there is a policy of changing the password
every 15 days. So when you, when you have
an offline cracking, so there are two kinds
of cracking. You got you got a hash or something.
And you're trying to crack that offline. You
know, you got, you got a password which is
encrypted, and then you are trying to crack
it offline. You use brute force, then you're
doing it over the web. You always try to think
about the time limits. Okay. And it is practically
impossible to break a 15 character password
in a, within a year, actually.
Okay. That is what you have to think. And
you will, of course get blocked. So someone
will block you because you're trying millions
of requests. Someone will notice you. That
is the time when we use a dictionary because
in a dictionary we are using low amount of
words. Of course, brute force has a hundred
percent success that will, of course break
the password. That's not a doubt regardless
of the time. But when we say there is a time
we have to manage the risk, there is a risk
that we will not find the password in the
dictionary. And there is a risk that someone
will change the password due to the time limit
in the Brute force. First Dictornary, we will
not use the password brute force. Someone
will change the password. Those are the two
things you have to evaluate. Which one do
you care about in, in, in the LPD exam or
in a normal three, four days or a week pen
test of course, brute forcing is not at all.
An option. LPD is like six hours. You are
only 6 hours to have this machine at this
kind of machine. Of course you cannot go ahead
and do brute forcing. So we go to the dictionary.
Does that make sense now? Yep. It makes perfect
sense. Right? So the, the, you know, the what
do you say if we go ahead and search WP-,
the syntax is quite similar. You can find
out a brute force and the syntax. The one
which I see right now is password username.
So you can give a password attack lists, or
you can give a password list and you can give
a user's list. Okay? So that's P for single
password on a left, that's U for a single
user in more or less, that is how it works.
You can do a brute force. So there, there
are the options here, maximum passwords, blah,
blah, blah. There must be an option for brute
forcing as well. So you can do that. That's
another, that's another day work Today. Let's
talk about how to do a dictionary attack.
We've got -b that's you two options. Remember
them? That's U thats it. The problem is we
don't know the username. We don't know the
password. Let's go ahead and try to find the
username. And username is very easy. Dash
-u and enumerate the username, and it is very
successful. It will come up with a user name.
Here you go, users, identify. There are two
users. First as admin. Second is developer.
Let me show this on another terminal on my
website. I'm quite sure it will find it there
as well. So that's it. Let me scan the url,
sagarbansal. Let me do one thing instead of
try on another website of mine. I think this
is not that secure. Let's say that a Am trying
my another website over here. I it seem not
updated. Do you wanna update ?thats updated?
Okay.
And we got an, error, we got error why. Permission
denied. Oh, we are not root. I do hope everyone
knew how to become root, right? Yeah. It was
a sudo[inaudible] I usually type it sudo.
So yeah. So when you type sudo, SU, which
is pseudo switch user, it will default by
default switch. You to the root, but for example,
if you want to switch to another user like
Paul, then you will use sudo su-paul So if
you specify username, would you do that? If
you don't, it will be by default. Okay. Got
it.
Okay. Very quickly. WP scan that, URL. My,
run.com, disclaimer, I don't own this website.
I'm the CISO of the company so I can do whatever
I want. It's a security risk. You need to
give that disclaimer, tomorrow. What happens.
Okay. All right. So keep that in background,
but let's say we got the usernames admin developer
now does being creative here. Of course, developers
are the people who do the mistake. Isn't it?
Developers are the people who will always
use weak password. They will do mistakes in
coding. So if you can, of course, private,
both of them, just for the example, just telling
you as a practical life scenario. And if you
have time, you can try both of them. But if
you have only one to choose, you will always
try to go with developer. Now admin account
is of course going to have more privileges,
but there is a greater chance that you will
get some access in developer.
And once you have access, you can then maybe
ask your client in real life. You can ask
your client that listen, we had only two days,
you were able to get access to developer.
You gave us two more days. We can try to get
access to admin as well. You get some liverages
there, right? If you try directly on a hard
target, maybe you will not get anything. Client
will think you don't know anything. You're
not good. Your reputation gets damaged. So
when you're doing a practical pen test professional
test, always try to first target the weak
targets. And as a admin and developer, I will
always choose a developer. So let's go ahead
and choose developer as a username. We need
passwords, where are the passwords. Paul,
you want to say something? There are the passwords.
I'm sorry. What's the question you say? What
are the passwords? The where are the passwords.
Which passwords will they try? Where is the
list. Oh, password. Oh, I see. Shadow nobody.
So see that's P no, no, no. I'm asking about
a password list because we need a password
code. Just like our code, right? So one of
them is dark cord. One of them is Rockfield
or TXT. There are popular lists on internet.
The problem with those lists is if I show
you a locate rockfield, you got a list there.
That is the list. So let me copy this list.
I'm copying this to form a Kali username,
desktop. I just copied that there. Let me
open it. Yup. Here is the list. Let me extract
that. Oh, alright. So I'm just going to extract
it. Tar-Xf a rock to own Kali desktop and
what it is.
And it says it's affiliated errors skipping
that better. Okay. That's right. Okay. permissions
problem. Yep. Let's try it manually. And just
drag and drop. There you go. We got the word
list. Let me quickly move to that same folder.
Kali desktop, basic question. Tar -xf that
command does what exactly to extract X in
extract F I forgot what is F so you can check
this index. I was just trying to extract that
file. I did not add it for some reason. Not
sure why extract and it's like zipping, right?
Yeah. So I just did it manually right now.
I just, I just opened the zip here and I just
got it. Got it. Okay.
Okay. We got this file.TXT. Let's see what
WC, R O Rocky, that xd that's entered. The
problem is this in these kind of word lists,
there are how many? 14,344,992 pass it. 14
million passwords to write 14 million passwords.
Let's say there is a throttle on the website.
You can only try a pass. Like you can only
try five passwords, and then you have to wait
for five minutes. Let's let that kind of thing
is there. It's going to date years. It's going
to take again years. So that's again, the
problem you need to come up with a great word
list. Now these are good word lists. Of course
you can use them, but when it's a professional
test, and if there is a throttle, you always
want to use a custom word list. Okay? No doubt.
You can try it, but it's all about risk management.
You need to check your risk for a pen testing
purpose. Do you have that much time to do
it or not? Normally you will have that much
time. You can use rockthing. So Rocky is a,
is a good list. The, the benefit of rock tool,
is they have, you know, they have put the
passwords in order. So the most common password
is on the top. The least common password is
on the bottom. So you are always trying best
passwords first. And then you're moving to
lower, low complexity and low success passwords.
So high success chances are in this starting.
That's why rocky can be great deal. I'm not
going to use Roku because I'm quite sure that
will never work because I have designed the
machine at the end. I know that is not gonna
work. So it will waste our time.
But I'm just going to show you how to create
a custom list, maybe in a LPT exam or in real
life, whatever you will get the list. So your
client may tell you that we want you to try
to brute force the password. This is a list
of passwords. You can try this. This can be
your, this can be your scope of work. Yeah.
in LPT exam, they can tell you that use this
list or that list. You can use the list. If
you do not get success, then try rocku. You
Roku is your last attempt. You never do brute
force in the LPT exam. But if you are having
like if you're failing with the list, which
they are providing as the client, if you are
feeling that with that, try with rocku as
your last attempt and you will do it.
You are you know, you start the brute first
and you keep it aside and do another other
work. You don't just, you know, sit on that
and wait for it. You just do other work it
until it is brute first. So just to show you
how to create a custom list, anyone how to
create custom lists, start a text file. Okay.
I'll come on that. Give me a minute. So here,
by the way, in mytutorial, we got a username.
It was either is my capital T. My tutorialrack,
I get the username. That is how you can get
usernames on a WordPress by the -u. So that's
the userspace. You enumerates users now. Yeah.
What you're saying again? Sorry. Uif I were
to create a custom list, I would create a
basic text file and I will try to recon and
figure out what the target might possibly
use.
So I can have a high probability of cracking
it. Right. That's absolutely great. You just
get the next while and you try to recon the
words, you know, related words, and then get
them over there. Now tell me you got like
two hours, only two hours to crack a website.
What is your best shot to get those, those
recon thing done? How can you do that? Recon?
Oh, social media. That's a big one. I think
if I know whats great, but let's say you don't
know anything about company. There is no social
media profile. Could you try and build like
a web scraper to kind of go through employees
for the company, see their social media accounts
and then try and get a password that way.
Yeah. I mean, all of these are valid option,
but I'm just saying, let us assume this is
a beta website, right?
This is a beta website. This is not public.
Let's say the company is not even started.
That is just a project, a test project. You
have to do it. Then what? Top known default
passwords. Yeah. I mean, they top known are
in the Roku. You, so we will use that as the
last resource. But before that, there is one
thing that you can do. Let me tell you that
you can go on live website and you can take,
I mean, this is a beta website, but this is
a website. You can go on that website and
take the words from that website itself.
I mean, instead of going on Google and trying
to find, because Google will only get data
when it is publicly available for everyone,
but you got a website that is private to you,
or you can go on their website and find the
word. So basically use words that the company
uses on the website. Yep. I mean, just to
just, you know, you can just because we are
targeting a developer account, just say, you
go to these are password in house.com. We've
got a website here. Right? We got works, hacker
house license. We got, we got different, different
words. You know, some complex words there,
they got different words, their phone number,
you know, you have a phone number there, address,
maybe you got address there. You can use all
of these words, isn't it.
You make a good point. They, one of my one
of our clients uses our wifi password is the
part of it is the building number. Yeah. A
lot of people we'll use phone numbers. A lot
of people use this kind of stuff. So that's
your first shot because I'm just saying you
use this because how many words will be there
on the website? Let's say we have a, we say
that we will use at 12 to 20 characters stuff.
How many words will be there? They'll be like
10 words, 12 words, 20 words, a hundred words,
a hundred passwords. How much time will it
take to test them? That's the first shot you
should be taking, right? That's your first
shot.
Is that making sense? Yup. Right now you can
do that. The problem is if you manually go
ahead and test all the pages of the websites,
that's going to take a lot of time. There
is something called cewl, okay. CEWL, which
you can use, you can say, say -help? And these
are all the options. And I say, well, we'll
do the work for you. You can give minimum
length and maximum length of words. You can
tell it how much depth you want to go despite
her. So it will basically go to two levels.
For example, beta.hackerInthehouse.com. That's
the first level beta.hackerInthehouse.com
slash uploads. That's the second level. So
anything on that file or that page, that is
how levels work. If there was level three,
then beta.Hackerinthehouse.Com/uploads/2020.
So those lashes different, different, multiple
nested pages, they are getting levels.
So default is level two here. Let's just go
ahead and use it. Just to show you clear the
screen. CEWL-M, let's, let's keep the default
depth level as to only minimum minimum words.
Let's say 12 maximum. Maximum words, let's
say 20 the length which we think the password
can be, of course, no company will use less
than 12. There's a rare case. Someone will
use more than 20. That's why 1220 is my best
shot personally. Then just give the URL, beta.hackerInthehouse.com
center. Here you go. You add these words.
How many words are these it starting here?
It's ending here. Yeah. This one line. You
can, you can always try this list. Maybe you
will need a password. You see this kind of
words. They can be password, these kind of
words. They can be passwords. So just go ahead
and try it. Try that. That's that's one of
the best shots you can do. I'll just go ahead
and create a file. Okay. I just created a
file there. Let's save it. Okay.
Now we just got 35 passwords. How much time
it will take to, you know, try these passwords
35 passwords. Won't take a lot of time. We
can always try that. That's one of the ways
I'm showing you, you know, you create a customer
list with the website words and you try. It
may work. It may not work really depends,
but that's one of the ways in the exam. Always
try this once. If you're a great team person,
just try this before this as well, you know,
even before this, you try default passwords,
admin, admin, Capital A admin, capital admin,
you know, first letter uppercase admin password,
user password, just try 2-3 default combinations.
If they don't work, try a custom list of password
from thew ebsite. If that doesn't work try
dock docu, that is the, that is the level
you want to try it, right?
Quick question. So when you typed in the CEWL
and then you go -M -1220, and then you put
the URL. So it automatically searches that
website and extracts words. Yes. Okay. Got
it So we've got a word list. Let's go ahead
and attack a WAP scan --url beta.hackerInthehouse.com,
then let's use -U, and let's -U let's use
developer dash capital P password list. Let's
just give it a password list. Let's press
enter now we are brute forcing it with the
words which we found on the website.
Here you go. Where words, all words, try it.
You see performing password attack on XML,
RPC. We are reading that XML RPC. That's what
I said. It's very fast again one user trying
developer. And this was the last password
we tried. 35 out of 35. We did not put any
password, no valid password found in such
a case. You should go ahead and switch back
to something like Roku, despiet all words.
Right. That, that is how it normally works.
I've been under good passwords. We can try
it Roku again. That's going to take a lot
of time. Is that making sense?
Yes.
Right. So what I can just do here, I can go
ahead and try it to rocku. I can keep that
pushing. And of course, that's going to take
forever. This can take a lot of time if I
show you.
I have one question. I don't know if it's
out of scope but just, I know some people
use no words and even if we're using we run
CEWL we pull out words there. I know people,
you know, you have special characters and
numbers. Is there any kind of software that
kind of automates, maybe adding numbers to
the end?
Yes, I am about to come it now. That's called
transmutation. Okay. That's called transmutation.
We improve the list. That's one of the ways.
So let us say, we keep this rocku.TXT running
on a separate terminal. We just need to keep
it running there. Let's let's go ahead and
hit that running there on a separate terminal.
We open another terminal. Then we can work
on improving our list. So if it is a test,
which is all about, you know, if it is a test,
which is all about brute forcing, we have
to try everything and then we can transmute
now transmute, what transmute is, let's say
they're in a password sagar right now you
can write sagar or you can write s@g@ or you
can, you can write sagar@123 right? Or you
can, you can write capital list, different,
different versions of the same password. Isn't
it. That's what you're asking.
Yeah. That's what I'm asking. Yeah.
Right. This is called transmutation. There
are different
Kinds of transmutations. This kind of thing.
When you use the words like a becomes @ or
you capitalized things, this kind of word.
This is called leet mutation. Okay. leet.
Mutation LeeT is called leetd mutation. There
are different others as well. There are, there
are substitutions additions. In addition,
you are adding passwords like one, two, three,
you, add @ now, there are multiple tools for
that. One of them is cueds. So CUED that can
improve a list. One is Chain enable Chain
enable is the most famous tool in the whole
history of pen testing chain enable, can do
it. There is a Python script called transmute.py.
Okay. Transmute.Py. That is my personal favorite
because it's like a one liner, a one page
python script py script. You can keep it anywhere.
It doesn't take a lot of times. It's like
instant and it gives me great results. So
you can use transmitter how to get it. You
can Google again. Firefox,
I'm sorry. There you go. We can search for
transmuters.py Just to mention one thing guys
in the LPT exam, you do not have internet
access. So you, I'm sorry. You can use internet
in your local machine, but not in the machine,
which they are going to give you. They will
give you a virtual machine. A Windows sorry
A Kali Linux machine that is the virtual machine.
You cannot use internet on that machine. You
can use it in your machine to research, but
let's say you download this in your machine.
You cannot transfer that file because that
machine is not having an internet. Is that,
is that making sense? Yeah, it makes sense.
Yes. You see a simple but effective word list,
on it and it works. Yep. And there is a file
transmutter.py, which is a very effective
file. I can just go ahead and download the
zip here. I'm just, you know, this is, this
is now going out of scope of the LPT exam,
but this is like practical stuff. You should
be, you should be learning this. That's a
good stuff. Oh, cancel. There you go. Let's
drag it out on next door.
You got it, what's going on? I'm trying to,
Oh, okay. Now I get it. Yeah. This is what
you need. So we got transmuter.py file. Now
we can go ahead and improve our list.
This is still Still going on a brute force
over there. I'm just, I'm just stopping it.
We have already tried like 5,000 passwords.
You can, you can keep it running in a professional
test. Of course, in the LPD. If you're not
getting any results within first 20 minutes
or 30 minutes of a brute force it's not, it's
not going to work. It just doesn't understand.
It's not gona work in the exam. If you're
not getting anything in 30 minutes, it's not
working because they are not fools. They also
understand this is a six hours. You have to
act three machines and six hours. One machine
is like two hours. You cannot keep a brute
force running. So if you're not getting any
password within 30 minutes in the exam, don't
do it. Just stop it. Just to show you, how
does transmutation work? I'll become root.
Does like Paul do this? I just, that from
kali desktop. There you go. Clear the screen.
Now we've got a list of passwords, right?
Password-XD and transmute. How does transmute
works? Just to show you drop transmute-h,
to help you can specify a word, single word,
or you can give it a whole list. So that is
the using transmute options usage in the file.
Otherwise you can give single word. Then there
are different mutations, right? Typical transmissions
typically it will make from itself append.
It will, you know, it will add some things
and it can insert some things. It can add
characters, numbers, it can add symbols. It
can add lower case alphabet. It can add uppercase
alphabets. It can create common lead mutations.
It can create leet mutation. This is apart
from the scope of LPD. LPT does not, you know,
once you to actually go ahead and transmute
lists, they will give you the list in the
exam.
You will get the list to bruteforce, or you
will at least get the option to use Rocku.
You don't have to do it, but just for the
common reference let's use -L, which is common
leet mutation, transmutation-l So transmute-L
input file. That is what we're going to do.
In the screen transmute-l input file input
file is passed, right? If I press enter I'll
press Ctrl+C just to it's a long list. You
can see it just made so many complex passwords
out of the list, which we were using. Right.
Nice.
Yes, I see it. It looks good. All right. So
I can just output the output which are getting,
I can just save it by, you know, angular bracket
and I can give new passwords. Oh, I just say
new, you know, I just press enter and they
just got a new file, which is new. And you
see how fast it was. That's why I liked this
transmuter script. And now we can say word
count, sorry. I just opened it. And now you
can see first password is hackerInthehouse.com,
but then there are transmuted version of this.
Okay. There are so many versions, then different
words, different versions. So that's the,
that's the improved list. And you can have
first, go ahead, try this list. Let me try
this for you. You guys new, right? That new
list as new press enter. Let's hope this will
work. I know this work.
I created the machine, but anyways, and it's
brute forcing now, and of course, this is
like a hundred thousand passwords, which is
way less than Rocky which is 14 million passwords,
14 million versus a hundred thousand way more
difference. Right? And these are quality passwords.
And you can see this one works valid combination
found. Username is developer. Password is
-. It looks very complex, but at the end,
it is hacker in the house, leet mutated, and
the word is even on the website. Right. Cool.
That makes sense. Makes sense. Yeah. Right.
And I'm going to take this username and we
are going to make notes, you know, because
you will need to reuse it. Right. Of course,
you've got the password, but what now you
will, of course need us. So let's create a
file. I always use that. I don't know why
just create files, but anyways, let's say
notes, I faced it there. I just like, note
the move. Not necessarily things. This is
something we don't need. There's something
we all need or in the house.com Word, press.
Right? Yep. That seems fine. Right? We just,
we just got the username and password there.
Let's save it. And now anytime we are in another
tool or wherever we are, we can always do
catch notes.
Okay.
And this will give us the username and password
because we just saved it right now. We just
got the validation username password . And
now we can further exploited the, we can dive
into Metasploit and use multiple things. We
can go to the website itself. Well, try to
attack it from there. From inside, there are
multiple ways we can do it. One of them is
like hackerInthehouse.com, we can go on the
website. Okay. We can go on the website. We
can just go to login and it doesn't work.
We can go to -WAP login and it didn't work.
We can go to /WAP dash login can. Hopefully
that will work. Yeah. Here we go. It works.
Here we can, we can use that username and
password, which we got. Okay. Developer
Based here. Then we got hackerInthehouse Username.
I know the lecture is getting too long. Everyone
needs to go home. So I'm good. It okay, cool.
No, that's fine. So you see we can log in
right .Now tomorrow and tomorrow's class.
Let's go ahead and further exploited, you
know, privilege, escalation, blah, blah, blah,
different kind of things. Let's do it. The
username is developer development part by
the way, but it does work. Right. Um sounds
good. Yeah. So today what you learned was
how to brute force in CMS. Okay. And further
how to create custom lists, which is out of
the scope of, LPT just, you still learned
it, but how do you use word lists to bruet
force? A CMS. So how to do a dictionary attack
on a CMS? That's what you learn. All right.
So,
Oh, Sagar.
Yep. Oh no, no. After you go ahead.
So are we going to cover like directory busters?
Cause I know you were trying to different
type of logins. Okay.
Yep. Oh, I just deleted that. I just deleted
notes. So my question was you know, we went
through quite a few commands here, there in,
in preparation for the exam and in preparation
for tomorrow. Should we go back to these videos
and kind of notate all the different commands?
Oh, of course. What they all do or what is
your recommendation within the next 24 hours?
All right. So what I suggest is you download
the lecture, I will upload it and I'll give
you the access. You will download the lecture
and watch it and follow it, actually do it.
You know, you've got these machines, you've
got the beta machine, you've got the license
to pentest, the hacker machine, go ahead and
do it. Just try to get the password yourself.
Okay. I'm not too familiar with with what
is that called again?
The hypervisor virtual box. And that was very
popular in the event that I get stuck, I'm
sure I can just Google things right. In order
to see how things otherwise if you know if
you are doing there right now, which I don't
assume you are doing, but in case you are
doing that right now, this is day for me.
Right. I'm in India right now. So you can
always, okay. Okay. Sounds good. I'm willing
to stay on if you want while I am available
then. Okay. Okay, cool. Yeah. I'm willing
to stay on just to have my VMs loaded and
everything. I don't, I don't like to take
it for grant. It sound real simple, but you
know I think I'd rather just have my VMs all
set up and make sure that it's set up properly.
So what you just have to do by the way, you
know, you just have to click on this tools
here. Can you see this tool here? And once
you click on import, you just click there
and you can open the files and I have given
you the file. So LPT yep. You got these files
just open them and everything is loaded. Just
like an import. That's what you have to do.
Go. Okay. That sounds simple before doing
any of the import, make sure you create the
network first, because then it will mismatch
what is preferences network. We've got these
networks, so create 100 148, 155, 115. Create
all of those four. Got it. So let's create
the network. Okay. Sorry. We're done then.
I don't want to hold anybody up. I can, I
can stay with you while I can kind of just
run through that real quick. If you don't
mind. I'm sure I can be on for a while. Okay.
Sweet. Alright. Okay. So just bear with me
sagar since this you don't, you're not in
a rush. Yeah, sure. Let me do that. Alright.
Oh man.
Zoom is so respectful. It doesn't let you
share unless somebody stops here. Yeah. I
mean, if I'm hearing something you're gonna
share, right. It's teams you just share and
you just put somebody off. That's correct.
You can do that with, with Microsoft. Uokay,
cool. So,uI got my windows. Can you see my
screen? Right. Okay. So I'm going to go to
file preferences. Yep. I'm going to go to
my networks and now I need to create those
different networks plus and the plus sign.
This is, I gave it a name. Let's give it a
range. Let's keep everyone on the same thing.
Great one 100, First of all, what was the
IP address? I didn't notate that. So just
change that to, 10.0.100 know, Ctrl+z, ctrl+z
that. Yeah. Just change that to 200. That's
the standard. Got it, got it. Got it. Okay.
It supports the ACP port for that click. Okay.
To create another one. So is this range? 200.
Okay. And what was the IP address for this
one? And fall. I see the pattern now it's
clicking. All right, then we'll do it again.three.
Got it.
Range 3115. I'm sorry. Range. One, one point.
What did you say? 115, one, one five. Oh,
sorry. I missed that part. Okay. And this,
this is 115. Yeah. We can do that as well.
So we've got four inches. Okay. So heavy range.
So that's got it.
Okay.
115. Okay. Okay. All right. And now I'm going
to import my machine, go to my folder, my
downloads. And you can start with this one
and that's gonna take a lot of time. Oh yeah.
Okay. Let me, let me do it . Yeah. Okay. Click
on next and then import share this machine
to anyone, right, right, right. Okay. And
that's it.
Yeah. I don't need to do any other customizations.
No it will be automatically assigned. I have
already fixed everything in the machine itself.
You don't need do anything.
Perfect. This is what you were talking about,
right? Rafael. Just kind of having that out
of the box for see yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So if I was to walk into a penetration test
right now,
Well, everything be configured after putting
the network Ranges.
I mean, that company will of course have network
ranges. Isn't it?
No I'm referring to in the exam scenario,
you know how you just said everything else
is configured. Everything else is configured.
Yes. I mean, the exam is just like a real
test. There are 30 days. So you have 30 days
in 30 days, you have to do the pentest. You
have to do it three times. So there are nine
machines. You have nine machines. You have
to hack five of them. Within 30 days, you
can use three days to do pen tests, 27 to
make your report.
Oh, okay.
It's a big exam. Oh, OSCP people think, Oh,
OSCP is the best example is if it's like 24
hour exam, it's not even teaching you those
things. Practical things which you actually
use in LPT is much wider exam this is much
better.
I thought we just had 18 hours full stop then.
No, we had 30 days. 30 days.
No, you have 30 days. And every day you can
use six hours. I mean, you get six hours,
six hours six hours. That is 18. You got three
days to do pentest and going 27 days to do
the report.
Hey, sagar, let me rephrase my question. So
you know how we just created the VM, right?
We we said the network ranges, and then we
configured the IP addresses that we need.
The yeah. So my question to you is you just
stated that after we do set the network ranges
and we import the the VMs, everything else
has been configured by you to operate accordingly.
My question is,
In this case, it is configured by me.
Yes. So I'm asking, are you going to go over
additional configuration steps that we may
require? In exam? Yeah. Or would those be
all you said? That will be preconfigured by
EC Council great. Okay. Thank you. Yep. All
you, you are not important in terms of machine.
What happened? Oh, I was going to wait for
you real quick. Because you say that one takes
a while. I want to, it take like three, four
minutes normally. Oh, okay. Okay. And yet
I wanted to ask you a question again. It all
seems simple, but I don't take anything for
granted. So let me just make sure I'm clear
here. This is a VM or this is an environment.
This is for each one. Each one is a VM. Yep.
Got it. Got it. Okay. Alright. Okay. It's
pretty much just turn it on. And then once
I turned it on, I click on here at the of
start. Is there and then the right corner.
Oh, there. Okay. Start. And then it turned
on. Oh, I guess I'm waiting for it. Okay.
So once you start, it just pops up. Okay.
There's no RDP needed or anything. It's just
pretty much connect like that. Cool. Okay.
How did we get one? Right? I guess I'm good.
Yep. So the Kali Linux which I have given
you, the hacker machine that is running the
virtual box addon those ad-ons will allow
you to copy paste files between your host
machine and the virtual machine. You can go
full screen or do drivers. Everything has
been pre-installed so that's, that's fine.
Okay.
Yeah. As I said, four minutes, you are also
using SSD, right? Yeah. State drive. Oh gosh.
Yeah. It's four minutes. I got some students
who were using hardisk. I was like, guys,
this is going to take forever. Yeah. I know
this guy named Victor. He did the same thing.
I couldn't believe it, but I agree that I'll
get after that he's standing right here. So
that's what I was, bring it up, his name.
So just going back to the test, I know we're
not gonna really have the internet access
to download things when they're looking for
Mmm. A kind of software for transmutation.
Are we going to have? Okay. So that is what
I was saying from last five minutes, that
transmutation is out of the scope of LPT.
They do not expect you to trust .
Wow. So they're all, they pretty much expect
you to do is use a word list and, and crack
it. Or they will give you a word list actually.
Oh, because you have to plug it in, you know,
you just have to plug it in. Okay. Well I
hope the rest of the test is that simple.
It's not that simple. You know, like I said,
I don't take anything for granted, so yeah.
I got you. Okay. Sorry. I , you can, you can
close those messages from there. I'm, Not
the Cross sign the message, you know? And
then this last time now the other sign that,
Oh, damn, there were two options. Right? The,
the cross has really closed it. The second
one was permanently remove the messages, my
fault.
I think you gave it the, so what I do now,
just log in, right? You log into one. Oh,
okay. The Pentester machine. Yep. Just open
that. It was what did you say using, Password?
What was the root username is root with the
password as licensed to pentest, license to
pentest and test like pen tense. Are you writing
that ? Yeah. I was writing this. I was writing
here. Here. Sorry. You can see. Oh, sorry.
I'm giving you the user name for that machine.
The pentested machine. Okay. This is right
here. Why do you need the password for this
machine? Right, right. I'm sorry. I'm tripping.
I'm tripping you right you right. My fault.
Pentesting machine is what I want. Let me
turn that on. But we are going to have the
beta machine, not the media because you are
not in the same network. Media machine is
in the internal production zone. You are in
the DMZ zone right now. Okay. Oh. Can you
just close the VM click on close VM. So go
to settings. Okay. Close it and go to settings.
Okay. So you're going to change the network
adapter, go to the network because my wifi
was different. Your wifi is different. So
here in the business, make sure this is your
wifi, right?
I mean, it has automatically done it after
the edit. So this is your wifi Can you take
the adapter tool as well? Sure. Come check
my, no no what I'm saying? Oh, well, right.
So this is correct. That's correct. Yeah.
That's correct. So you are in the adapter
tool. This is the range 100 you're in that
range. And the beta machine is in that range.
Not the media machine. Media machine is in
a different range. Got it. Got it. It is in
this range of I guess you didn't put on the,
on the other ones. Right? So you only need
one range, which is a hundred because you've
got idea on their machines. Got it. And then
I could start the machine. Okay. Yeah. No,
it should work. Cool. Okay. You guys following
along over there, it might be beneficial for
you.
And they are going to call you. I know that.
Cool. Got my Kali. All right. Sounds simple
enough about what's been avoiding virtual
box. Alright. Let me read this this time.
If you want auto capture keyboard and turn
on. Yeah, I like that, right? No, not that
one. The second icon. All right. No, the second
Icon not be crossed the second icon. That
that message will cancel somewhere. I have
too many mines. This one? Yes. This one. Don't
show this message again. Got it. So you can
press Ctrl+F to go full screen control will
be always right when you are using virtual
box commands, Right Cntrl right. Control.
What do you mean by that? So there are two
controls. There is a left control and there
is a right control on your keyboard. Okay.
When you're using virtual box commands and
shortcuts like control F to go full screen,
you use the right control, the right control.
And you can always click on switch is the
saying that you want a full screen. And if
you want to come out again, the right control
and F and F got it. And if are, if you want
to use control in the VM, you use the left
control. Right? Got it. And by the way, if
you click in a VM, your mouse will be logged
into that VM. If you want to bring your mouse
to the host just press control. Oh, okay.
Okay. So license to pen test. Yes. That's
the root
LICENSETOPENTEST. Hold on one second. This
right. L I C E N S E . Okay. To pen test.
Cause I couldn't do spell mistakes. I know,
I know. It's probably me. Hold on. L I C E
N S E D T O P E N T E S T. I don't want to
give you do one thing. Can you write Kali
Kali? That is the non root user. Yeah. Okay.
Kali is what it is.
I was taking some time for start Yeah. Close
that browser. Yeah,
Yeah,
Yeah. There you go. Oh, Roku is already extracted.
You can delete that. If you want to do it
yourself. I do. Okay. As just a copy of my
business.
Let me see inside. I just sent it. Right.
Isn't that logo cool. By the way, it's our,
our personal, yeah, I like it, man. I like
it. I like that picture too, man. You gotta,
you gotta tell me who your photographer is,
which picture there's a picture you had, you
were showing I think on your desktop. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Thats my another course
for CISO kind of people, you know lot of experience,
just like easiest is a CSSP. So to grow further,
maybe see CISO. Nice. Nice. Okay. Can you
log into root using, using terminal now? Yeah,
let's do it. Yeah. I forget one click. You
want to go too sudo-su. So you become root
now this, but without sudo, you know, of course,
without sudo permissions exited the site exit.
Okay. Now just type su root. So when you type
sudo su, that will ask you the user, the password
of your account, because you are using your
sudo powers when you directly type switch
user to root. Now does asking me the password
of the root user, so just type license to
pentest.
Okay.
Okay. I believe the password is something
else then try Kali, Kali, instead of licensed
with a D, no, no, yeah. Sorry. Are you using
license D yeah, I did a D I think, I didn't
saw that. Yeah, it is license without d, yeah.
So I, I did'nt notice that you're using with
a D. Okay, cool. We're good. I just quickly
just try one thing. Just try to ping the machine
in the DMZ area. The beta.hackerinthehouse.com.
What was the IP? Beta.Hackerinthehouse.Com
Sorry. You're right. I already configured
the host I haven't run and done it. Okay.
Oh, okay. Yeah. It's not running. I think
as it it's me. No media, oh media is running.
Okay. It's not reachable. Okay. Run it. Then
let's run it. Let's run it paid in the house.
Let me start. Oh, also guys, just adjust the
amount of Ram according to your system. So
like, Oh yeah. Sorry. Yeah. 16, gb. So not
16, but maybe someone is using like eight
gb or four gb. Just adjust the Ram always
before launching any kind of machine you want
to close. First of all, you
Might want to try it again after the machine
starts.
Okay. CTRL+C Yeah. That's when I typed in
the wrong side, I know you're on full screen
basically you can just say clear. Sorry. I
didn't see that part. I think machine is on,
can you check that? The beta.? Yep. Yeah,
here it is. It's on.
Oh, okay. I think you are using two desktop
to do, to, you know, to, it stops.
Yeah. Yeah. I brought up one of them. Yeah.
You can see this one, right? Yeah. Just ping
it Alright. Let's see. Pentester Yeah.
There you go. It's really convenient. So you
can, you can work with it further and you
can try to do whatever we did today. Sweet.
Alright. All cool. Then. Any doubts? Anyone?
Nah, we're good, man. Thank you very much.
That was very clear. Concise,
Alright? So basically the Metasploit framework
is one of the most popular frameworks in the
whole pen testing field. There are three main
frameworks. Basically. We have the core impact.
We have the canvas. And metasploit so these
are the three most common frameworks in, in
industry, which we use, of course if the project
is like, you know, very expensive, a big project,
you may want to go with core impact. That
is a much better tool. If it is a normal organizational
day to day activity, then Metasploit is kind
of fine. Now Metasploit comes with three flavors.
So actually now it's coming with two flavors
earlier. There were three, it was it pro version,
a community version and a framework version.
Now community is no longer existing, so they
discontinued it. So we just have Metasploit
pro and Metasploit framework. What's the difference,
Metasploit pro has got a much more exploits,
much more features, and it has got a graphical
user interface, `framework has a command line
interface.
So that's the whole big difference. You got
a command line versus a graphical. That's
where the difference comes up. Let me just
go ahead and become root very quickly. There
you go. How to stop me display you just type
MSF console. That's one of the ways to start
Metasploit in the framework talking of course,
pro version, you cannot buy the pro version
as a individual. You need to be a company
and import licenses needed. So but you can
always try to sign up for the trial version,
they got like 15 days trial and int the LPT
exam, basically you will get Metasploit. So,
you know, unlike OSCP and the offensive security
believes that you need to do everything manually,
which is like exploit development work. We
are not expert developers. We are professional
pentesters in professional pen testing, we
never develop our own exploits. It's very
rare that you will make your own exploits.
You will always use, you know, industry specific
already made exploits, which are accredited.
So I think we, we got us, we got tWo CSSP
here. I Paul CSSP. Yes. It's Easy to CSP,
right?
Correct. Yeah. So, so you guys understand
the accreditation and certification process,
Is'nt it? Right? Right. So for rafal, basically
say, when you are doing any kind of change
in the company, you need to do, you need to
go through a proper change management process.
Okay. When you're doing a pen test, of course
you are making changes. You know, you can
crash their systems. You can do a lot of work.
Maybe you run a exploit from public. You know,
you just go on internet, you find the exploit,
you run it. Maybe it will make some changes
to their system. So you cannot use such kind
of things in professional environment until
it has been, you know, going through a process
where there is a proper change management,
proper testing, a lot of different stuff that
is called the accreditation certification
process, where, you know, you get proper authority
to run that.
So that's why we don't use public exploits.
We use professional frameworks. A Metasploit
is one of them. We use these exploits and
the, you know, exploits from these networks.
That's the whole reason behind using it. LPT
exam is very, very professional. They believe
that you are in the real life going to use
it. So they will give you the Metasploit framework.
You will have access to it. And this is going
to be like 80% of your, your, your tool that
you will be using for the whole exam is so
Metasploit is something you need to learn
very deeply. Now, if I go ahead and let me
just open a new terminal. And so if I go ahead
to a directory, I hope you know how to navigate.
So use user is one of the root is one of the
folders user folder in that there is a folder
called share and in that there is a folder
called Metasploit. Okay. Do we have Metasploit
Metasploit framework, Metasploit framework.
So there's a folder user in which there is
a folder share. There is a folder, Metasploit.
In Metasploit there's a folder called modules.
I can see these are the modules this is what
Metasploit is basically made of. These are
the main modules you're in auxillaries is
you got encoders, evasion, exploit norms.
Payloads,Posts. Let's discuss them very quickly,
like 15 minutes. What exactly does this all
mean now?
Yeah.
I would like to start with exploit and payload
because that's the easiest one I can. And
I always like to give this gun analogy. So
think about you, you have a gun, right? You
have a gun. You're wanna shoot someone then
what do you need? You need a bullet. Isn't
it,
Guys. You got a gun. You need a bullet to
shoot someone that's correct. Correct. Now
that bullet is your payload and that gun is
your exploit. Okay. So the thing which is
actually going to hurt, I mean, you know,
the, the malicious code, which is actually
going to run on a system that is a payload,
the, you know, the, the thing that you will
use to send that exploit to the system, or
to exploit a vulnerability, to take advantage
of a vulnerability, a loophole in the system,
the process that that thing is exploit. So
you use exploit to deliver a payload or to
run a payload. Okay. That is how exploits
and payloads work.
That makes sense. Yup. Alright
Then after that you got auxiliaries. Auxillaries
are the most important part after exploiting
payload, because Auxillaries are supporting
elements. They will support your exploits
and payloads. How, for example, if I show
you an auxiliary. There you go. For example,
you got a scanner here, a scanner module in
auxiliary, you got fuzzers. Okay. You got,
you got dos attacking stuff. You've got cloud,
you've got analyzing stuff. You've got, for
example, spoofing stuff here. Okay. If I,
if I even show you in scanners and I do LS,
you can see you've got different kinds of
scanner. So FTP scanner, you know, DNS scanner
SDB scanner, there are different kinds of
scanners. So what exactly, this is the supporting
elements first, you know maybe you will need
these scanners to find version numbers or,
or do a lot of information gathering. That's
my auxiliaries will help you out. That's where
auxillaries help you out. Right.
No, not really. It's not coming out crystal
clear in my head, but I think I understand
what you mean. It supports , so supporting
stuff basically
Basically, so, okay. Let me give you an example.
Have you ever all of, you know, what is n
map
N-Map yeah, it's a scanner.
Yes. Alright. So what we do with n app is
we scan ports and services. Right? Right.
Now you can use n map within Metasploit. So
there is a module for n map, but there are
other kinds of scanners as well in Metasploit
in auxillaries modules. So you have PCP scanning
module. You have SIM scanning module, you
have UDP scanning module. So all of those
modules are there in Metasploit. Now you might
say that, why do we need that? I mean, n map
is the best tool. Everyone knows, and Metasploit
the best tool. Why do you need a scanner?
And what you think about it when you are attacking
a target using Metasploit framework and, and
you need to use a lot of information. So you
need to collect a lot of information. Where
you keep all of that information. You will
keep all of that information in the Metasploit.
So you can create a database here that will
collect all the information for you. And then
you can use that further. You can use that
information in your payloads and exploits
are you getting it. So it's reusing same information
again and again, it's, you know, organizing
your information.
Yeah. It isn't making sense. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Now
What exactly is post post is the post exploitation
tools. So normally people don't talk about
posts, but it's very, very important. One
of the most important things a post comes
you know, on, on the basis of different, different
operating systems and the environments. So
one example is Android is there are Ios is
there DSD, Cisco fireworks? Jupiter, Linux
multi is basically it's, you know, it's, it's
multiple operating systems that will work
on, multiple things, OSX, Mac, Mac, OSX and
those windows. If I go with something like
windows,
Then you can see, we got post exploitation
tools, which are again, divided into categories
like capture. So you can capture some things.
Now, for example, you want to capture key
logging. You know, you knowt, you're not have
a key logger there. You have, you have a system
now you want to install a key logger. You
can use a captor post exploitation tool. So
CD capture LS, you can see you are a Key logger
recorder and you got to log out key logger.
So you got two key logger modules there, and
you can, you can read them to understand what's
the difference. So that, that is a postexploitation
tool. You got, you got some reconnaissance.
What do you say? Post exploitation? You've
got wireless postexploitation toll. You've
got managing stuff, gathering information,
escalating the usage. So a lot of people,
they struggle a lot with escalating this,
the privileges. So you see right now we were
using Kali Linux, right? Sorry, Kali user.
That is a non-root user. We cannot run a lot
of commands, but we may want to escalate ourselves
to root user. So how do you do that? You use
escalate, post exploitation tools. You can
escalate your users. You can try to escalate
yourself. That is the escalation.
Any doubts, is that clear enough? Or shall
I give you more examples? Right? Then after
that we have encoders and evasions. Envasions
was a new module, which was recently added
encoders is the old module. Almost do the
pretty much the same job basically. Encoder
will change the coding. Okay. This will encode
your code. What exactly does that mean? Basically?
you know, it can basically change the code.
For example, it can change the language. It
can change the patterns of the code. How does
this helps to bypass firewalls, to bypass
antiviruses ideas, IVs, you know IPS, all
of those securities stuff. They, they look
at patterns. There are two kinds of you know,
there are two kinds of security devices. One
is pattern based signature based. One is realistic
space, which is behavior based.
So signature versus behavior now signature
is can easily be evaded by, by encoders. You
can just encode yourself and you're good to
go. Encoder also helped to, you know, do a
lot of web attacks. Sometimes you need to,
you know, encode your, your virus, your malware,
you need to encode that into different languages,
right? Basically four different, different
kinds of encodings. Sometimes it is required.
So encoder help over here, evasion similar
version. Did they just improve the encoders
and bring a division which was antivirus division.
So you will find like windows defender. Let
me just show you, see the evasion. It is only
available for windows right now. If you just
do LS, you can see the windows. They will
add it. They will improve it. So for example,
windows defender, you can, you can evade windows,
defender, easily using this.
A lot of people, they don't have paid antiviruses.
So that's weird. It's very helpful. That was
encoders evasions. We are left with one, which
is notes. Notes basically is no operation.
Notes are used when you are making things
like buffer overflow. You know, when you are
writing your own exploits, so Metasploit framework,
it has got its own language. You can code
it, ruby is the language. Basically it has
got its own formats. You can code in Ruby
in Metasploit format and make your own exploits.
And that's where you might need to use notes.
Or, you know, basically notes, notes means
you are telling the CPU that do not do anything,
just stay quiet. Stay Ideal don't do anything.
Being the ideal state. That's in no operation.
We practically don't use it. You know, exploit
developers will use it. Pentesters rarely
will, will use. I've never used an open in
my whole career. So it's kind of, you don't
use that maybe in a buffer overflow you might
want to do it, but normally you won't do it.
That's notes.
So, so you basically, you want to be quiet
not to do any phase so that you don't get
detected. ? Is that purpose?
No. So do you know what a buffer overflow?
Sorry. Do I know what, ? Buffer Overflow?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.? So do you know how it works?
Okay. Can you tell me? Yeah, sure. So in the
buffer overflow attack, basically I try to
get into the bucket of another run, an application
to manipulate it, to steal data or to control
it. Right. I mean, pretty much how it works.
Yeah. I mean, that's the theoretical part,
but you know, the practical what's going on
behind the scenes. Oh, no gosh. Okay. Let
me explain that. So it will make much more
sense. For example, this is your program.
Let's just say, this is your bucket. Okay.
So this is the core capacity, and this is
the core capacity, which it can handle the
capacity for any program, memory allocation.
If you think about it is the memory part.
There is a, there's a, this is the capacity.
This is mine. Now you send so much data to
this input. You send so much data that it
overflows, okay? Let's say it overflows. Now
when it overflows this, this, this thing,
you know, this is overflowing. This is the
overflow area here in a buffer overflow am
just giving a high level overview. You can
ask it to have a jump instructions.
So JMP, you can say assembly language. You
can say that, jump to somewhere. Now you can
tell it where to jump when you are, when you're
overflowing the data, you send a payload as
well. You send a malicious code. Let's say
we have a code here. So let's say this is
our code. Or let's say, Hey, here it is. Okay.
So this is your malicious code. You tell him
that, listen, I want you to jump to the this
code. Okay? So basically this is the program
it's already executed. You overflow it, you
control this byte. This is called the ESP.
So you, you control this ESP byte. You put
a jump instruction there that jump instruction
jumps the program to your malicious code.
That's how overflow works. Okay. But the problem
here is if you're using a jump instruction
you need to jump to exact address.
So for example, zero X, zero six A B, okay.
Let's say that is the memory address. Memory
has got addresses. You have to jump exactly
this address. And it's very hard. It's almost
impossible to jump to the same exact address.
So here we use notes. We just say, we just
say that instead of jumping to this address,
you jump anywhere before it. So you say that
you jump anywhere. Let's say it will jump
here. Okay. Let's say this is the point where
it jumps your, your program. Now here you
add notes, these are notes no operations and
CPU will not do anything. So here's, CPU is
not doing anything, here's CPU is not doing
anything else. Here's CPU is not doing anything
here, it is not doing anything. So you added
notes and finally it will hit it, right? You
you're sending your jump instruction before
the address and then adding notes.
So it doesn't do anything. And eventually
it will hit the program and your code will
execute That is how notes works. That is our
buffer overflow. Is that makes sense. Yeah.
Right. But again, you don't have to do this,.
Anyhow, I have never made any buffer overflow
or any kind of custom code for any program.
You never do that because of the affilation
management process. That's one of the reasons
people think that OSCP is a good certification.
They teach you how to code, but what's the
reality. Are you actually going to do that?
No, you're not going to do that.
Alright. So that was the nopes. Let me just
quickly show you the payloads. There is a
difference between payloads. So payloads comes
into two flavors. A third one is stages. You
can ignore that. That is something else. I'll
talk about. That payloads are singles versus
stagers. Okay? What's the difference between
singles versus Stagers. So think about it
in this way. You are sending your payload.
You're sending your bullet, right? Will you
send it in one shot or will you send it in
parts? So part by part that's the whole difference
between single versus stagers singles are
one shot. You send the whole payload, let's
say the five megabytes of file. You send that
file within one shot. That is a singles. You
make it into you know, small, small pieces.
You send it one megabyte first, then two megabytes
after that. So small pieces, that is a stager.
Now, really, it doesn't matter what you use.
Sometimes stagers will not work. Sometimes
in some cases you know stagers will, will
die. So you get a session. It will work. You
will get the access, but then access will
automatically die within a second. That normally
happens when you using a stager. So you have
to use a single there, okay? Understand this
thing in your exam, in any kind of test you
are doing. If your session is dying, it's
99% chance that you're using a stager and
you need to use a single there because the
connection is not able to handle multiple
files. You need to send it in one shot. Yeah.
In some cases, you, if the explode is not
even working, you know, exploit is working,
but you're not getting a session you may want
to go to stagers So maybe session is not able
to handle one file of that size size matters.
Maybe session is not able to handle one file
of a big size. Then you won't do stager, but
in case you, you are getting a session, it
is dying. Then go to a single. It is not able
to handle multiple files. Making sense. Yep.
Yep.
Oh, sorry. I just wanted to confirm. So you're
just saying if the file is too large, you
stagers if the connection is dying, you
Singles. Right? Okay. Thank you. Stages is
nothing. Stages is basically you can say an
extra part with stages we'll use, as you know,
it will make stages out of it. And then it
will send in stages. It's like both of these
are connected. Just, just think that is why
I said all of this, there is only single.
There are only two. And I will show you that,
you know, in practical as well in the few
minutes that why there are only two.
So overall I don't really focus on stages.
They'll just say, What?Sorry? Do not focus
on the third one stages.
Okay. Let me show you that. Give me one second.
Right? There you go.
Okay. So here, let me show you thhe stages
versus stages. And then stages. Okay. Can
you see there is so first of all, this is
the pattern. Understand the patterns. There
is windows slash 64 slash something slash
something, underscore something, okay, this
is the pattern. So windows are, let's take
this example. Windows is the platform operating
system. X86,X64 that will be your architecture
of the CPU. So if your processor is 86, a
32 bit or 64, that is the architecture. Then
this is the name of the Payload. There are
multiple payloads. There is PowerShell payloads.
There are shell payload. There are meterpreter
payloads. I will talk about that. This is
the payload type, then bind versus reverse.
So there are two main things bind versus reverse,
in a bind connection. You trying to connect
to the target. In a reverse Connection. Target
is trying to connect to you, okay?
Bind, you will connect with them. So you,
you know, you attack that. It will open a
port on that system and you can connect with
that port. Anytime in the reverse, you will
open a port on your system that target will
connect to you. Now it, when you are doing
a reverse, it may bypass a lot of firewalls
because on a system, it is possible that they
are not allowing anyone else to connect with
them, but they are able to connect to everyone.
So in the reverse, it may bypass a lot of
firewalls that is bind versus reverse. Then
it is big protocol. Are you going to use PCP?
Are they going to use HTTP? Are you going
to use UVP? That is, that is the protocol.
Okay. That is the pattern. Now, when you see
here, for example, shell, and then can you
see this slash here versus can you see PowerShell
underscore here?
Yeah. So PowerShell underscore bind shell
slash bind. What does slash versus underscore
means? This underscore is single. You see
power shell PowerShell under score, bind,
underscore PCP. It's one word. It does a single
stager. When you say shell slash bind under
Courtsey underscore whatever. This is a stager.
This is a stager. It is staged. This slash
is a stage. Underscore is a single. So there
are only two kinds of payloads. You can see.
There is nothing else. It is either slash
or it is somewhere, either, either underscore.
There are only two kinds of things.
When you go to, when you go ahead and go to
stages, I'm trying to, Oh, okay. Modules.
Payloads
Stages stages. I'm talking about stages now,
again, not stagers, which I send you that
stages. You can see stages are for different
platforms. If I go to windows, now you can
see, these are just stages. These are like
supporting elements that, that, that the stages
use to, to go there. You know, these will
divide the stager out into stages. That's
what it is.
Okay.
And now let's talk about exploits. Exploits
are a platform dependent. So there will be,
again, you will find, for example, Android
, Firefox Linux of different things. Let's
talk about again, windows, very, very simple
in windows. You can see them. They are coming
on to be services or protocols. That's what
they're coming up at the end. You can see,
you can, you can exploit antiviruses. You
can exploits firewalls. You can exploit FTP
service, email service, my SQL proxy SMB service.
So just to show you SMB here, SMB is very,
very popular thing. SMB, you can see there
are some exploits like ms. 06040 and zero
eight, zero six seven net API. What exactly
this is this was a exploit, which works in
windows. XP windows XP is exploitable due
to this specific exploit, the, the net API
issue for that, they made exploit.
Then there is eternal blue. Everyone knows
about eternal blue because this was the exploit,
which, which was used in one of the wanna
cry attack the wanna cry ransomware. It was
used using eternal blue. This was developed
by NSA, the national security agency. They
developed it. They kept it for themselves
for years exploited everyone whenever they
wanted to exploit any windows, they use eternal
blue. It was one of the most powerful tools
in history, but it got leaked. Everyone used
it. And now it' is a metsploit. Eternal blue
has got other options. Eternal Blue windows
eight version PSEs. This one works on windows
10 as well. I used it. I understand you can
hack it very, very popular. So these are exploits.
They are used to take advantage of vlunerability.
These are exploits. And with that, I hope
it's extremely clear now how Medisplay works.
Yup.
Okay. Yeah. I mean, I don't even need this
domino. So to start MediSploit you just type
MSF console and that's how you started. Let's
go ahead and do a little practical on hacking
the WordPress site, which we, which we study
to crack the password, right? So very, very
easy. You can find, you know, exploit in multiple
versions. There are, there are authenticated
exploits and non authenticated exploits. When
you say authenticated, it means you need a
password and username. When you say I'm not
authenticated, you don't need anything. You
just, you're going to take advantage of any
kind of vulnerability. That's, that's what
it does. Now, let me open the notes so that
we can have the password. Now, if you go ahead
and if you try to find an exploit for the
WordPress, how will you do it? You can just
say search in metasploit, of course you can
search, and then you can tell it, like, I
want to search exploits so type colon, whatever
exploit I want to search a exploit and then
tell it, what do you want to search?
I mean, a keyword. So I'll say WordPress,
okay. I just say, WordPress, there you go.
This is the list of WordPress exploit. I can
go up and you can, see, they will give you
the matching modules. And because we only
search exploit, they are only giving us exploit
here. So this is the ID number for your reference.
This is the name. So this is, this is the
path, basically, this is how, this is what
you need to do select this exploit. Okay.
This is the exploit. This has been disclosure
date. This is the date when it was disclosed
in the public after that, it is the rank Metasploit
give you the rank. So excellent is the best
after that as the, is the good after that
is the normal, sorry. Excellent, great. Average,
normal. That is how it works. Okay. Ranks
argument there. Then you have check. Now what
is check, check will allow you to check if
the exploit is working or not on a target.
So, you know, it's just going to tell you
that if the target is one variable to this
exploit or not.
Before exploiting it. Of course you're not
sending any payload. You're just, you're just,
you know, firing a dummy bullet. It's not
a real payload. It's just a dummy bullet and
you are actually not firing even a bullet.
You're just testing the gun on a person on
your system, that there is a system you think
it is vulnerable You test a exploit by using
check, and it is very important that you check
things before you actually fired them. Then
there is a description which you can use to
easily understand what the exploit is. So
I have just zoomed in. You can zoom out. So
this is the description that you can use to,
you know check what the, what the exploit
is all about. Now we have the admin username
and password. So this exploit will work very
fine. WAP admin, shell upload shell is another
name for payload.
We want to upload a shell. We want to upload
a payload. And this is the, this is the exploit
here. You copy. You can say clear and you
say, use, so use this exploit. And now you
are using that exploit because the module
has changed to exploit. This is the module
name, and you can always type info, okay?
Info will give you the information about how
to use it, what it is all about, etc, etc.
So some information about the author and all
of that available targets, what is the target
wordpress website check supported, yes, you
can check before using any payload, then basic
options. These are the options you want to
configure in this required options out of
this, this, this, this, and this. So password
is required. It's an authenticated upload.
A proxies is not required. R-Host is required.
R-Host is target host your target, basically
in this case, that has a website, which is
beta.hacker.inthehouse.com R- port NSSL. R-Port
is the remote port. So the port on which you
want to attack now, everyone knows. I think
every one of you knows that HTTP work on port
80 and HTTPS work on port 443. Are you available
aware of it? Yes. Yep. Yep. So if the website
was working with a SSL, we will change this
port to 443, and we'll change the SSL to prove
in our case, even in the exam, I believe.
I'm not sure on that. Because it's been long,
I have taken the exam. So, you know, in a
simulated environment, of course, it's a non
SSL version. Doesn't matter as you just have
to keep it on port 80 and false, if it does
SSL, keep it true port 443, that's the only
difference target url. Right? What is the
target url anyone knows about that? And I
explain the URL of your targets of your, I
know, but that is R-host. Oh, okay. Okay.
Let me, let me show that. So for example,
I hope you can see this screen on the lower
side, right?
I mean, you can see what I just type. Right?
Right. Right. So for example this is our target,
right? Beta.Hackerinthehouse.Com So here,
when you said target is a domain which is
basically in the root directory, this is a
root domain. You just type a forward slash,
but there are possibilities where companies
will, will install websites or will have data
in folders. So there can be a folder in this,
this domain beta.hackerinthehouse.com slash
secret website. Okay. So when you go to that
slash secret website, it opens a new website
that is also a possibility, or there can be
something like, you know employees. So there
can be a specific portal for employees and
let's say it is made in WordPress. So when
you get to know that there is a sub directory,
which is having a website, then this is your
target URL.
So in this, if this is the URL, which you
are trying to attack here, the target URL
will be slash employees. In our case, we don't
have any sub-directory. The website is installed
on this domain itself. So our target, url
is only a slash makes sense. Yup. I User name.
Of course, if you have a password, you will
have a user name we host it's basically for
the, you know, apache web server stuff, you
will probably never use it. It's just kind
of a custom. If you know, if you are working
in a company and it's an internal test and
your things are not working, you can ask them
that are using a specific V host. It's a virtual
host. They will give you the information.
It's like white box testing work in the exam
or in, in, in normal professional testing,
you will, of course never be changing a vhost,
but you can always ask your client or your
company if they're using every vhost, separate
vhost.
Okay. I hope it's quite clear now, just to
give you the description this module, generate
a plugin that WordPress has plugins, WordPress
users plugins. Plugins are just like apps
in your phone. You install apps in WordPress,
install, plugins. This plug, this module will
generate a plugin back the payload into it.
So it will make it plug in and have the virus
code into that and upload it to the server,
running wordpress providing valid admin credentials.
If you use it, if you give it the valid credentials,
it will make a payload for you. It will upload
that payload to the website for you, and then
execute it and give you the access. That's
what this module is going to do. So let's
use it. How do you use it? You need to set
these options, which we just saw. We need
to set a password, username and R-host you
set a password. What is the password you can
copy from there?
No,
There you go. Set username set R-host.
It just beta.hackerinthehouse.com. You can
always do show options. To check what you
have set and what is, what is not set. So
password, it set, R-host is set R-port is
okay, R-port okay. User name is set. Right?
And I think I just did something there. Alright.
So that is how you set things. And once you
are all set, once you're satisfied with the,
you know, tuning your exploit, we just tune
that basically you can always type exploit
and you can press enter wait for it to complete.
You can clearly see right here sending stage
and you see it was a stager and it has sent
in stages. Okay. Metalsploit meterpreter session,
one open. What is meterpreter? Meterpreter
is the type of a payload. So there are multiple
payloads. There is a meterpreter. There is
PowerShell.
There is shell there is generic shell, multiple
types Meterpreter was developed by the same
company. Metasploit rapid seven company. The
name of the company is rapid seven. So they
develop meterpreter. It's one of the most
powerful payload in the history ever created
because it gives you a lot of options. You
can do a lot of stuff with meterpreter. You
can take screenshots, you can record voice.
You can upload files, download files. You
can run commands. You can take, even sometimes
you can even take a graphical interface using
RDP or something. You can crack passwords.
It's a very, very powerful payload. It gives
you additional options. Now that you have
a meterpreter shell, right over here, you
can start using it. I mean, you can, you can
use any kind of comment. I can just say help
and specific meterpreter will give me specific
commands. So, this is a WordPress website,
which is running on PHP. Now. I hope you guys
understand what is PHP, right? PHP is the
language which wordpress use. Right? Right.
Yep. So this is only one PHP. Now PHP meterpreter
is regarded as the weakest meterpreter that
has got the lowest amount of features. If
it was a windows meterpreter, it will get
the maximum features. You can use a lot of
things, but here also you can see, you can
run these commands. Okay? So you can PHP,
sorry.
Wordpress always runs on PHP. So when you're
doing information gathering also you can,
you can actually go ahead and check that.
Let me show you how to check that, by the
way, I'm going to say background and I'll
show you what, what that means. I'll tell
you. Okay. So you can type sessions. You can
type sessions and you press enter and it will
tell you, what are these sessions you have
available? You can see the type of the payload
is meterpreter PHP, which is running on linux.
Okay. That is how you know it is PHP. The
user, the user, which you just had is www
data. It's one of the users, it's basically,
you know, the user of web server. This is
the host name. This is the IP address of you.
It's my IP port is 4444. This is the IP of
that machine, which we have on this port.
We are connecting to that machine. And yeah,
that's pretty much it. I mean, that's how
you view your sessions. That's how you can
know that it is a PHP, by the way, it's like
experience thing, but still you can check
it if I want to go back to this session. So,
you know, I can have multiple sessions at
the same time. That's why it's a framework.
I can manage a lot of things to get. If I
want to go back to the session, I will interact
with this. I can just type sessions-i interact
and session numbers. So one is the number
you can check the id over here, right? I'm
just saying session one. Now, presenter, you're
back in session one. And I can always background
it when I don't need it. I want to go back
metasploit. I can just say background and
press enter and I'll be back over here. And
then now why do we want to go background?
Maybe you want to exploit something else,
or maybe you want to use a scanner, an auxiliary,
or maybe you want to use a post exploitation
tool. That's why you need to background things.
That that's how it works. So I can again say
sessions, -i one. And I'm back into metadata.
Now let me say help.
You can see what you can run. You can execute
a command. You can get the UID, which is the
user. You can kill a process. You can, you
know, do a lot of stuff here. You can check
the processes. You can get a shell, command
shell. So what that means, if I say shell,
I just got a shell over here. It may give
you another, that's fine. It's a shell I can.
Type if-config. And you can see the IP addresses
10110. My IP is 10109. This is ten. I am right
now. I'm controlling the terminal of that
machine. Okay. That is a shell. If it was
a windows that will give me a command prompt.
So right now I will have a command prompt
instead of a terminal. This is the terminal.
I can have a command prompt if the target
is you know, a windows interesting thing here
is this machine is running two network cards,
right?
Because we said that we know that, but as
a pen tester you can see, this is the IP range,
okay? This is the DMZ range, right? We are
in the same range. We also have 10,.0.100
IP. There is one more range 10.0.148, right?
That is another range. And there must be machines
in that range, but we cannot go in that range.
We cannot even ping if I try to ping. So if
I try to say ping 10.0.148.1 Which should
be of course, one is the router. So if I try
to ping there and I don't know, why am I getting
the signal? 46, 46? Yeah. 148. Still. It is
giving me, yeah, it's not working out. Right.
That's fine. So 148. We are not in that same
range. You see, we are not getting any signal,
right?
So, but this machine again. So if I give,
give from here, if I tried to say ping, because
I'm going to right now controlling that terminal.
If I say 10.0.148.1 you can see, we are getting
replies and I can terminate it, so this machine
can ping, but we cannot ping. But that's where
pivoting comes in. You know, we can use this
machine at a pivot. We can use it as our gateway
internet gateway. We can route our traffic
from this machine to that network. That is
a pivoting stuff. We will come on that, but
later right now is not the time for pivoting.
Right now it's time for exploitation and you
know, all that stuff and you can come out
of meterpreter by the, if you want to close
the connection, you can say exit. And by that
you will exit the connection. Connection is
closed. Now you should privacy sessions. You
will not have anything. That's how sessions
work. And I'm quite sure with that Metasploit
ends. I mean, approximately there, there is
one more module, which I want to show you.
That module is multi handler. So if you say
use exploit multi handler. Now, what is a
handler info? Listeners
Sorry. Yes. To listen to service, right? So
a handler is the part of this framework, which
listens for a connection. Okay. When you say
it's a reverse connection, right? Any kind
of connection. So that target is trying to
connect to you, but there needs to be someone
which will listen to that target, right? That
is trying to connect to a port that port needs
to be open. And there needs to be someone
who is listening that is where we are using
multi handler. And you can just say, show
options here. Right. You need to, first of
all, collect the payload as well. So let me
select a payload.
Yes.
Oh, sorry. So you need to select a payload
for a multi handler and you can say use payload
and then you can tell it, which kind of payload
do you want to listen to? Let's say we want
to listen to a PHP based meterpreter. Just
the one in which we will just use few minutes
ago, but we are doing it now manually again.
So let's say PHP. Okay. I don't see that.
Does anyone knows what's wrong? Why I cannot
get a PHP?
Well, any ideas I'm trying to get a PHP payload
here. Not able to select it. Use payload PHP.
Oh, now I can do that. I think there was a
space. So use payload. PHP. Let's see. Oh
no. Sorry. Can I just set it? Set payload
Yeah. I need to set it. That's that's the
problem. So we will set a payload and it will
set a payload PHP. I just press double tab
to see what are the availabilities. So let's
say I choose a payload, which is meterpreter.
And let's say we choose a stager. So stager
version, meterpreter reverse TCP this one.
So I can just copy this. Sorry. Did I ask
you what you say? You said you did double
tap. Yeah. So you can always press press the
tab key. You got a tab key, right? Yes. You
can always press that tab key two times to
see the availability's.
Okay. All alright. And you can press that
once to auto-complete. So one is autocomplete
two is check availabilities. There you go.
I just set that payload. Let's clear the screen
and now let's see the options and you can
see we've got some options. There are two
options in this payload option is L-port and
L host. So what is the listening host, which
is your IP who will be listening? What does
the L-port, which is your port on which port
you want to listen? Okay. And L-port really
doesn't matters. I suggest, okay. I do suggest
always to keep L-port to be 123, anyone knows
what's the reason for using 123, that's an
NTP server. Isn't it? Yup. Network time protocol.
. So normally what happens in enterprises,
the best practice is to have a local time
server. So the best practice is to have a
time server machine itself in enterprise network,
but people don't follow best practices. You
see, they will always in their firewall. They
will always keep the 123 port open and they
will use publicly available type servers.
So that's the problem. 90% of the enterprises
I have ever pentested audited, whatever. They
never have their own time servers. They will
just use public time servers, just like Google
server or Microsoft service. That's what they
use. You do that port one, two, three is open
in the firewall. That's most of the cases
you will find it. That's why we use time server
port. Some people use port 80, port 80 because
everyone allows to connect to internet, but
that sometimes can be suspicious.
So I just, you know, like to use either time
server if it is possible, whenever it is possible,
use time server 123 we just said L-host a
L-port. What is L-host? Now you may want to
give it a specific interface. So I may want
to tell it that let's see, I got two IP addresses.
Listen on this IP address, but the best practice
here, the best way to do it is you've always
said L host to 0.0.0.0. This is a wild card.
You're you're telling, accept everything,
you know, and anyone who's trying to connect
on any IP, any interface onboard one, two,
three, just accepted. Because at the end,
it is multi handler, right, we are expecting
a connection on that port. That's why we are
running a multi handler. So we just keep L-host
0.0.0.0. It doesn't matter. It's like a wildcard.
Anything comes, accept it.
That's how you do it. Well, this will be your
listener. You're listening to a connection
and you can always say run and it will start
running. So You said L-host is all zeros.
It doesn't matter. It's a wild card. It's
a wild card. So any, any connection which
is coming to you, it will just listen. They
will listen. I got it. Yeah. Now we are listening
on port one, two, three. It doesn't matter
who is connecting on which IP they want to
connect. So, you know, if we have multiple
network cards, multiple IPS, then it is important
to give it, but 0.0.0.0 Works fine because
now we are saying any IP will work as long
as it hits. Okay. Now, as long as someone
hits, but the problem is this is a listeners
Someone needs to send you a connection and
who's going to send you a connection for that.
You need, you need an exploit. That's what
an exploit does. An exploit will exploit the
vulnerability, send a payload, execute that
payload, and then even open this handler and,
you know, get the connection. But let's say
there will be some cases when you need to
do it manually. There may be some cases where
there is no exploit. You have to do it manually.
So just to give you a practical example, there
let's say there was no exploit here. Let's
say there was no exploit on, you know, on,
on what you were doing. Let's say there is
no exploit about WordPress admin shell upload.
Okay. Let's say it's a, it's another CMS.
And there is an exploit on, on uploading a
shell. How will you do it? You will do it
manually. How to do that. You open the website,
you opened the website and beta.hackerinthehouse.com/listening.
And you go, what is the password? The password,
there is the password we can log in there.
And now we need to find a way to, you know,
to paste a code here. So we need to give a
code on this website. So we need to find a
way, multiple ways are there. You know, you
can see there is something called post, or
maybe I'll just go to post let's click on,
add new and here I can, you know, give it
a title and an article. Basically. It's like
writing article and I can paste some code
here. Right? That's one of the ways there
is pages. I can create a new page in this
website and I can paste the code there. There
are plugins. I can make plugin so multiple
ways, right? So that is what you can do. But
the question is which code, where is the code,
which code relocate that will make this website
connect to you. That code is a payload and
you can create payloads. When you use an exploit.
When you select the payload in metasploit,
it will do all of the work for you. But again,
manual is important because maybe there is
an exploit for that. So you need to do it
manually. So that's why you need to create
a payload yourself manually. How do you do
that? Open another metasploit framework sorry
open another terminal don't open metasploit
framework become root.
I'll just go to desktop. There you go. Now
I am on desktop. In Metasploit framework,
MSF console that we were using was a console
that is used to, you know, use the framework.
There are other modules as well. One of them
is MSF, venom, MSF, venom.
Okay.
And msf. Venom is the interface which we use
to create payloads. Okay. Let's say -p and
here we can create a payload. So we will create
a payload which we just used in this thing.
I'll just Cntrl+C just say show options. And
here, this is the payload which we are using.
So I'll just copy this and it'll say clear
screen i will paste it here, this is the payload.
What we also need is in that payload, you
can enhance it. You can again go. You can
see, we have two options. L-Host L-port. So
we need to give them here. We'll say Lport
equals one, two, three L-host.
Okay.
Equals. Now this is the tricky part on this
listener. We are giving listen to any connection.
We can say zero, zero, zero, zero. Problem
is over here. Here. We cannot say zero zero,
zero, zero. This is the, this is the code.
This will be on the target that target needs
our IP address because that target needs to
connect to us. Is that making sense? Right
here will be your IP. That is not zero zero,
zero, zero. Yes, because that target needs
to know where it has to connect, to check
the IP address. You can easily use if config.
I know my IP address on 0.0.100.9 That is
my IP, right? That's pretty much it. You just
give it the, the payload name options in that
payload. And now you can tell it a format,
which kind of format do you want to use? I
can say dash F for format and there are multiple
formats. And now I'm going to do a wrong format.
I will just say PHP, actually the format you
want to use the raw raw. I'm just using PHP
just to show you the adder. Okay. And I will
output, or let me just do it as it is. I'll
just press enter here. It will give me error,
okay. Now wait for the error
There you go. Invalid format, PHP doesn't
exist. And these are the formats. So you can
create a batch. See, you know, all the different
things. Java perl is there, PowerShell, Python,
raw Ruby. These are basically the languages
or the scripts, which you will be making,
right? So that is what you have to select.
And here in our case, we want to use a raw
What is raw? You know, we don't want to code
it into a language. We don't want to have
a Python file because of course, A website
cannot run python right? If a website is not
going to run a Python file, it will run a
raw code. We just need that code as it is
in our, in our screen. That is what the raw
format is. If I show you what happens when
I use raw format, if I just say, I want to
use that raw format, if I press enter there,
it will put the whole code on my screen.
Now, here you go. So now this is raw cord,
and you can see this will automatically take
the format using the payload. It is a PHP.
So the raw code, which I'm getting is in PHB.
There's a PHP code. And now I can copy this
and make a file. Or this is basically the
code. So I can just copy it here. And I can
go to the website and I can paste it here
for, let's say a paste it I maybe I need to
paste. I can like paste it as HTML text here.
I can just paste it there. And I can say publish,
right? And that is one of the ways of course,
this will not work for WordPress. For many
other CMS, it will work and I will show you
why it doesn't work. If you open this link,
you can see WordPress will automatically remove
that code due to a security feature. It will
remove the PHP code from there. And if, even
if I run that handler, even if I run the handler,
you will not get any connection. I'm running
the handler. If I reload this page,
You can see, I don't get anything because
WordPress has a security feature that it will
remove any kind of PHP script. That's the
problem. But there will be a lot of CMS. There
will be a lot of CMS, different, different,
even custom codes files. They will always
render the page as it is, you know, at the
end of the code, as it is. That's the problem.
That is one of the exploatation, which I can
do the same thing with pages. I know it will
not work. One of the things I can do is themes.
You can go to themes, you can go to editor
theme editor. Now themes are important because
in themes you have, Oh, sorry. I just pressed
back in theme. You can have multiple files.
For example, here in the right side of my
screen, I hope you can see that there are
files you know, header.php or different kind
of files. One of them is four, zero, four,
very, very common file. Four, zero, four.
You can find that and it will be there somewhere.
That's what I'm trying to find. 404. it seems
like there is no 404.
Do you guys see any 404 there?
Yep. That's what I'm going to do now. 2015
should 2015 is not there. Okay. 2016, 2019.
Yeah. Let's see. Four, zero four. Is that
right? Yeah. Yeah, this one, four zero four
template. Unfortunately four is like a common
one. I mean, you can also use the header file
footer file. In this website, I have designed
the website. It is not using the header and
footer of the theme. So that's why I'm not
using footer. Normally, no one designs, custom
footer so that they can not do it. This is
the, this is the PHP code for four, zero four.
Instead of this, I will put my code for four,
zero four, and this is safe. Right. And you
see file, edit it successfully. Now your code
is also on the website. You got your code
deliver? What's the problem execution. How
do you execute that code? That's another challenge.
You need to execute that court in this case,
I may just go ahead and I'm on Google. I mean,
I, of course that that is the normal step.
You will do. Just go on Google and search
how to open four, zero, four
Page on WordPress. Because just to show you,
because if I open normally 404 like this is
the thing and I just type anything in, I press
enter it will not be WordPress 404. This is
coming from the server. Okay. In this case,
it, this coming from the web server, not from
the wordpress that's the problem. I need WordPress
404. I can see 404 template, how to customize,
how to open up , how to fix. No one tells
you how to open it. I do remember something
like if I just try for 404 , will it work?
And it doesn't work, no idea how to do it.
Four, zero four. Let me go in and quickly
check out the 404, I have some notes on my
phone. Let me quickly check that. I always,
always create some notes, you know, on your
cloud or whatever, whenever you're, you're
doing such kind of tests, because future,
it will help just like it is helping right
now. I'm just going to open a file and see
that's true. I'm looking at my end as well.
Yep. There you go. U
Index.PHP. Question a question, Mark. Error404
index.PHP. First of all, let's try that one
You know, we don't want to apply things, which
you know, that works in the index.php question.
Mark error = 404. I mean, that's what my note
says. At least let's see XYZ. There you go.
Page cannot be found and you can see there
is something, I don't know. It's like a but
I'm quite sure it did not work. I mean, if
it would have worked, we would be, it did
not work. That's the, that the end note um
why didn't work, I'm quite not sure this is
the error page, but maybe what I can try here
is the note which I have is 13, 2015. Okay.
Maybe I can just go ahead and change the themes.
So I'm just going to go in as I'm going to
change the theme, and maybe I can try with
that option. So themes, I'm going to change
it. How will I change it? I will go ahead
and say 2015, add new I'm going to search
for anything. And this, this specific web
server is not connected to internet. Of course,
it's a virtual machine. So what we can do
is we can upload a theme for that. We need
to download it. So I'll say 2015. Oh, I just
remember one thing. Okay. And this is the
silliest thing you will, you guys will ever
remember. We edited which theme again, if
anyone remember
Guys, which theme did we edited? 2019, what?
Which theme we are using at the moment in
the website, it has to change. The theme was
2019 because our code is in the 2019. Not
in the 2015, isn't it? Yeah, let's try it
now. Okay. Error 404. There you go. We had
it. Why we had it. It's not loading. It's
not loading because it's connecting to my
system. You can see it is the meterpreter.
Right? Got it. Listening to open. Connection
is coming, blah, blah. That's how you hack
it. I can just say exit. Okay. And now that
page will load because I connect, remove the
connection. You can see it loaded. This is,
this is the part which is in that PHP to show
that, you know, it's in meterpreter In meterpreter
shell, you will always have this part. If
you are getting this part, either connection
has been died or it did not work.
So that's how pretty much you, you do you
know your physical exploit, the machine, you
put a code there, you executed any how you
executed them and you get it. One of the options
was plgins. So I can create a plugin here.
I mean, I can create a manual plugin. I can
upload that plugin. And that should work because
if you see in that, that exploit of the WordPress,
that, that exploit which we used earlier that
was creating a plugin description, say it
was creating a plugin how to do that. I'm
quite not sure you can go on Google and you
can just, you know, search how to hack a website
by creating a plugin and how to hack a WordPress
by creating a plugin. There you go. And you
need to learn how to Google. You know, that's
like 90% of the time. That's your best friend.
You, you always need to Google. Here you go.
Exploit this plugin. I don't know what it
is. Cause you inject your payload inside a
legitimate plugin. Can have it run. Yes, you
can do that. Otherwise you can create a plug
in yourself. It's like plugin is just a zip
file. You know, it's a zip file with, with
two PHP files, index dot PHP and all. And
that's a plug in it.
Making sense, like, let me even show you what
is a plugin? Let's say file upload plugin.
File upload wordpress manager download this
is, this is one of the plugins I can go on
Google and download it manually here. And
I can just say save and where it got downloaded.
It is still working. So you can see a plugin
is basically a zip file. Right? I can .zip
and let it load. Let's open it.
Yeah.
And if you open it, you can see in this, there
are basically, it will depend, but basically
there are file right there. There is a PHP
file in the name of that plugin. And then
there is, there are additional files when
we are creating a plugin for hacking a WordPress,
we just create one PHP file that has that
code and we make a zip and we upload. But
to do that, there's a specific format. I have
done that in the past and I have always used
Google to do that. So you can always find,
you know,uuploading a shell, to WordPress
using plugin or something like that and making
WordPress plugin or shell for shell upload.
You see, there is a video on that. You can
always go and, and by the way, in LPT exam
and in professional pentest in real life,
no one is going to stop you.
You can play videos. You can go on Google,
YouTube. You can go ahead and play that in
the exam time as well. You can do that. No
one is gonna stop. You can go on Google. You
can go on YouTube, watch videos. I did it
when I was giving my exam. I, I went and I
don't know how to use open vas. So I have
always used Nessus. And this is a professional
tool for scanning. I use nessus in my real
life. The problem was in the exam. They did
not give me a nessus. It was a, it was an
open vas. I don't know how to use it. I went
to Google. I went to YouTube. Hacker-Sploit
video. I saw that 14 minutes, video views
open vas. And I used it. No one's taught me
that you can do whatever you want. No one
is going to stop you again.
You can sit here and you will see how to make
a heading 2015. I think I did my research
from here itself and you know how to hack
a word press. They are using footer footer
file. Maybe you can still read that, right?
Yep. They're not giving them about plugin,
but that video will tell you how to make a
plugin case you need. Another way will be
one more way will be a file manager, plugin,
you download it, you upload it. And it's a
file manager. Of course you can upload files
after doing that. Right? If I tried to show
you a little file, add new upload. There you
go. Let's set up that plugin, which we downloaded
here installed and out maximum size. And the
PHP, our file is bigger than that. So maybe
there is a restriction on the website.
You cannot install maximum plugins. You know,
you cannot manually install anything on this
website. So that is possibility. They will
block you, to install things. Maybe your access
will not be there. A PHP environment will
not be there, but in case you were able to
install it, it's a file manager. Then you
can just upload whatever you want. It's a
file manager. Uthere is one more possibility
which you should check whenever you get initial
access. You know, I got the password. What
I should do is I should always go and, you
know, check the available themes available
plugins. Maybe there is a possibility maybe
there will be a theme. So, you know, when
I go to appearance themes, there will be a
theme like 2016 is there and I don't have
any possibility. I go on Google and I say
2016. Wordpress vulnerability
I can see if there's a vulnerability in that
theme as well. Maybe there is a vulnerability
in that theme, you see WordPress theme directory
shall upload. This seems like there's a plugin.
There's a plugin called this theme directory
plugin, which has vulnerability to upload
a shell. So there is a possibility you will
find the plugin or a theme, which is pre-installed
and that has a vulnerability And then you
can exploit that very, very easily. So maybe
let's say this is WAP forms. Like I go on
google and search about this thing. And I
get to know that, Oh, there is a there's vulnerability
to upload a file, or there is vulnerability
to take any kind of different kind of access
using this plugin. And it is already installed
on the system. So I can take advantage of
this. This is your post exploitation. You
are doing post exploitation after getting
initial access, which is the password and
username. Is that making sense?
I mean, if let's say if, if you know our case,
if I go to users and I say, all users, if
I say developer, you can see but all of the
developer here, I think you can see that here,
you see both of them are admin users. Admin
is also, admin, developer is also admin. That
is just a username. But the role that writes
the privileges we have out of admin in case
our rights were not of an admin, we've got
an author or we were just a user authenticate
user. We cannot, we cannot upload anything.
We cannot install new files. We cannot do
anything in that case. We want to see what
is there in the system and can we attack it
or not? Make sense?
Right. That's how, that's how it, it does
works. Right. So we just attacked the WordPress
site. And I think it's quite clear now I will
give you a practical explanation on how to,
how to do work. Like if you have a vulnerable
plugin and how to further exploit I'll do
that later. Not right now, it's not the right
time because we don't have enough knowledge
at the moment because you guys don't have
that, like burp suite is needed. So I'll show
that that's pretty much it. I mean, that's
how you create a shell. That's how you use
Metasploit. I think I'm quite done with risk
class. You know, I, I know it's still early,
but there is nothing else to cover for me.
Like if you guys have any questions, I will
be happy to get them.
Yeah. So my question was just so we know in
Metasploit they have thousands of modules
that are available. What would you,
Know,
What's the best place to start to know which
one you should be using.
Can you give me a situation, like example?
Yeah, just say your hack, you're trying to
hack into the hacker in the house, a web server.
How would you know which module you're going
to employed for that?
You mean as you're asking about exploit?
Mmm.
No more about the payloads.
Okay. So payload, as I said, they are only
two types singles versus stages right now
in those singles versus stagers, there are
only selected types, which you have to use.
First preference is always Meterpreter. After
that your preference should be shell. Okay.
Meterpreter. If that doesn't work. So shell,
these are the only, only two you should be
getting available even in the real life. Yeah.
These are the only two which you will be using.
Okay. how about all those other modules? Like
PHP?
Oh, you mean the architect. Okay. You mean,
this is some type, so, okay. Let's say I am
testing a target, which is a windows machine.
Of course. I know that is a windows, right.
But let's say it's a website. I can go ahead
and, you know, I need to gather some information,
basically. I need, you know, if, if I am on
this website, right. And we all did that,
what web and got the technology profile that
clearly says that it's a PHP. So if I just
go ahead and say what web and I said, beta.Hacker
in the house, it will clearly tell you that
it's a PhP.
Okay.
You see it's, it's running. It's a PHP. 5.5.9
Could you actually jump into the metasploit
and just open up that modules folder?
There you go. Oh, okay. And the folder.
Oh no. If we go back to multi handler and
just like search PHP
Search, I payload. I think that's what you
want to search. Right? PHP. There you go.
21 different payload.
Yeah. So my, so my kind of question is how
would you know, I'm like, I want to use PHP
bind perl over a PHP, find perl IPv6 or bind.
I, I find underscore PHP.
Okay. Okay. Let's take it step by step. First
of all, PHP, you want to sort out of it, meterpreter
is your first choice. Shell is your second
choice, right? That is something you already
understand that you will use a stage versus
single. That is also very much clear til this
point, I think. Yeah. Then it is all about
bind versus reverse majority of time. You
want to get a reverse connection because it
is seeing that people will not allow a connection
coming in, but they will allow a connection
going out in all the systems in all in this
world. If you have a company, you will not
want anyone to connect to you, but you will
want to connect to internet. Isn't that right?
Yeah. That's why you always try to use reverse
first. If that fails binders is your option.
Okay. You just have preferences, just take
simple logic and get the preference.
Binding is your second option. If reverse
is failing, there is a possibility where reverse
will fail. Reverse will normally fail. My
mean, if someone, you know, firewall is blocking,
it's very, very, very, very rare chance that
a firewall will block a reverse versus file,
but a reverse may fail when you're using proxy
or pivoting, when you're doing pivoting or
proxies, it reverse, normally will fail. And
that wasn't the situation where you will have
to use bind. If we were suspending user bind,
if it is not feeling that's good. So it's
like, if you're using Meterpreter is the first,
you know, first priority reverse is the first
priority. Then it is about PCP or, you know,
or HTTP there, there are multiple in PHP.
Of course we don't have a lot of them, but
if it is, let me show you what windows will
make more sense.
There you go.
I'm there are too much, right? And, and this
one, you can see, you got a HTTP, actually,
HTTPS, TCP. These are just protocols. So maybe
that website is having a, you know, HTTP protocol
open. So you can connect over the port 80
or port 440. If that, it really depends on
the firewall of theirs, or they may have TCP
traffic coming in and coming out, they may
be blocking UDP traffic. So in that case,
you may not be able to use it. Uthat that's
basically the protocol. You just have to test
and try. But TCP is the most reliable because
everyone knows that TCP is the most reliable.
UDP is the fastest, okay. Tcps, deniable,
UDP is the fastest, but we, we want rei;ability.
We don't want our, you know, exploit to work.
They get the access and then suddenly just
loses the connection. We don't want to lose
any connection. That's why we use TCP as the
best option. If TCP doesn't work as HTTP is
or HTTPs is your, is your best option. That's,
that's basically the priority order. And it
just comes with the experience. You now, you
know, it, you got the experience now, you
know that TCP is the best option. Yeah. That
makes sense. Yep. Any other questions?
Guys?
No, that's not good. When you're creating
your payloads, always save them. Okay. You
don't want to lose your payloads for a specific
test. So always save them and to save a payload,
this, this angular bracket and give it a location.
So I always like to save them like on desktop,
you can create a folder if you want for the
project, but I can just say you know shell
dot PHP and that's how it works. And that
will make a PHP file which will contain my
payload and always save them because it comes
handy very, very handy to reuse them as it's
a good practice. If one is working on one
system, most probably it will work on all
the systems, you know, because they are identical.
And now you can always for example, a lot
of people say that, how do I know? What is
the IP and port? This, this payload is using
very simple you just go ahead and check the
code. So you're going just say, just go ahead
and check the code here. And then you will
see IP addresses this or port is this. So
there are two variables and you can always
change this. You know, you don't need to generate
it again. And again, you can just take the
payload as it is, just change the IP here
and port here. So that's a quick tip.
Well, with that the sorry!, I'm sorry, I'm
going to say, I noticed you taken a payload
You didn't code it. Right? I did. This will
be, this will be a good stage if you were
dealing with inspires to encode it. Okay.
Right. So let me show that in case I want
to deal with antiviruses. I can always use
encoders. It's very easy. You can just say
msf-venom so you can encode them after making
the code or you can, but then you will use
another tool. Metasploit cannot do that. I'm
quite sure it cannot do that. Otherwise you
can just say PHP Meterpreter I'm just giving
an example here. PHP Meterpreter. Reverse.
TCP right. L-Host, let's say a 10.0.100.9,
L-host 123 -f role. So I'm going to show you
side by side. This is the first terminal split
this terminal. Can I split this terminal or
terminal or horizontally? Yep. So this is
the first code without encoding. And then
I can actually take this as it is and I can
paste it here.
And I can hear by it before giving the format,
I can say -e encoder. And then I can tell
the encoder name. You can of course, go on
Google and find the encoders. Otherwise you
can say MSF venom - list space encoders. It'll
give you the encoders. Metasploit . The best
one out there. Yes, but I don't know how to
spell it. That's why I'm taking it. Oh, and
it is. I think something like that. There
you go. These are the payloads. Let's say
sikatakanai. Is that one? Yeah. Here it is.
Why is the best one? Do you know the reason.
No idea. Okay. It is best because it is a
polymorphic encoder. There is a difference
between a polymorphic versus a non polymorphic.
What is it? So just to show you, if I paste
it here and I will show you what the difference
and I would just press enter now and I'll
tell you, what's the difference side by side.
Okay. Now, can you see this, this code versus
this code? The first one is PHP. The second
one, you cannot tell what it is, isn't it?
Yeah. You can never tell it's a PHP payload
because it's encoded now why other encoders,
you know, are not that good as shikata ga
nai, why shikata ga nai is a polymorphic?
And it is the best, because if you use any
other encoders, which is not a polymorphic
that will use an algorithm, you know, that
will, for example, a alphanumeric encoder
but it will do, it will change your letters,
to numbers. Okay. Like PHP, it becomes something
like three, four, three. Okay. But everyone
knows that it is changing P to three. That,
that is a fixed algorithm in a polymorphic.
There is, there is a randomization. It, every
time you create a code, it will be different.
If I try to do this again, this score will
be exactly different. It will be absolutely
different. If, if I tried to do it again,
I will just do it in the upper hand side.
There you go, though. We cannot read it. So
maybe we not, we will not be able to have
the difference, but let's see still. Let's
see. There you go. Yep. You can clearly see
the difference question Mark. Question Mark.
Question Mark. Something like that. And here,
question Mark. Z question, Mark, can you see
the code is completely different?
Of course we cannot read it, but pattern you
can see pattern is not even the same, right?
So that's the polymorphic. It's always changing
the code whenever it is encode polymorphic.
And that's why shikata ga nai the best, because
there is no pattern in shikata ga nai.
And do you know why it's running a 32 bit
architecture as opposed to like an X 64,
Shikata ga nai 32 architecture. For for the
x64 we have some payload encoders one of them
is xor. So I think they don't have a list
here. Let me check. Nope. They don't have
a list here. You can actually check the list
of using this MSF venom-h. Let's see the l.
We want to list, list the things. So list
this one space type and type is and called
encode etc etc. So have list -L right? So
MSF, venom that's L and then iencoders
One, two, three. There you go. So these are
the 86 32 bits and these are probably, yeah,
these are independent. They, they don't really
care. And these are 64. These are only two
which are x,actually four, which are X 64
earlier. There were two, they might have added
it. I don't remember when this has been added,
but you can either sort it again. The other
form of xor. So what is xor, I think you guys
have attended a seminar or a class on Gates,
you know, electricity, Gates, Xor, and exor,
those companies. UXor is basically the, you
know, bites and zero, to one one, to zero.
That kind of thing. So this, these are the
only four encoders available in 64 bit environments
And these are the 86 bit environments 32 bit.
So you just have to choose accordingly.
So we got three machines today. First is the
pen testing machine. The second is the beta
server. And the third machine is windows xp
machine. Just to sum up with the IP addresses,
you can see our beta server has two IP addresses.
One is in the range of hundred and one is
in the range of 148, right? So dual network
cards and windows XP is also in the range
of 148. And our pen testing machine is in
the range of hundred. So I hope that's much
more clear. Pentester is in hundred windows
XP. Is in 148. We are in different ranges,
but this machine is in both of the ranges.
So this is the common platform using which
we will route ourselves to the next network.
Umhat makes sense. Yep. All right, let's go
full screen. Let's login. Okay.
There you go. We'll open metasploit very quickly.
We will hack the first machine we have everything
set up. That's let's become root Okay. Give
me one second.
Okay.
Oh, it works. So we are in the range, a hundred
let's very, very quickly attack the hacker
beta beta server. Right? So beta.hackerinthehouse.com
I hope it's working. It's working well,i just
open msf console and let metasploit load here.
This is the password and username for the
website. There you go. Let's clear this screen
views exploit webapp. Nope. I don't know.
Let's let's search it. Search admin_shell.
If I'm wrong, there you go. Is it! And we
have covered all of this in the last lecture.
I'm quite sure, right?
Mmm Yes.
Yeah.
Yep. So options There you go set.
That's where a password is this
Copy paste, enter user name developer set
R-host , beta.hackerinthehouse.com,
Let's clear the screen. I think everything
is all set.
Yep.
Run the exploit. There you go. And we got
our shell open. So this one which we have
got is our first meterpreter shell. And I'm
going to background it Cntrl+z enter to a
control+z that to background, or you can type
background there.
Okay. Now let's see sessions.
So you can see, we have one session here,
which is session number one coming from WW
data from this host. And this is a Meterpreter
shell PHP based, running on Linux. And here,
this is my IP address. Okay. Dot nine is me.
I am connecting from port four, four, four,
four. Basically. I'm listening on four, four,
four, four on this IP, which is the server
on this port. So it's a random port over there.
Now that's the whole scenario, but let's go
ahead and interact with the session. So I'll
say clear sessions, dash I for interact. And
I will interact with session number one.
And if I say shell here,
I get the terminal of that web server. Right?
So that webserver now i can control it. If
I do, I if-config,
I can see by doing an IF config, we can very
well, see there are two network cards. This
is the first card using which we are hacking
it, but this is another network card. And
if there is another network card, of course
there is a whole network. There, there will
be other machines. And that's very normal
just to give you a practical insights. Normally
let's, let's see you have the smart TV. Okay.
There was a smart TV, which was having a,
you know, all kinds of networks or all TVs
and, and, you know, similar, similar devices
basically, but connected with a networks.
So your smart lights, smart bulbs, smart TVs,
all of these smart devices were connected
with one network in your company and you have
one of them. And you found out that they also
are connected with another network range.
So you pivot using that TV to another range
and then attack those devices. That's one
of the examples of routing. So, you know,
you just need to find multiple network cards.
As soon as you get multiple Metro cards, you
start attacking them. That's, that's basically
the, the thing now here. I do, it says fine.
Let me close it.
So let's say we know that there is another
network card right. Now. Let me just copy
this very quickly. This range copy. And let's
get out of this. I'll just say exit here and
do not exit the meterpreter I just exited
the shell, but never exit meterpreter. If
you do that connection will die. So all this
background it background the session, let's
clear the screen, and now we will use a post
exploitation tool, which will be a string
sweep, because we want to know how many other
machines are there in that network. That second
NetworkCard, how many machines are there in
that network? That's what we want to know.
So I can just say search ping sweep. And there
is a post exploitation tool, post multi gather
from ping sweep, right? That's the, that's
the tool. Go ahead and check it. So you post
multi
Gather ping sweep. There you go. Let's see
the options. So show options.
And I can see we have R-hosts and session.
Why does it need sessions? Because this will
automatically take this session and automatically
route us. So, you know, we don't have to set
a route. It will automatically help us using
that machine to that network. So if btw, if
I just tried to show you, then you have,
There you go,
Right. If I tried to ping
a machine, now, this is the IP address of
that machine. Let's say I try to ping one,
right? . One. This should be the router. You
all know that, right? This should be the route.
Dot one is always the router Right, right.
If I tried to ping it, it should work. I mean,
if I was in the network, but you can see,
I am not in the network. And just say, it's
time to live exceeded. It's not going to work
because I'm on the network. Okay. That's that's,
that's the thing. However, this module can
ping it. So this module will use this session,
which we have just have that we have caught,
that session will be used to set it out. And
this module will do us do that work for us.
And this will automatically thing. All the
devices R-hosts.
We can set R-host here and for R-host am going
to set the whole range. So I will remove this
.slash 24, because it say 24 network. We'll
just give it the whole name. You want to search
the whole range. You can actually give it
like this as well. So dot.zero two dot let's
say a hundred. So it will take all the IPs
dot zero to dot 24. I hope that's very, very
normal. Everyone knows about how IP addresses
works. Even if you have any doubt, anytime,
just let me know set sessions. Sorry session
and session number. You just have to give
a session. Number of our session. Number is
one. There you go. Let's go ahead and Run
it. Now, can you see, we are getting hosts
here and we cannot ping these hosts, but this
module is pinging the host right now. What
it is doing is as just going there, ping the
host, checking if it is getting a reply, if
it is getting a reply, is it showing us on
this screen? That's what it is right now doing.
Mmm. Yeah, it does. But what could we have
just think the sub-net while the meterpreter
session. I mean, while we have an meterpreter
session going while we're inside that meterpreter
session, there's no command that we can use
to ping
Directly from that machine. Right? So what
you're trying to say is we have a Meterpreter
session. We can open a shell and then ping
it from that machine. Right? Exactly. You
can do that. It's not a problem. That's one
of the approaches. But think about it. How
will you use a tool? Let's say you want to
scan for ports. How will you do that? Using
that machine? You will have to install something
in that machine, right? And in pentesting,
normally you're not allowed to, you know,
change things and install things on their
machines. They got companies. You cannot just
install tools on their machines. Makes sense.
Makes sense. And think about it in this way.
Now we know it's a Linux right now. Just think
about it. It was a router, or it was a smart
TV. How will you install n map or something
on a smart TV,
Right? There are ways sagar ways, but you're
right. I see what you're saying. I hear you.
Right? Right. I mean, so yeah, still let's
say you can install an app or something, but
then the thing about bigger things, you know,
you need more memory, you need more power,
you need more processing. All of that is not
available on those machines. You cannot do
that because your scope will not allow it.
So anyways, we found these machines it was
basically pinging from one, two, three, four.
It was continuously pinging for us. And now
we do have all these machines and we know
that the default is windows XP machine. I
just show you there. Right. So let's go behind
it. .111 Is basically the same machine from
which we are getting the session. So it's
that same machine. Can you hear me? Yes, sir.
Alright. I just had some problems there. Alright.
So let's, let's go ahead for this machine.84.
I just copied this selection and we will clear
the screen now. I mean, this module can do
that, right. This model cannot rout, but what
if I want to do something manually? What if
I want to run an exploit exploits, don't have
this option that we can give them sessions
and, and these exploits can run automatically.
We need to set a manual route. How do you
do that? There are two ways you can do that.
Either inside meterpreter, or you can do that
outside of the meterpreter. Okay. It's basically
the same thing. It's going to set up the same
route, but how do you do that? I'm just showing
for example right now I can just say run,
sorry. I can just say add route add. So I'm
trying to add a rout. And now here, and let's
actually check the sytax.
I don't remember the, syntax too much. There
you go. Route out. Add or remove. You can
remove as well, then sub-net then net mask.
And then the, basically the you know, it's
basically going to be the channel or the ID
or the session ID, basically. That's what
it is. So that all work. So route add this
is our sub-net dot zero and you go and net
mask two, five, five dot two, five, five,
two, five, five.zero. And you can take it
by going into the machine itself and typing
IF-config. And such a number session is one
press enter. Route has been added. Let's try
to print it. So print route sorry route print.
And here you go. Now this is your routing
table. So you are routing all of your network
from this machine, okay? From session one,
basically to this sub-net on this netmask.
So this session one is now your gateway, right?
You're you're routing everything in that machine.
That's what you're doing here. Session is,
is, is what you're trying to do. And you're
trying to reach this. Sub-Net on this net
mask by this session. That's what you're doing.
That's how you add it out. You never add the
IP address of the machine in which you are
as well. You always are the destination, the
sub net. Very, you want to reach which, which
you're not. I that's, that's the destination
subnet. That's what you add here. And once
you have added it, I mean, it's going to be
quite simple. Now you can basically run any
exploit. You can run any scanner. It will
always go through this route. So it's quite
simple. Now, if I try to show you, if you
just go ahead and say and If run a scanner,
let's say let's search for a scanner. So search
scanner.
And we got a lot of them. Okay, let's go ahead
and check. So we got like SMTP scanners, blah,
blah, blah, different kind of scanners, SMB
scanners. I'm trying to find a PCP scanner.
Basically. There you go. Port scanner, app,
scanner, FTP, SIN scanner, PCP scanner, Xmax
scanner. So all these scans we're doing n
map, they're already here, X, max, TCP, and
act. Let's go with TCP, which is the most
reliable in routing. So I have tried sin scanner
earlier sin scanner, normally we'll give you
problems and here's the thing you need to
understand. See? Why do we use sin scanner?
Anyone, I mean sin versus TCP. What's why
do we use them?
Well, Sin is half open. You usually use it
for dos attacks. And it's, but it's more detectable.
Why is it undetectable? Well, sin scan is
more detectable because it leaves open connection,
half open connections versus TCP scan, which
completes that three way handshake. I'm giving
you a CAS response. I know.
Yeah. I think it's wrong. Okay. Let me explain
that. Please send us less and less detectable.
Yep. Yep. And let me explain why, and then
wait, I'm not tripping. Okay. No worries.
So that said, this is our target and this
is me. Okay. So in the first shot, we always
send a sin there. Okay. And let's say, this
is our sin. This will reply back with, and
I know how hard it is. I'm not having my pen
today. Sin act and we will reply with act
and the connection will be established. Okay.
That's how the TCP handshake works. Now, this
is what happens in a full TCP connect scan.
That is a TCP scan in that sin scanner. Basically,
we saw that, how do we know that the port
is open or the close? So this is how we know
how report is open or closed.
Then we are sending the first stage and you're
sending this sin right when we're sending
sin. And we get a response such as a reset,
or we don't get a response. That probably
means that the port is closed. If we get a
sin act, that means the port is open. Okay.
If we got a reset, if we get to you know,
RST, or we don't get a response at all, that
means the port is closed, or there is a firewall,
something like that. The port is basically
not open. That's the response. If they're
getting us a sin act, it means the port is
open. Now we came up with this concept that,
you know, what happens if we just keep on
sending sin, okay. We just, we just send sin
on port number one. Then we send sin on port
number two, port number three, port number
four. Now let's say port number two and three
replies bits in act port number one, doesn't
reply, port number four. Doesn't replies.
It simply means that yeah, port number two
and three is open four and one is not open.
That's basically the, the automatic response
that we know that, right? So why do we even
need to send this act? Why shall we send us
act? There is no reason of sending this act.
This is, this helps us in two things first.
Yep. So first we are saving bandwidth. You
know, that maybe there is a network, which
is not that, not that heavy, you know, it
can be a sensitive link. They're saving bandwidth
there. That's the first thing. Second, is
that any firewall, any ideas, any IPS, they
will only know that you are scanning something.
Then this app is sent, okay, until the connection
is established a firewall or IDs IPS, it will
not be logged. Basically the connection is
never logged. If it is not completed, that's
the, that's the thing where if you're not
even completing the connection, it will not
be logged in, in any firewall. It will not
be logged in any backend server. It will not
be logged anywhere. And no one can just read
the logs and tell so that that's the whole
purpose of a sin scan that it will not be
logged.
And no one can tell that you are doing something
fishy. However, with latest technologies,
anyone, if you talk about SIEM solutions Sor
solutions, they have started to monitor the
sin package as well. So when they see that,
all right, sin packets are coming continuously,
sin packets are coming from someone. They
will understand that that it support scan
and they will block you. So it's quite useless
these days. I mean, seven PCP doesn't really
matter. Both are quite same. The advantage
of SIM SIM in these days is it will save bandwidth
on a low, you know, low profile network. If
the network is not capable of handling a lot
of traffic sin as the best option there it's
not too much reliable by the way. I mean,
if in a, you know, I mean, it's, it's, there,
there can be some firewalls. There can be
some systems which may block the sin act.
You know, even if, even if it is open, they
may block it. So it's not too much reliable.
Packets may go left in, in the middle. So
it's not too much reliable, but it's a good
one to give it a shot. So that's what we tried
to do. It's a good shot basically to save
bandwidth. That's the only, only trick it
used to be undetectable these days, advanced
technologies. It's not detectable, but it's
a good shot. That's the whole thing. But in
our case, when we are doing port forwarding,
and if we're port forwarding, we, you know,
sorry for routing. We are normally always
using the Meterpreter. Now with Meterpreter,
you need to understand a big E okay. There
is a big E what is this big E it's encryption
meterpreter sessions are encrypted. They cannot
be decrypted. They cannot be seen by firewalls.
Firewalls don't know what's going on for them.
It's just a encrypted connection. They don't
know if a port scan is running. They don't
know what's going on. So they don't know if
you're sending a payload. So it's quite undetectable
when you are doing a port scan in pivoting
and routing, it's quite unpredictable there.
So then it doesn't matter. As you can always
go ahead and use a PCB scan. It's more reliable.
And in port forwarding and routing, you are
always looking for reliable is always try
things which are reliable because sessions,
they will die. They die very, very easily.
And the reason you always try to get the reliable
things, let me clear this screen. We will
use an auxiliary, which is a scanner, which
is into, or I forgot, which is into port scan.
Yup, yup. TCP. That's what we're going to
use.
Sin scanner, again, it's not too reliable.
That's why we're not using it. It may A session
may die show options. So that makes sense,
right? I know it's now clear why sin is better
and why they're not using it still. Right?
It does. Thank you said R-hosts, come on,
here you go. So if we are going to set R-host,
then we will set only one specific IP because
we are targeting it. And now here there is
something more than you can note you can always
select the ports. And I never recommend, you
know, searching for, there are some 65,600.
I never remember that number or let's Google
it, but whatever the ports are 600,000 never
you know, scan all the ports in one shot,
always go in you know, sections. So maybe
first a hundred ports, then first 200, a hundred
to 200, then 200 to 300.
So go slowly, just don't push it like 10,000
port in one shot. It's gonna break the connection.
You will lose the route. So you just say it
set ports. And let's say, we keep it a hundred
to 500. So just give it small, small ranges,
divided it into project. It's a project. Now
we are dividing it in small things. That's
first thing we just said, R-hosts. We said,
ports here now threats. So people will go
with five threads, 10 threads. What thread
means, how many ports it will scan at the
same time. So maybe it will send tens sin
package one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10. You know, all those
ports. It sends a send sin package to all
of them in one shot. And then from 10 to 20,
then from 20 to 30, again, I never recommend
this.
I mean, until, until you know that the network
is stable, a company has already told you
that your network is stable. And, and this
is kind of like if it is a gray box test where
you can call them and tell them that, Hey,
I need you to restart this machine, blah,
blah, blah, things take your risk. I never
recommend going more than one because it really
doesn't take that much time. So this go with
one thread, it'll take like extra five minutes,
but it's worth it. A timeout thousand is fine.
A timeout is basically when it will stop this
scan. If it is not getting into this month
delay, you can add a delay. If the network
is sensitive, as I said, concurrency, it's
basically again, how many ports to check.
So basically, you know, thread versus versus
a thread versus concurrency, basically it's
quite same.
Here it is. Port here. It is host the same
concept. Basically it is machines. It is ports.
So the same thing. Ten is, is fine. You can
keep it on one actually. So one is the most
reliable. I'm just going with 10 because I
know my machine is stable. My network is stable.
You can kind of go with least, just always
go with least show options. If I do that again,
you can see concurrencies, 10 at a 001 to
500 ports. We are going to scan. And this
is the IP thread is one. Timeout is thousands.
Let's run it. And there you go. We started
getting ports. So we just got three open ports
and you see it doesn't make really much too
much time because we are at the end. We are
in the internal network and interna; networks
are always fast, right?
That's fine. So at 135 is open 135 is open.
139 is open 445 is open, which are basically
the SMB ports. Let's still go further. You
know, just to show you, if you go ahead and
set the ports this time from 500-1000, so
this is what you will normally do. Maybe you
can just keep it in, you know, a thousand
thousand ranges. So 1000-, 2000 and 2000 to
3000, you can do it in that range normally.
So I'm quite sure we will not get any result
here. You can see no result found, there are
only these three ports open on this machine.
And I know that because I know it's a windows
XP and I have made this machine normally in
a test, you will go from zero to 65,000, whatever
you will do all of them because there can
be services.
There can be services running on, you know,
non-common ports. They can be servers running
on port 5,000. Maybe someone has configured
that there can be web server running on port
20,000, something like that. So it's, it's
even possible companies. They do this kind
of work, their internal portals. They're always
on random ports. So it's a good, you know,
a good way to always scan all the ports. Okay.
Just always scan all the ports right now.
We are just leaving it with thousand ports
because we know that there is no other open
port but you know, you got 135 and 139, 445
right now. What next, anyone scanning part
is done? What's the next step in the methodology?
Vulnerability Nope, it's a Integration, right?
We going to integrate. So we just know that,
yeah, we got a port B, we have scanned it.
But what, we also know that 445 is SMB. I
mean, that's common sense, but what can we
get using the port 445? What can we get using
this SMB? We'll start enumeration. And I have
seen people. They try to do it manually. I
mean, if you are using a framework, you're
doing a professional test. Why will you do
it manually? Even when there are tools for
you, you have paid for the framework to that.
So let's go ahead and search for a scanner.
So I will just say search SMB. That's what
I'm trying to find. There you go. And we got
a lot of them. Let me increase the size. And
now you can see, these are exploits.
These are auxiliaries, and we are always interested
in auxiliaries. This is my SQL. Nope, here
SMB is starting. So now you can, you can scan
from multiple things. You can scan for one,
vulnerabilities here. These are all vulnerabilities
SMB. So MS09, blah, blah, blah. But what I'm
trying to find is an enumeration tool. So
just see if there is some SMB you know something
like that. SMB, SMB, enumeration, those kind
of things you will find. And I can see there
is SMB one SMB SMB genome SMB one shares.
So it is starting. The list is starting right
over here, List starting right away. And we
got some cool ones, right? So the first thing
which I want to detect is I I'm we know that
there is SMB on port 445, but which version
we have not even done version detection, right?
Because it's not n map. It's TCP scanner of
metasploit which is not n map. And that was
the best tool, but we are not using n map.
So for Version detection, I'm going to use
this one. So I need to know if it is version
one or it is. Version two. After that, we
can go ahead and try something like, you know,
users you know shares, you know, domain, those
kinds of things. Let's let's start it. Let
me just go ahead and quickly use this SMTP
one obligue.
Yeah.
So use SMTP one scanner show options. Okay,
here we go. Now I'm set R-hosts. It was 10.0.148.84.
If I'm not from that was a run.
Yeah. That was the IP. I gotta scroll back
up. Yeah. 148., 84. That is correct. Right.
Let's run it. And it completed. And you can
see this host support SMB. We want that's
cool. It is supporting SMTP one because it's
window activity. We know that it's going to
support, but still we get to know that they're
supporting it now what? Now we can go ahead
and maybe search for SMTP twsmto yeah. And
you can go ahead and search SMBP too. So just
testing, the next version, basically show
options and just clear the screen and run
it you can see this time. It doesn't give
me any output. You see it just saying scan
completed? It's not giving me any output.
Now that's very common with auxiliaries. They
will not give you the output if it was not
successful. Okay. That's, that's one thing
to note. If you're not getting anything it's
not successful or your auxiliary was not in
a properly set up, you're not tune, it got
completed.
It's running, but either it is not tune or
it is not successful, but you always check
the options once. You know, and when you check
the options, you can see, yes, it is properly
tuned. It means it's not there. SMTP 2 is
not there. Now why SMTP,2 is not there in
windows XP. I think it was not even created
at that time. So it came with windows seven.
I think when windows seven was released, they
came up with SMTP tool and we went, there
was no SMTP two. So that's why we don't have
it, which is normal. Well, now you got it
right now. You got that. We have SMTP one.
What? Next? Let's try SMTP enumeration. So
how do you do that? Again, a search SMB. Here
you go. We got enumeration users, domains.
Let's go with users. That should be fine.
Let's go with users. So use yes, FME users.
So options. There you go. We need R-host.
We need SMB password user. These are not needed
required are not. You can give it, if you
want in a white hack box test, a white box
test study, we are doing a black box. Really
doesn't matter. We just need R-hosts. So set
R-Hosts better than that. Command here. There
you go. We have the, R-host. Let's go ahead
and run it.
Okay.
Doesn't see any output again. Does it mean
there is no user? No, there must be user,
but it's not, you know, it might be secure
enough that it's not giving us which users
it is getting that point. Yeah. Okay. Let's
see if we have any other SMB tools. So search
SMB again. I'm just going to go ahead and
do it. Let's see what we have here, SMB.
Yes. SMB one, the two and shares. Maybe we
will go with this. Semi version. Okay. What
will this, this is version detection again.
I mean the same thing, which we did manually.
Maybe this may give us more than information.
Let's try it. It doesn't really hurt. I SMB
version is there SMB login? So let's try these
three. After that, we'll see what we can do.
But I mean, once we know that there is SMB
1, we can always try to find, you know, exploits.
And everyone knows that eternal blue is going
to affect SMB 1 as well as, as SMB 2 so eternal
blue is the one which we should be using.
It's quite common sense if you are in pen
testing. So I'm just using it. So options
set R-host and run it. This is SMB version.
And if you go, we got the version hosted running
windows, XP SP3 language.
Language is English. The, the name is the
name of the machine basically, is this work
group is hackerinthehouse? Signature optional.
That's fine. So we got, we got a lot of information
here. It's windows, XP, special pack 3, or
the service factory and language is English.
Why is it giving us language? And why do we
need, there will be some exploits where you
have to specify the language as well. There
are some exploits I have seen them in past.
You have to give the service pack version,
then you even have to give the language pack.
And normally it is, you know, with the case
of servers, there is a web server, maybe windows
server, 2008, windows server, 2013. Those
kinds of things you need manage packs. Normally
that's, that's a good thing. You can get different
here. Okay. Windows XPS, special factory.
What do we do? We go ahead and search windows
XP. So let's say a type exploit . I wanted
to search the exploit and let's say XP. Okay.
Press enter. Oh, there are hell lot of exploits.
And these are not for XP. These are, mix,
but they have XP in there. You know, they
are like XP there in common. So that's the
problem. That's why they're getting it. Okay.
Uthe first one you can very well see here,
Microsoft server service related,upart stack
corruption. This is a very, very common one.
And guys just remember this. It was specifically
made for windows XP and earlier I think it
even works in windows seven, not too sure,
but still this zero eight, zero six seven
net API. Remember this, maybe take a note,
you know, MS08 67 net API, very common. Everyone
uses it whenever they find a web server, which
is like all the web server is going to affect
them.
So I'm just going to use it. We can use eternal
blue, by the way, you know, that was recently
released. You can always use eternal blue
that's of course, definitely going to hack
it, but let's try another exploit. I just
randomly brought it. Now I'm just trying it.
So you can just say, use this and it'll say
info because I don't know how, what to do
or how it works. So these are all the targets
you see, windows 2003 then you can actually
hack windows server here, XP all of those.
Are there XP windows 2000, is there a XP special
pack two? See now language is coming there.
So if it is not English, maybe you will have
a problem in our case. Yes, it is English.
And I think this one is basically our target
English special factory.
Anyways, let's try this. Let's try this special
pack one. Is there yeah, windows server basically.
So I'm just gonna try it. We have check option
so you can check the exploit before running
R- hosts. You can specify r host here. R port
is there SMB pipe browser really doesn't matter
as you can, you can try between both the options
they have given you the options. So that's
cool. Let's try it set r host
And 10.0.148.84 said yeah, r port 1445 is
correct. I mean, we don't need to change it
in case SMB was running somewhere else. Custom
port. We can change it. Five let's keep it
as it is. Let's just go ahead and check it.
So I'm going to say check and target is not
exploitable. Can you see target is not exploitable.
It just comes up. It just tells me what I
can try here before leaving is we can right
now on zero automatic targeting. I can just
go ahead and tell it that. Listen, this has
been windows XP, special factory with English.
Target is six. So I can just tell it that.
Go ahead and drive at six or maybe this one.
I don't know. What is this always on NIX.
Maybe some version, but let's try it. So six
and seven went to go ahead and tell it the
target
Six,
No options very quickly. And now you can see,
we have specified the target. Let's check
it. Oh, it is not exploitable. That's fine.
I set the target a seven.
No, let's check it.
How does not exploitable. That is not going
to work. I mean, even if I tried to run it,
it's not going to work. And if I run it, it
will break the SMB. That's why I'm not doing
it. That's why I'm using tech, but it's not
getting it tells you and believe me or not,
this normally works. Okay. It normally works.
Every windows XP. I have tried it in the past.
It always works. The one which I have set
up, it contains some security features. Maybe
due to that, it's not, you know, I have done
some updates on that. Some security updates,
maybe due to that this vulnerability has been
fixed. And normally in, in, in pen testing,
if you find something like windows server,
2003 or windows server, 2000 or windows XP,
rare case, even if you find that user's exploited
MSU08, MS08 ,067, I think net API. Basically
you can always search that by using search
net API. And you will find all of the net
API APIs, hero six, seven is the one and it
always works. Umust try that I'm just going
to try on more? Uhery randomly. I just going
to try one more, which is this one
I know it's not going to work, but still just
want to try it. Maybe use this show options
very, very quickly. We have set R-host 10.0.10.0..
Okay, let's leave it. It's not going to work
because it's only for windows zero special,pack
zero to one. We are running on special pack
3 It do not work thats why am leaving. It
doesn't matter. I just clean the screen. What
happens there? So you got to know that is
SMBP one, of course you can go on Google and
find how big SMTP 1. But I think everyone
knows about eternal blue and SMTP one V two,
all of them are vulnerable. So I'm just not
going to try it or not.
There you go. These are Eternal, blue variants,
different variants. One of them, which I will
try if I was, you know, doing a pen test,
is this one SMTP sorry. SMB, MS17010. Just
note it down as well. It's one of the most
popular ones. So zero one zero, most common.
I would rather try it if I was doing it very
normal or sorry, this is the auxilary. This
is the exploit. So in the same MSA, one seven
zero one zero Eternal blue. So I would rather
do it. It's not going to work. I know on this
machine, but I'm just doing it so options.
I can see why it's not going to work. It's
not windows seven or server 2008 RP Mmm. XP
was before windows seven. Really doesn't hurt.
You can, you can check it.
I know it's not going to work. That's why
I'm not doing it, but you can always check
it. If it was a pen test, we were doing a
real pen test. You can always check. But thing
to remember here is this one is for windows
seven and server 2008. There are more, there
are more there is this one. If I move my screen
up, there is this one eternal blue windows
eight. This one was for windows eight. Then
there is this one, M S one seven for a PSEXEC.
This one, even this one was even able to hack
windows 10 one, which we use right now. This
can hack windows 10. In many cases. It's not
going to hack in most of the cases. In many
cases, this one can hack windows 10. So really
it doesn't hurt.
You can use it. It's a very, very, you know,
big combination. They are using eternal romance,
syenergy champion. These are all folks of
the same exploit. They just made one eternal
blue and then improved it, improved it, improved
it. The final one was PSEX uh you can always
try to go with this one and that's what I'm
going to do now. So clear the screen. And
of course you can, you can try it with windows
10. It may work. There is a good chance. It
will work show options. Okay. It's completely
messed up. Let me decrease the screen size
right now. These are the options. What we
need to set is required is this is already
said, this has already said, this is not required.
The has already said, this is not set. We
need r hosts. That's fine. This is already
set. Not required. This is already set. Not
required, not required not required, right?
So we only need to set r-host, basically set
r hosts and which r hosts, we are going to
set 10.0.148.84.
That school, we just set it. You can always
tune it. So, you know, you can always do it.
Maybe you can just go ahead and port number,
there are pipes, so you can always change
the pipes and you can download a list of pipes
from Google. You know, you can just go ahead
and search Google, SMB pipes, and list, and
you will get them for windows 10 and old.
Now let's go ahead and check it. Sorry. I'm
not familiar with the pipes. What does that
mean? I'm so SMB basically, is it server message.
Block Its is the protocol and it uses pipes.
It's like technology to communicate, okay,
here's this pipe. So this exploit requires
you to have the exact pipe on which you want
to attack the communication. You know, you
can just say there's like the, the phone number
basically on what you're trying to call them.
Okay. Got it. Yeah. So you can get a list
of them from Google. Metasploit always has
a list. If I check it, can you see target
is vulnerable and that's always, you want
to hear, right. So it's vulnerable. When I
go ahead and say exploit and understand one
thing right now, it won't, we got the Meterpreter.
It works. In many cases, it will not work.
It will either crash your server. It will
crash. The whole machine itself is you are
trying to hack machine will get crashed. It
may sometimes even, you know, crash your meterpreter
the earlier one, which you have the only connection
you have with crashed that, just restarted,
you know, just, just get, just have that first
machine again, set a route, try the exploit
again, you have to do it multiple times. It
always works for me. It has always worked.
Really doesn't hurt, you know, just let's
try it again and again again and again. And
it will eventually work and that's basically
it. So I made a meterpreter session to open.
Now you can clearly see, we are getting the
session from.one, one, two on this port. Okay.
Sorry. What it is.one, one, two.zero.
I don't understand. How is this one, nine
two, one six eight. It has like, I'm kind
of confused there actually. It's mainly meterpreter
doing some mistake, lets check in sessions.
That will be much clear sessions. I don't
know. It's the same one, one, two. One, one
thing, you know, one, one good thing here
to understand is that's fine. Even if it is
saying one, one, two, basically it is routed.
So I think one zero nine as that's the bridge,
right? The bridge IP maybe. Yeah, maybe, but
here, this is, this is what you always want
to check the last one in the bracket. So in
the bracket earlier one, the first one is
our beta machine IP. The second one is our
windows xp ip might be, that is what you want
to take. This that's how it works. And you
can see, you are getting the connection from
NP authority, which is basically the highest
level of user from this machine windows XP
it's, it's a windows shell. So you can just
go ahead and say sessions dash i two. I want
to interact with session number two and oops.
Yeah. clear doesn't work in meterpreter many
are using multiple. Let's try to see if we
can do a lot of things here. Okay. We can
the normal stuff. What I want to show you
is basically migrate and all. So where is
my migrate?
Okay. Okay.
Now you can find that yourself. I'm just going
to show you how it works directly. Basically
for example, if you try to go ahead and let
me just do one thing very quickly. There you
go. So basically if I go ahead and say, PS,
it will show me the list of all the processes
that are running on that machine. And you
can see there are these processes running.
Okay. Now normally what we would like to do
is if you try to see, we will have a process
running for us as well, which will be I don't
know where that process might be in which
name we are using. It depends on the exploit,
but we will be in one of these process. Okay.
We are one of these processes here and we
normally want to change from our port to any
other port. Okay. Now, any of the process,
because maybe someone will close the process,
maybe someone will, maybe the process may
crash. What we want to do is this is like
maintaining the access. We want to change
our process. Number to, some other process.
And, and you always want to go ahead and see
which process is running with the highest
authority, okay. With your users. So I can
see these, these all are running as high,
high end user. When login is the login service,
it's great process. I can just go ahead and
choose it.
What need here is the PID number. So PID number
is 644. So what I can do is migrate 644 and
i can see. So we migrated successfully. Now
you can see migrating from 296 to 644. Can
you see here 2y96, this was the process we
were using. Okay. This was a randomly created
by our exploit. And now we are running in,
in this process. So until a user completely
shut down the machine, the restart the system,
they basically cannot remove us from the system
because we are running as they've been logging
process. It's basically, I think it is the
person responsible for logging users and logging
out users. That kind of thing. Or you can,
you can go ahead and maybe migrate to this
process virtual box until someone closes the
virtual box completely. They cannot log us
out. Or you can maybe just go ahead and am
I migrate one of the processes?
Like IASS really depends on Google search,
but processes are choose the best process
and migrate. That's the, that's the thing.
Now we are, I've been logging. That's that's
one thing. You can, you can do some good work
like screenshot. Oh, so they just, it just
saved on our kali folder. You can go into
your home and you're got a screenshot here.
You can see the screen, your screensaver is
running out at the moment. So you can always
do a lot of stuff with windows meterpreter,
windows one is the most, you know, windows
one is the most powerful one. You can do a
lot of stuff with windows. Uthere is something
called get system. Okay. Let me just background
very quickly. There is something called get
system, oops, sessions. There's something
called get system. Okay. Uwhat gets system
will do is privileged escalation.
So think about it. You are like a non root
user or a lower level user. You were like
given the access of a employee you want to
go up because you may want to learn some commands
and you want to install something. You may
want to do something special. You cannot do
that. Get system were try to do that for you.
And here you can see got system. We are technique
one. So it has got like three techniques.
I think three or four techniques. It will
try to privilege escalate. You automatically.
It's like an automatic installation will work
in. Most of the cases will work. In some cases,
it will not work there. You can do manual
escalation. And we were talking about manual
escalations in another class right now. Just
understand get system is your best shot. Whenever
you have a system and you need to escalate
yourself on this, try to do get system.
So if I do get through I think that's the
command. Yep. Now you can see, these are my
privileges. Okay. I can do all of these things.
What these means, always Google it. So, you
know, what does this privileges do? What does
this privilege do? A lock memory. What does
this privilege to, I'm just telling you, like,
normally you may want to go into some folders.
You may want to search the machine. You may
want to go into some folders, may want to
run a program. You cannot do that because
you will not have the privileges. You will
have limited privileges and then you want
to escalate. So always try and get system.
It will try to escalate you and it will work.
It is a very good one. It normally works.
I get system. If it doesn't work, there are
manual ways. I will, I will show you that
the next other class. Maybe not next, but
yeah, I will show you. It's a good one to
remember get system. One more persistence.
So, yep. Sorry persistence. Doesn't works.
Okay. And even those what's the spelling of
persistent, I think that's correct. Right?
PERSISTANCE.
Yes, he PE R S I S T E N C E. That's what
I typed. Yup. Okay. let's see why persistence
in working for not working metasploit. I mean,
that's basically what you always do. Just
go on Google and try to search persistance
not working. And guys, I'm just telling you,
if you are considering LPT exam or something,
similar, learn to Google. Okay. You need to
learn to Google every singlesecond. Whenever
you have a problem, whenever you're want to
find some, always run Google screenshot, you
run persistence. Oh, okay. Run persistence.
I see
And this did not even persistence. I'm destroying
your I'll do it myself. I'm basically in persistence.
It's a script. I just remember. There is also
a post exploitation module, by the way, if
you search for that here, I will. Just say
background. So background clear the screen
search fork persistence. We've got a lot of
them. We got a lot of them. Okay. I do think
this is the one. So we only have two ports
here, right? Three ports and windows as this
one as a manager. And it's a persistence.
Maybe this one is the one that you can use.
I'm not too sure. You can run this script.
So run persistence in the meterpreter and
you just type run persistence and then the
command line. That's how you can do it. Use
this show options.
The name call no this is not the one. This
is not the one. Anyways. You can always run
this script using it. I'm just showing you
using this blog, how this works. Okay. So,
and this one, basically what persistence will
do is it will create a reverse shell, which
will automatically you know, start then someone
restart the system. For example, if right
now someone restart the system, I will lose
this shell. This, the shell will be gone.
There will be no connection. Coming back to
me, it's a reverese shell, but I will not
get anything. If something is restarted, because
meterpreter always works in the memory, it's
basically going to your Ram, your memory.
It's not stored in the hard-disk. It's going
to memory with persistence, we store it. We
store the meterpreter on, on, on, on the hard-disk
so that whenever the system is restarted automatically,
that triggers and we get a reverse shell.
You can do that with this. So I can see port
P -p port. They're using HTTPS ports. You
know, as I said, not too much exploits, they
are non professional hackers. We use one,
two, three, normally four, four, four, three
can be blocked that by -R is the IP address
of yours. So this will be your IP address
on which you want to get the connection back.
And that I think is the interval. So every
30 seconds, it will send you the connection.
If you're not getting anything, it will just
send you the connection. Every 30 seconds
and dash L. And this is the location where
you want to store that script. -X, I'm not
too sure. Maybe it is to execute this script.
Every second, you can check the options, right?
So you can just say, run persistence dash
help, and it'll tell you all the options.
-L, I'm not sure what it's going to do, but
this is the, this is the structure. And if
you even copied this line, as it is, does
change the location like i am don't, don't
do it in C, C is very common. Do it in like
a temp, temp folder and interval set it yourself,
port you can change r you can change, but
that will make it,uyou know, that will just,ugive
you persistence. Every, every time system
is restarted. You will get the, you will get
the persistence done. You'll get the shell.
If I just try that, I'm not sure how this
will work. Ups run for persistence. It's just,
there you go. No, run persistence dash dash
help.
It doesn't make sense. Okay. Persistent. I
dash h will it work? Yeah, here you go. You
got the option. So -h is automatic. It will
just take the machine ID automatically. -l
Was the location - X was the automatically
start the when system boots. So every restart,
just start this that's the persistence right.
Automatically starts when user logs in. So
you can always give these options right. In
an interval, as I said and interval and port
and the remote IP. Right? So that is how persistent
work. You can always set this up. Yeah, here
it is. So you can try it using exploit windows,
local persistence. That that is that it's
a local exploit. You can always run it. It's
going to be out of scope. I'm just telling
you if you're consulting something like LPT
exam, it's going to be out of scope.
You are not supposed to set a persistence,
but in professional testing and real life
testing, if you are doing a test, of course,
it's not going to be one day work. It will
continue with, you know, multiple days. It
can, it can go two months. I have done tests,
which are like three months to test. In those
tests, of course you need a lot of persistence
and you try to establish persistence at that
time. That's pretty much it. I think the concept
is quite clear. Right? How do you set up a
route guys?
Yep.
The concept is quite clear, right? Yep. So
if I just do routring, okay. Can anyone tell
me how to remove this route? I mean, you guys
know how to set it. Of course. You also know
how to remove it. What's the command remove
right? Route remove then
sub-net netmask gateway. That same thing.
Okay. So ten.zero.148.0252252225 dot two,
two five, two, two, five.zero session number.
Let's enter route remote. Okay. And route
not found it right?
Oh, yep.
Yeah. I would remove, if you try to print
a route, you don't have anything, right. That's
not how it works, but you can also set route
in one more fashion, just telling you one
more quick way in case this doesn't work in
your exam or anywhere this sometime doesn't
work. You can use the auto routing feature.
So for auto routing, you need to go into the
session. So session number one, the original
session here. If you are in this session,
if you have a meterpreter, you can use auto
route, so run auto route
And then dash S and just give the sub-net.
You just give me something one nine, two,
Oh, sorry, ten.zero.one 48 dot 84. It will
do all the work for you. It'll select this
session for you. It will select the sub-net
for net mask for you. You don't have to do
anything. You can see finally adding route
this with this sub-net via the session. So
automatically does all the works for you.
Very, very good thing to do. The, the only
problem is it says scripts are depreciated.
So it's going all, you know, they are not
updating it. Maybe they will update it someday.
Right now, they are not updating it. That's
the only problem, but it's, working till you
know, in these days it's working, try it whenever
you get a chance auto route is a good one.
Otherwise you can always set a manual route
as I show you right at anyone. If you try
to print a route , you can see it's the same
route, which we did manually. It has done
it automatically.
Right. That makes sense. Yup.
All right. I think it's quite clear how to
route and how to do all this work. I hope
you guys are much more clear and you can,
you can practice that. Any doubts?
I do have a quick question though. Can I share
my screen with you? Yep. Okay. So, Oh, so
I was doing a little bit of practice I'm with,
I've only gone through, like I said, half
of of, of the first video. Let me see, can
I see my Oh, no. You're sharing so I can share,
let me stop it. Okay. Yup. Okay. Let me see
that screen real quick. Okay. So I, I started
doing some this goes back to day one. Where?
Can you see it now? No. Oh, I'm sorry. I thought
I click on share my fault. Please. Forgive
me. All right. So,uso yeah, so day one, just
kind of do a quick recap. You at, what was
that right here?
Hey, send that, send those notes to me once
you attend it
So far. So you had showed us how to do WAP
scan, WordPress scan. And so I went ahead
and curious started looking at courses. Uone
thing that kind of struck my,umy attention
I started with not doing here seriously, there
was about a key. Oh gosh, I'm sorry. I had
it all ready. Like I said, don't have it as
ready as I thought I did. Alright. So one
of the things on the scan. Oh Lord mercy.
Sorry guys. I thought I had this on hand.
Oh, that's very, I think fairly, I think that's
a screenshot. Hold on. Maybe I'm just, just
feeling, Oh, here it is right there. So you
can see that right there. So I was curious,
you know, it had an exclamation point, it
says, m
Oh, okay. So yeah, so that's a website and
it just gives you the register link there.
Right? So you can always go ahead and register
on this link and provide your API key. And
with that, it will actually do better vulnerability
scanning. So right now, what it is using is
it's using a database. It just downloads a
database of vulnerabilities and uses that
locally. But using this, it will use a, you
know, online check. So that's, that's the
thing, but at the end the free version, not
worth it. I mean, it's just 50 requests. Fifties
is very, very less, okay. 50 requests are
already less. If you are doing a professional
test, it's definitely worth it.
Yep. Got it. So let me just, okay, so, so
the way it works now, what you're saying,
the way it works now with WAP scan, it pulls
the database and then scans it.
Yeah. So when you start the WAP scan for the
first time, or normally it will, you know
with, with time, it will ask you to update
the database. So whenever a significant changes
made, it asks you to update the database.
So it downloads a file from the server.
Right?
Right. The problem with that is it's not real
time. So WAP scan the database is not real
time. Every time you are doing a scan, you
have to update it manually. So there is an
option WAP scan that update, something like
that. You can check in the help menu. Got
it. So you always have to update it manually
before doing this kind of scan.
Yep. Got it. So basically what I'm saying
is you can buy a service that will automatically
update it for you, for you.
So if you buy the service, it will basically
do the scanning and it will take the results
and it will send the results to this website.
This website will process them on the cloud.
It will find the vulnerability on the cloud
and send the data back to you in WAP scan,
and then it will show you the results.
Oh, okay. So it's like all those scans, like
on a regular daily. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So that's
a new vulnerabilities. It's like keeping tabs,
keeping a tab on your target.
No, I think no, no, no, no, no. I think it's
not good. It's basically the same thing. You
got a local database, they got a remote database
on the cloud. That's the only thing they can.
Okay.
I mean, you're not processing things on your
machine. You're processing things on their
machine. That's the only thing, that's it?
Okay. So it's a paid service. So it's much
more detail it's they got new vulnerabilities.
So every second they update vulnerabilities
that's quite different, you know? So if there
is a vulnerabilities found like 10 minutes
ago, it will not be in WAP standard. Maybe
it will be in that website.
Got it. Okay. All right. I'm back on the bus.
Thank you. Alright. Appreciate it.
But I like to do it in manual. You know WAP
scan will give you the results, right? It
will send the same result to this website
and you can much better where you can take
the results and Google it. You can, you can
take the plugin name and Google the name and
that's much better way to do it using a service
automatic. You know, if I have to use automatic
in my company, why would I even hire you?
Right.
Exactly. Right, right. No true.
Being a business owner. I can buy the tool.
I can buy the service. I can run it. Then
what's your need? That's the need of a professional
tester. You have to do it manually.
True. True. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. That one was
just wanna recoganize by. So I was, I was
curious to know what your thoughts were. Let's
go ahead and quickly up on our terminal and
you know, do the usual stuff, get the shelf
as the fall. And then we'll talk about.
You know, advanced pivoting which is port
forwarding and all of that over pivoting
So console. But before that, let's pick a
root. First, you go your root kali is the
password and MSF console.
Yeah. Let me just push this thing down here.
Maybe.
Yeah, that would help. So So
Let me go WPA,. And we should actually start
with persistence on this anyhow, and we have
to do every copy. Copy. Copy, copy.
Alright, so use this show options set. R hosts
username, which is developer.
And by the way, you can use the console as
a terminal. Very, very normal. So, you know,
for example, if I have those notes on my desktop,
I can just create a tab
Desktop slash norms
And it will work just like a normal terminal.
It'll execute that command and I can, whatever
I want, basically, it's just like, it works
as a normal terminal as well.
So that's a handy thing.
I don't think we need anything else. Let's
clear the screen and run it. There you go.
We have the Meterpreter and let's go to shell.
So now we are in this shell. Let us suppose
our target scope says that hack the beta machine
and then have the, and a second machine, which
is a media server. And let's say we are told
that the IP 10.0.148.217. Then first thing
will be to of course, try to ping it. So thing
10, zero.one 48 dot two, one seven. And we
are ping it from the machine which we had
because that's, that's going to have a dual
card and after we are getting the ping, that
makes sense.
Yeah. did you need to do the route out again
or is that no. So of course you will need
to do that. What I did right now was I just
did a ping from the machine itself. So I am
in the shell If you see that shell means I'm
getting that machine. Right. Gotcha. Yeah.
So I was not using my machine to send this.
I was using that machine to send it and we
will add the route now. That makes sense.
Yeah, that makes sense. Alright, so run auto
route. Oops, but I don't know the route. And
then ten.zero.one 40 eight.zero/24 enter.
And that gives them that, that answered right.
Added the route. You can see the last second
line let's background. The session they'll
go. That is the shortcut. By the way, you
can type a background itself. If you want
to do that clear route print.
There you go. Now we have that route again.
So now once we have the route, we should be
able to do whatever we want. We know our target
is two, one seven, what to do first thing,
first scan reports. Right? So use auxiliary,
scanner port scanner, TCP. Enter set r host
192.. Sorry. 10, zero.one 48 dot two, one
seven. Yeah, I two one seven. Right? I think
we don't need anything else. Let's run it
here. Here you go port 80 is open? Which means
it's a web server. Of course they named the,
just media dot hacker in the house. So of
course it's webserver, but let's wait for
it. Let's see if anything else comes up and
I'm just telling you, there's nothing else.
That's just the one port, a port 80. And that's
what we're going to, I try, but you can, you
can actually be it if you want.
I'm going to leave that. Okay. You guys can
read it if you want. Right. That makes sense.
I mean, I just know there is only one for
why to waste, but if it was a test, of course
you have to do it, are you getting that point?
Yeah. So let's say now one, suppose we know
what is, I mean, there is something on port
80. What we can do is maybe we can try to
search for something apache scanner or something
like that. I mean, virgin scanner for Apache,
we are not sure, but let's try that. So search
and we don't know which service it is. Maybe
banner grabbing. Do we have something called
banner grabbing banner? Okay. No search results
because spelling is wrong. Of course banner.
There you go. So we have a, do we have a banner
grabbing here? No, I don't see that. So we
have IMF version scanner, not SMTP version
scanner. We don't have a banner grabber. I
mean, FTP. We have one I don't see any other
banner grabber it there. Okay. When you're
stuck with that, maybe what you can do is
go on Google and search and thanks. You need
to learn this. I mean, whenever you are stuck,
you have to go on Google and search. Okay.
So how to do version detection in Metasploit
Okay.
SMTP version detection. Here you go. That's
what I was looking for. Even you can, you
know, service identification. So there is,
there is a post there, maybe all of these
helps it's helped a lot. And this is something
you should learn how to, how to go ahead and
do that. So, yeah. Okay. They're only talking
about two services SMTP may be and rapid seven
is the best website, best website because
they are the creator of the metasploit. SMTP
Version detection. There is a module it's
using is auxiliary SMTP SMTP version.
Okay.
Well it seems it there you go. Clear the screen
and I will actually take the visit itself
from here. So use this copy. Okay. Paste Why
this tab open. Close it. There you go. Now
we are in that show options. So r host, which
is required port is. Okay. SSL, of course,
you know, if it is on four, four, three, you
will make it true. If it is on port 80 make
it false thread, that's fine. You can keep
it one. So what we need is r-host. That's
the only thing. So set r host. Here you go.
Run it. Now let's see what comes with some
information
Until it is, until it is working. What we
can do is we can try to go on this. Oh yeah.
We cannot go on this website because only
Metasploit is the part which, you know, only
metasploit is the framework with just having
that route added. Okay. Your system is not
having route. That makes sense. I mean, you
cannot open this. If you try to do that, it
will not work. Let me show you, it will, it
will basically not work because you don't
have any, any kind of connectivity between
your computer and that computer. It's just,
Metasploit, has a connectivity you could in
session. Is that making sense?
Yeah, it does. All right, but we have a solution
for that which is a SOC server. We can open
a Soc server for that or, or port forwarding
two options. This is not working for some
reason maybe, and this is very, very normal.
I mean, on, on routed things, it's, it's always
the case. The really fine. We can post this
and we can try to use other methods. I mean,
that's why we have other methods. So one of
them is using a SOC server and one of them
is using the port forwarding. Port forwarding
is the easy one. Soc server is, I mean, port
forwarding is basically more reliable Soc
over, does not that reliable. I'll tell you
both of them first. Let's can you quickly
just describe what a SOC server is? Okay.
Have you ever heard about proxies?
Just like proxies, right. So what we can do
here is so proxies are different, different
protocols, different, different pilots. PCP
is there UDP is there HTTP is there SOC is
there, these are different, different types
of protocols. What a soc server will do is
this Metasploit console, because this has
the access to that range. Now with, with that
route, this will become a proxy for our whole
system. And we can set up that we can set
up that proxy and due to that, we will be
able to use Firefox n - map, whatever you
want. Everything will work because every traffic
will go through Metasploit as a proxy Metasploit
is sending that to beta server as a route,
a pivot, and then beta server is sending it
to the final destination. So it's going through
Metasploit as one more intermediate pivot
and getting that point. Yeah. So that is,
that is what you can do in SOC server. That's
easy. That's easy enough. Before that I, you
know, let's, let's go ahead and try port forwarding.
That's a kind of issue. No. Who do port forwarding.
You need to go into the session of the meterpreter.
So sessions one.
There you go. And now you can just type port
forward. Write port FWD. They, they just keep
it low profile. Now here you have three options.
-l Oops -p -r. Okay. Now what does r r is,
the remote host? So ten.zero.one 48 dot two
one seven. That's your dash R dash p and L
are the ports, which you want to forward.
So -P is the port on that machine, which you
want to forward, which will be port 80 and
dash L is the local port where you want to
forward. This can be anything, but normally
we will keep it same. So port 80. So therefore
it becomes my port 80, I guess that's what
we are doing. And before I go to right out
here, add it, add, press enter. Now we have
a local PCP relay on this machines port, 80
coming to our port. And if with that, we try
to, you know, open our local address one,
two, seven.zero.zero one,
Which
Was not working earlier, but now it should
work because we just added a port forward.
Yeah,
I was just login. Okay. you got any ideas?
Why it may not be working? Okay. What I want
to try here still, what I want to try here
is just try to, you know, Oh, did our session
died, I that's, that's what I'm thinking because
cshell is not working as well. Okay. Shell
is not working as well, and it should work
added running shell timeout ablation. Can
you see that's possibly our, our session is
not working properly. What I'm going to do
is I'm going to close the session, first of
all, and remove the port forward. And it really
doesn't matter. You can, you know, keep that
running, but it's a good habit to remove it
and I will exit the session and let me open
that session again. So the exploit which we
were using.
Okay.
Where is the exploit? There you go. And let's
get this session again. Session two. Okay.
Now just does, you can see, you see the port
is not responding at all right. Now. Let's
go ahead and add a port forward So one to
seven zero zero one, which is our local IP
doesn't work. That's really fine. We can just
say now port forward and I can bring this
command here. Yes. Enter. And let's try to
do it now. And you can see this work. So it
has hacker in the house media. You can see
that title there. It's loading now though,
it's taking a lot of time, but it is going
to work.
And that makes sense, right? There you go.
Now loading up. Yeah. No, it's, it's not loading
properly anyways, but it is still loading.
Okay. That's, that's one of the things and
why it does it you know, this problem is very
common. It doesn't loads things won't load
because that somebody's expecting a domain
name. Again. Normally they are not expecting
you to be running it on a, on a IP address.
They are expecting, you will be running it
on a domain name. That's what they're expecting.
And you can just, you know, go in your host
file and add this thing in your host file.
So you can just go there. And you can just
say nano, edit, sorry. Nano Exe. Host's okay.
That was host as not post. There you go. And
for example I have this IP, this is wrong.
Let's keep it one to seven.zero.0.one. Let's
close our control X by enter. And now possibly
this will work in a much better media .hacker
in the house. And there you go. Now this is
loading. Absolutely fine. Perfectly right.
Can you see that? Yep. So we got a cool login
panel, a click click bucket application. There,
you updated the host file. You said I just
added the host file with the entry. So normally
what happens is, you know, if you have a company
and you are having an internal website for
the company, you will not keep that on, on,
you know, IP addresses. You will rather keep
that on a domain names, right? Internal domain
names, which only company users can open.
So that, that, that web server or the website,
it was not working on. Uwhat do you say it
was not working properly on the IP address
because it was not expecting the IP address.
So we just added our local IP to media or
hacker.com because our local IP is being port
forwarded to that machine, right. That machine's
IP. So at the end, our local IP, and that
machine's local IP for port 80. It doesn't
make any sense. It's the same thing because
of the port forward, right.
Port 80 on this, this IP, our local people,
data on this IP is equal to port 80 of that
target. Is that making sense now? Yeah. All
right. And we have access to our local, so
we just add the local here, and then we just
added this entry here. Right. So now, if we
are going to this IP, our browser is taking
us. So if we're going to this URL, our browser
is taking us to this IP on port 80. Okay?
Okay. So now we have the website. I mean,
that's the first way. So that was the first
way, which I wanted to show you. And now you
can, you can use it very, normally everything
will work as the admin is there. You can use
it very normally. That's how it normally works.
Since you have the port forwarded, you can
possibly go and run something like n map or
something like that. So I'm just going to
quickly show you and, n-map then one to seven.zero.zero.one.
And I think that is the IP.
Here you go. Port 80 is open. And of course
it is open because we only forwarded one port.
And I normally, you would actually like to
go ahead and specify the port as well, to
avoid confusions, only add the port, which
you have you know open and maybe just try
something like SV Virgin detection or dash
eight to aggressively scan it. So let's hope
we get the version of this Apache. So now
we are using n map. We are scanning the machine
in the range. I mean, the machine, which is
in a range in which we are even not there.
So it's like over a pivot. We are scanning
it over a PCP scanning. So we have the Apache
httpd two, one, four eight seven. You can
possibly go ahead and try to find some exploit
on this. I know there is no exploit on this
understanding it serach exploit.
I know from my experience, I know a 2.4 0.7
is a very secure version is a very stable
version. You can go in and try to find it
here. But you will not get anything, 2.4 0.7.
There is nothing like 2.4699999999999998 in
this list. So you will not get anything there.
Okay. But in a pen test, and if you were not
aware of this version, maybe you will go ahead
and do a research using some tool like searchsploit
and, and to see if there is any vulnerability
or something like that. I will come on this
part as well in another in the next class,
basically how to find exploits, how to, you
know, search for them, how to exploit services
or service exploitation. We will do that in
the next class. Today we are basically talking
about port forwording and all that kind of
stuff. Okay. I do hope you are now pretty
clear how port forwarding works and you won't
even have to add a route to do port forward
because you are doing that from the meterpreter,
not outside the meterpreter. Okay.
Okay. That is making sense. Yeah. Yeah, no,
it makes perfect sense. Port forward. Add
your local port. It can be anything I can
just add, you know, dash one, two, three dash
88, dash four, four four, four. And dash p
is the port, which you want to forward. Dash
r is the host on which you want to forward.
So port 80 of that machine becomes my port
80, anything I wanted, I can do that. And
then I can just access that port using one,
two seven zero, zero one, right. What comes
to mind is FTP, right? You can put forward
FTP over here and in, in this dash L it's
your choice. You can keep it 80. You can keep
it for 21. Just, you know, you need to remember
which port you have forward it on which, right.
Right. So if we go ahead, let me just remove
this very quickly. Make copy. I mean, that
was this method third.
Now I'm just going to, I mean, that's the
best method, by the way, it's, it's, it's
kind of the much more you know, suitable method,
but it takes time. This, this takes a lot
of time, just think about it. You've got like
20 ports. You, you will have to open your,
you will have to forward all of those 20 ports,
and then you can work on the machine. This
takes a lot of time and it's not suitable
for, you know, very, very quick. Maybe it
was like a quick test. You were, you were
trying to do, you are trying to do something.
It came to your mind. Then SOC server is one
of the options and soc. And what is kind of
you know, it's kind of a, it's kind of a good
concept to understand. So what you can do
is you can, you can do soc server by let's
search, whatever. So I'll background the session
clear this screen and soc server SOC
Soc soc, by the way. Sorry. That's that's
so s I've heard on the spelling. I think it
is SOC. Okay. Soc, there you go. You can open
a soc server. I mean, you can open HTTP server
as well, a TCP server as well. But I think
soc is the most reliable in terms of the protocols.
There is soc five and four eight Now I have
personally tried both of them and soc five
doesn't work for me. Okay. It never worked
for me for that reason, port 84 a for a protocol
is as much better. I think this is more reliable
that doesn't work for some reason that doesn't
work. Let's use it, show options. Now, when
you have to do is you have to just set the
server port and a server, a host. Okay. So
several hosts let's keep that, you know, zero,
zero, zero, zero doesn't doesn't really matters.
Server port let's change that. So set SRE
port. Okay. And thats how we port. And then
we can just say something like,usix, six,
six, six, and randomly, I'm just giving Even
SRV host. You can change it if you want. So
let me redo that. Uhr let's, let's keep it
as there you go. We are now running a server
Sod server starting it. So let's wait for
it
Starting and starting. So I think what's going
on. It's taking a lot of time.
No,
Yeah. It's still working. Okay. And on command
now it's giving me those things. Anyways.
I think it has started. What you can do is
you see, this is job. You can actually just
say job. Maybe jobs dash. I know you can,
you can basically say job and it will show
you every job running. So jobs, zeros running
there, you can just say job dash i zero it
will show you what is, what is it running?
So it's soc server running seven port 0007
server port is 6666. So now we have a proxy
running, which is running on 0000 on port
66, 66. Okay. That's the proxy. But I mean,
so now, whatever our Metasploit have access
to, we also have access to the same thing.
That making sense. I mean, the, the connections,
which metal sploit has access to, we will
have access to if we, you know, connect to
this, this as a proxy, but our Metasploit
doesn't have any connections because we have
not set the route as well. This is this, this
is not a port forward. This is just giving
the connection of the MediSploit to us. So
we need to give Metasploit the connection
first. So I'm going to add it out here. Sessions.
one. No, that doesn't exist to yep. And then
run auto route dash S 10, zero.one 40 eight.zero/
24.
Oh, what does it say? Okay. I added two times
full stop. Yeah, there you go. Now it's working.
You can background it. And now whatever our
metasploit has access to, we have access because
of this we're running. So we can just take
this,
Then go to our Firefox. And now if I refresh
the page, by the way, it will not work. Yeah.
It is not going to work. You can see if I
go ahead and open my preferences and I set
up a proxy here in my Firefox. So manual proxy,
and we are going to set SOC proxy, right?
So soc proxy hosts the zero, zero, zero, or
this six, six, six, six. This is a sock for
proxy. Okay. I'm trying to do that. Not working.
Oh yeah. It's just all soc proxy. So every
other thing is blank. We are not using HTTP
We are not using SSL FTP soc proxy zero zero,
zero, zero on four, six, six, six, six. Let's
try it. It should work. And now we can directly
use that IP address. So we don't need to use
one to seven, whatever we can use that IP
directly because Metasploit has got access
to that IP. You do the route and we have got
access to that IP due to the port due to the
SOC server, which is running on metasploit
. So,uten.zero.one 48 dot two, one seven.
If I press enter, you can see website works
absolutely fine. That makes sense.
We just added a proxy there. We just added
a proxy. Yep. I soc proxy, which is, which
is connecting to two metasploit and it is
working over there. Now the beauty of this
is you can use any tool. I mean, see, we added
a proxy, right? So we can actually, we can
use any tool to be configured with this proxy,
but how do you do that? Like, is it possible
to use any tool with the proxy? It's kind
of I mean, just think about it. Like any tool
with the proxy is like there should be an
option in firefox. There is an option to configure
the proxy, but it's not mandatory that every
Googler will have it. So for that, there is
something called proxy chain. You can go ahead
and set up a proxy chain, nano proxy chain
exy, proxy, chain dot config. That enter go
to the end very end. And you will see proxies
here, SOC for proxy, port and six, six, six,
six. I'll just change it. And even if this
entry is not there, you can add it yourself,
SOPs for space your address.
And it is always a good practice when you
are starting your server, by the way, it's
a good practice when you're starting the server,
make the port 127.0000 instead of having all
the ports, what all the domains mean using
to any interface it's like, it's not specifying
any hosts and interface. It's always a good
practice to keep it your local host. I'm just
going to try it. Not sure it will work with
00. Let's try it, save it. Since we have the
proxy chain. Now we can even ping that machine.
We can do whatever we want. So what we have
to do is proxy chains by proxy chains, space,
whatever you want to use, let's say you want
to ping ping space and the IP ten.zero.one,
four, nine, four hours. The IP 10.0.148.217
I enter. Okay. It doesn't work. So I was expecting
it work. Okay. Let's let's, let's wait for
that. Let's wait for that. Uis something else
gonna work is w get connecting to that connection,
but refused. Okay. Connection refused. UI
don't understand why connection refused when
they connect to the server. Maybe our proxy
is not working.
Yeah. Adjust the payload to a bind payload
instead of a reverse and some other things.
I mean, there is a lot of things we can manage,
but,ul port, let's say nine to three, four,
roughly just L host. Uyou can give an l host,
let's try to run it. We will see. Okay. It
says, following you have to give it it's the
same. You cannot. So set L host and let me
give my IPS, you know, not,uwhat is my IP?
I have config, there we go. My IP is, there
are seven, right? So set L host 10 dots, zero
dot hundred dotr seven. I mean, I cannot give
my,uyeah, I mean that, that's the only ip
I have. Right. I cannot give my real IP. So
I'm using IPV six. This is IPV six. I cannot
use IpV six because that does not in the DMZ
rate itself.
I cannot use my local address because that's
only local. So I only am left with this IP,
which is the DMZ one. Let's try this. If that
works, uploading the payload, executing, it
may not give me a reverse. Shell I have a
very bad feeling? There, there you go. No
session was created, right? You don't get
any shell. Why? Because off the, you know,
because of the double pivoting stuff here
you know, you're pivoting to a hundred machine
and then you are pivoting to the one 48 network.
So your machine, your machine can communicate
with one 48 because you have you were routing
your traffic, but one 48 cannot communicate
to you. Are you getting that point?
Yup. Yup. That's a problem on the back way,
right? I'm sorry. I mean, in a illustration,
it will be going through the front way, but
the destination wouldn't be able, they cannot
send traffic back to us because they can not
route their traffic through beta server, right?
That is a half way. Middle man. They are their
only middlemen for us. They are not middlemen
for the media server. Let's say with clip
Bucket 4.0 exploit, right? When you see this
one, you will find that this is the manual
of all those three vulnerabilities. This one
is manual way right. So when you see this
manual way, you can easily see if you start
reading this. I mean, this is a text file.
If you start reading this, you will find,
for example, let me just take the same, same
exploit. I mean, you can use other ones, but
an authenticated arbitrary file upload the
same one. So it says here a malicious act
can do that proof of concept. Let's see. Unauthenticated
file upload proof of concept. This is the
proof of concept. It is a curl curl command.
So you can send this signal to do the website.
Let me copy this.
Yes.
Okay. Copy. Let me go and open something like
leaf pad paste it here. So it does in our,
it needs to be in one line. That's why I understood.
Okay. HTTP host. Let me add the IP of that
server. So media dot hacker in the house,
I'm putting the address directly because we
are using a proxy server. Remember they're
using a proxy server. So we can communicate
with the website directly. Now, here, name
any name dot PHP. You can put anything. I'll
just leave it as it is forever. F Dash F is,
I dont know what it is. Just leave it. A file
is equal to P file or PHP. So p file dot PHP,
you can of course put your own file PHP file.
Right? So let me try with a file and I'm going
to make a very quick a file. I'll just move
to the next spot and I'll just make it filed
a dot PHP, a dot PHP. I just put this as a
file. That's normally just for the proof of
concept. So now we have a dot PHP. Now what
I can do here is I can change this file. A
dot PHP to eight dot PHP, because that's the
name of my file. Right? I can take this line
copy and I can come here. I can paste it and
present that. Will it work or not? What do
you guys think might, might work 80%. It will
not work.
Try to see why.
Yeah,
No idea. Okay. Because you are not mentioning
any proxy here. How does curl curl is a command,
right? It is a software. How does curl connect
to this website? I mean, you have a proxy
running, but you're going to use proxy chains
as the making sense. Because curl doesn't
have any option. Yeah. So you gotta, you gotta
mention proxy chains here. So proxy chains
press enter. Now it is connecting through
the chain, right? So let's see. There you
go. You can see success, right? Success. Yes.
File name. It gives you the file name as well.
Extension PHP file directory, where it has
uploaded. It has uploaded in this directory,
right? That's giving the data.
Copy. Let's read it a little bit more. Let's
read the exploiy which we got here. So for
the more vulnerability is also authenticated
with basic privileges, blah, blah, blah. No,
we don't have any information. Let's read
it again. If we have something here. Okay.
Unauthenticated file upload. A malicious file
can be uploaded into the web server by unauthenticated
attacker. It is possible for an attacker to
upload the script, to issue operations, authenticated.
Something doesn't make any sense. Let's try
that. Okay. Let's try that. Where did we uploaded
it? If you see that URL again, the POC proof
of concept, which we just use, we use this
one, right? So we uploaded it in cost actions,
read PHP, something. Right? We uploaded it
there. So first of all, I will open this,
this folder, right? No, we used this one.
Yeah. First of all, I will open this one.
So I think this is the PHP file, which was
vulnerable. This is the folder where the PHP
file is. Right. So I will open the slash actions.
I'm going to open a slash actions, right?
So that file that vulnerable file isn in slash
actions. And this this line says that it is
in this folder. So this is a folder. But because
that PHP file was'nt in slash actions. So
we have put that as well. Now here, let's
see if this works, let's see again, it's taking
time, but you can see, we got the file and
we got three, four files because we uploaded
them using Metasploit. So three files are
using at this point, we did three trials and
one is the one is the one which I just did
right now.
If I see the file name, which I got is this
one, one, five, eight, five, right? All of
them are one, five, eight, five, zero seven
CD. So zero seven CD. This one, the last one,
right? This is the last one. Oh, you can even
see the time. And so 15, if I open this, you
can easily see, this will say, this is a file
because that's what I have written. You see,
this is a file. So we have done it now. Normally
what you can try, if you are not getting a
connection, you can use a PHP shell. So there
is a very common and a very cool one, which
is C 99, C99, PHP, shell. Very common, a very
famous one. Okay. C 99, right? Download you
go. This works. Open, come on. This is the
PHP. I will extract it to desktop.
Okay. How to extract to desktop anyways, I'll
just drag it. I'll just drag it here. I will
change the file name to a.php because that
is in my command. I will delete this change
the file name, but rename a.php. And I can
run this command again, right? The last, command,
which I just did here, I can run this command
again. It's going to take time. It's a heavy
shell. It's kind of a big shell. So it's gonna
take time. I did it. And now we can go there.
Refresh the page. Oh, sorry. Let's go back.
Yep. So refresh the page.
Okay. I mean, we, we, we upload it, right?
It says success. Yep. Success. It's taking
time. And I don't see that. Oh, I think this
is the one 641 KB. And of course this is the
one. And let's verify, you can see eight F
five, seven, eight, five, seven. There's the
one that's open. It may work. It may not work
again telling you, but let's see. It's a very
famous shell. It's heer you go. It's a complete
dashboard. Now you can easily do whatever
you want. You can run commands. You can, you
know, directly run commands in that machine
and you can upload things. You can make a
new file, make a new directory. It's very
powerful. And there is one more, there is
there's one more, which is even powerful than
this one, which is called weevly. Okay. We
weevly is WEEVELY. It's called a weaponized
show. It's very dangerous. We believe you
can encrypt, you can password protected. So
no one knows what it is. This is the gift
code.
So you have to make sure you have a proxy
chain that, I mean, you have to make sure
you're able to connect to the, to that website
for you to be able to do all this. So you
use the C the C nine, nine shell. Is that
correct?
Correct. Correct. Correct. the only reason
I'm using it, web shell, I mean, not a meterpreter
session or something. The only reason I'm
using a webshell is because I'm not able to
get reverse connection. Then again, there
are possibilities. I don't know why I'm not
able to get it. Maybe because I might lack
expertise in that topic. I'm not the best
person to do everything in my team. So there
is a possibility, but I can still, I can still
do whatever I want. It's it's a complete shell.
Okay. So let's say a hacker has already done
this. So from a pen test perspective, how
would we detect this is basically compromised.
Okay. This is easy. This is easy. So this
kind of shell C 99, it's code, is a very famous,
right? The PHP code is very famous. Everyone
knows it. What you can do is you can use a
antivirus or a DLP or something like that.
I might, you know, go ahead and use antivirus
software, something from McAfee or something
from, you know, check. Good, good reputed
companies, a bit defender is one of them.
So you can scan the server or the storage.
You can scan the storage of, of that, right?
Or you can use a web application firewall,
for example, and WordPress, they have something
called word fence. WORD FENCE, not word fence
has a scanning tool. So you click on scan.
It will start a scan. It will tell you that,
listen, this is a malware file. This is a
you know, this is a modified, sometimes hackers
are so intelligent, they will take the code
and they will not upload it as an individual
file. I mean, I have access to the file now,
right? So I can possibly, I can just, I can
move back there. You see, I have all of these
files right now, this admin, dot PHP. It's
a default file. I can edit this file. I can
create. I can edit it. And I can paste the
same shell in that file as well. So, you know,
not, not removing the content of this file,
but also putting content of my that's one
possibility. And normally you will use something
like weevly. So weevly is encrypt shell. You
will use this kind of thing to evade those
antiviruses. Weevly is very hard to detect
you. You'll get people. It's very hard to
reflect.
The only possibility is you're not trying,
trying to check the logs. What happened when
happened? Why do we have this file? Should
we have this file here? I mean, I know that,
okay, there are 20 files tomorrow. If there
are 21 files, why is one file more? Did we
created it? Or what, why is that? Right? So
all those things, now you can see the owner
of this file is a root. So possibly we can
not edit it, but this folder, the owner is
www data so we can edit it. So those kinds
of things you have to remember. So that's
how basically you can hack it. I mean, again,
you can always run the commands from here,
right? So they can always run the commands
and upload whatever you want to upload. So
that's one of the, one of the things, if you're
not getting a connection back, these kinds
of things are what you have to use.
One more quick thing. I mean, if this was
a real, real hacking scenario, if I was not
a pen tester and I don't care about your security
one of the creative ways to do it was I can
one of the curative ways is I can hack the
beta machine using this machine. I mean, I,
I'm not, I'm not running commands here. Right?
I can run whatever, come on. I want, I will
hack beta machine, this machine, and I will
do it myself. So media machine pivots through
BETA to me, okay. Through Beta media machine
pivot to the DMZ 1,000 rate. So now I am pivoting
through beta two, one 48 range, this machine
pivoting through beta 200 range communication
established easily. We can communicate. Now
I can upload a shell and then I can have full
access to that machine as well. So one of
those ways, if it was a real hacking scenario,
I won't care about your security. I will just
break it in that making sense.
Yep, yep. Using this machine, I can have beta
and then get access to. Right. that's basically
it, I mean, that's the quick quick thing.
And honestly, I have uploaded this C99 on
this machine. First time in my life. I have
just, this, this lecture is quite new now.
Also I also got to know that, yeah, there
is a metasploit module for this one and I,
and I did'nt know that earlier. So maybe I
will play with the metasploit module and I
will ask them to, you know, help and get a
reverse connection somehow if we can get that
direct;ly from metasploit, we will try that.
But I, but I guess it's quite clear, right?
If you want, if you don't have the complete
resources, you can always, always, always
do this kind of stuff and you can always,
you know, do this kind of thing. Right? Right.
I start with the web application pen testing.
Now, you know, you guys need experience in
web apps the most, because if you guys go
to a job right now, as a fresher, no company
will give you a job. If you don't know how
to do webapp test. And that's kind of the,
that is the primary skillset they will be
looking for. They may not care about network,
pen testing that much, you know, those services
ports. They may not care about that as the
priority, they will keep the WebApps okay.
That's the that's going to be. Maybe they
will ask you to do an interview or a challenge.
And that challenge, our interview will contain
webapps about that's kind of sure. Okay.
When you talk about web apps, there is a very
good guide or ask testing guide. And the latest
version is four 5th is in development. But
fourth is the latest version. Just open the
first name or ask testing guide, at least
for now, this PDF is very small. Okay. It's
224 pages. This is something I need you to
read again. There's something I want you to
read. They have perfect examples here again.
They will give you every kind of example.
It's the testing guide its going to teach
you proabably everything in web apps or app,
basically application. They can be, they can
be web apps. They can be software. It's going
to teach you every single thing you need to
learn. And once you do it, you will have so
much confidence. Then you can get going any
interview on crack. It's going to be very
easy for you. Oh. As testing guide definitely
definitely recommended material after our
class. You know, maybe even after we finished
the whole program, then you can get your hands
dirty on this one. Very, very important. You
need to do it. Okay.
Second thing, if you searched for a web hacking
masterclass it's one of my courses on YouTube.
It's roughly, it's roughly two and a half
two and a half hour. Okay. you can definitely,
you know, you should go ahead and do this
one. It has, it's contains a lot of tests.
It's contains a lot of basics. First of all,
you, you should be doing this one and you
should be doing this one within this week.
Okay. That's going to be one of your challenges.
You have to do it. That's not like after the
program, but it's like, you have to do it
completely as it is just like I'm doing it.
It's not going to take a lot of time. Like
maybe one, one full day. It will take so divide,
whatever, you know, however, you can divide
it. There are different different tests and
this one that you have to learn, okay.
So web hacking masterclass for this week or
testing guide after you finish the program,
just make a note of that. There are automated
scanners every day. There is a lot of stuff
in this one and that's something I need you
to do. With that, I think with that that was
probably what I wanted to share. After that
let's come on the topic. I will still explain
you some of the concepts of web hacking and
today's class or possibly in the next slide
as well. But again, that is the, that is the
main focus area. Web hacking master class
on YouTube and web testing guide. That is
what you are supposed to do. Now. Let's, let's
start. What I can explain you is with my own
application. So my team has created a vulnerable
application for you people, and you can go
on my website here and it will show you SDBA.
So you can open that SDBA that this is the
SDBA download. You can enter your email here.
Okay.
It's close of content. So don't use it for
the commercial purposes this is for personal,
personal use. Once you add your email, it
will start the download. There you go. Download
now. And the release one is the latest one.
Okay. I, once you download that, you need
one more software, which is called Zemp, but
when you can use any web server Zemp is the
easiest one. So for windows am telling for
Mac, it can be a different software. Zemp
is cross platform, by the way, it will work.
So you can just say Zemp, open it, go to,
okay, let me close it. Go to more downloads.
Don't download the latest version and go to
more downloads here and download 7.2. So PHP
version 7.2 is the one which I recommend,
of course you can, you can download any of
these. They should work. But 7.2 is the tested
version.
So it is something which we have been using.
So this first version 7.2, again, Linux has
one. Mac has one. So it is the Mac. Just use
whatever downloaded and installed it as in
next, next, next setup. So I know you can
install it yourself. I'm not sure that, you
know, open it next, next, next, and install.
That's what it is now coming to the point,
the SDBA, which you download it. You have
to open that, so, okay. Let's see. Downloads,
downloads, SDBA release. Here you go. This
is our SDBA. You can copy this and go to your
C drive, open zemp, go to SD docs and then
paste it here.
So basically by doing that, you uploaded your
web server files to sorry, you uploaded your
website files to the web server. This is a
web server, now your machine is a web server.
You uploaded all the files in that. Once you
upload it, it's time to start the web server.
So you have to start these services. Okay?
You have to open the ports. You have to open
the port 80 and my SQL port. I don't know
what that is. Three, three, eight, six. I
think so to do that the Zemp control, you
can run it at admin. Once you run it as admin,
you can see their can be crosses here, just
click on them. And it will either ask you
to uninstall or install. Okay? If there is
a cross here it will install this. Otherwise
it will become a tick here, a green tick.
It is a red cross. You have to click on that
cross. Once it is done, you can just start
the service so I can stop it like that. And
I can start it like, okay, that's how it works.
So this is the port of my SQL, and this is
the port of Apache. Okay. Apache is running
on 80 and four, four, three 84, HTTP version,
four 43 for HTTPS version. And my SQL is running
on this port. So once you do it, you are good
to go. And you know, you, you upload the files,
right? You uploaded the files you have start
the server services, you're running website
right now. The problem is database. You don't
a database for website where it will store
the information where it will come, you know,
saved information to have that open your browser
and go to local host LOCAL H O S T.
Okay. Local host slash PHP. My admin. Yeah,
of course, guys, the video is recorded, right?
So once you, once you start doing it, you
can of course follow it from the video, this
open the video. And again, don't be confused
right now, right now. Just try to understand
the concept. Download Zemp installs zemp open
a server, you know, make a server open the
port 84, four, three my sql by control panel.
You just start, copy the files of the website
in the zemp and then create a database, link
the database to the website. Boom. You did
it. That's what you have to do right now.
This is the panel where you can create a database.
So new and new, you can give any name. I can
just say SDBA okay. And let's click on. Create
database has been created now let's again,
go to the zemp and we will link this database
to our application.
So sd docs, SDBA. Yeah, it includes. And then
config. Okay. That's the file that has the
configurations. And let me edit it. So this
is the file here. This line configuration
equals my SQL connect here. Local host. Yeah.
Let the local server, root is the username.
This zemp is running on root user password
is blank. Okay. That's fine. It is blank because
by default it is blank in Zemp. Then database
name is SDBA. Now, if you give another name
here, you can keep any name. Doesn't matter.
You just have to change that name in this
case over here. But since we are using SDBA
in the file, as well as the database name
is also SDBA, we don't need to change anything.
That's how it works. It should be fine. So
I will be showing you how that works. That
is how connection works You don't have to
do anything if the name is same, because in
the file, I have mentioned SDBA by default.
Now, once you're done, you just have to go
to local host slash SDBA slash set up dot
PHp. I, we have created an automatic script.
You don't have to do anything, press enter.
It will set up the website for you. Here you
go. The website is ready and you can test
this. Now it's like a review kind of website.
The model that has, you know, people can come
here, leave their reviews and it will get
stored here. So the first review has been
added by me sagar bansal. So, and I just written,
the review as this is an awesome application
and the country was India. That's basically
how it normally works. Okay. There is a login
panel here. People can go here and login.
And I mean, by, by default, the username is
sagar. Password is bansal So you log in there,
okay.
You log in and you can see it says welcome
back. And then you can log out. Let's move
out. Does it matters? That, that is how you
do it, then contact pages there. Okay. You
can go to the contact page and you can submit
a form, upload a file. That's that's what
of contact pages in the home. Again, there
is the review tab. You can, you can change
this thing. To 100, you know, there are entries,
there is a search form here. You can just
say to, and when you press nothing is found
you plus one, one entry is found. And so you
can, you can search things here. Next previous
buttons and rater us rate us form. You can
rate us, okay, you can, you can leave a review
there. So again, this as a test review and
maybe country, let's say India submit, and
you can see it.
That's another entry. And that's how it's
going to work again. If I had to delete this
entry, I can just say, delete. If I want to
delete all the entries, I can click on this
reset button. It will delete all the entries.
No records were found. Okay. That's how it
works. Now, if I, if I add a new one, submit,
you can see from entry when it starts adding
again, again, that's a, that's how it works.
That's how the application works. Any doubts
in how application is working, the website
is working and any doubts on that?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I don't expect you to
understand the steps right now, but I think
the concept needs to be clear that what I
have done is I have downloaded a server, installed
the server. Now my windows is running a web
server that is running a website right now.
And I am hosting a website. So website files
were downloaded from my website, right? The
SDBA is, is a website. And this website is
working in this way, right? Right. So when
you are testing your website. There are a
lot of things you can do. There is a very
common list or OWASP sm them or OWASP, happen.
These are top 10 vulnerabilities. You can
test in a website. Of course, there are more
tests. All of them are given in the testing
guide, which I was showing you all this testing
guide. But these are our top 10 tests from,
I mean, I have explained most of these tests
in web hacking masterclass, the first one,
the most easiest one is the login login panel.
If you click on login, you will see, you want
to use your name field, and you've got a password.
You enter anything randomly, let's say bansal
bansal, which is not a valid user. What happened
to click on login? Nothing happened, right?
You, you don't log on. Right? We can see we
don't log. Now. Maybe you brute force it maybe,
or maybe you can test for SQL injection here.
SQL injection is talking to the database.
If I try to add this colon here, if I tried
to log in it doesn't do anything. If I try
to add a double.
Colon here. If I try to log in it still doesn't
do anything. This is the first test you can
do, you know, just add a colon. Okay. Sorry.
I was saying colon add they add a single inverted,
a single inverted comma just add them and
they use the name and password and just test
them. Okay. That's something you can do. So
if I just randomly add something like this,
if I try to log in, nothing is happening because
we have disabled, the error reporting. You're
not getting errors in reality, it is producing
some errors, but you cannot see that because
in a secure environment, you will possibly
never see that. But let me, let me tell you
what's going behind the scenes. Okay? when
you are doing anything in the, in the form,
what is going behind the scenes? Let me open
the files. If I go to SD docs.
Okay. Login page, right? This is the login
page. Let's open it right now. Here. How this
form is working. Just bear, bear with me with
this single line here. This is the line I
want you to see, okay. SQL query with the
descending to be database. So website is sending
something to the database. What it is sending?
Select start. Start means everything from
login here. Log in as the table name. Okay.
There is a database. There's a table called
login. So select everything from the logging
table where the condition username equals
something and password equals again, something.
Okay, this is something. And then N D quit.
That's how it is working. Making sense. Now
how the, how the website is performing the
test. It is just checking that, see select
everything from the login table. Their username
is something. Password is something. If there
is a perfect match, if, if there is a match,
right, if you're able to see a match, give
me the result, whatever the result is, let's
show me the result. Is it making sense to
you? Yes. All right. And if we go to the database,
actually, you know, if we really go to the
database so we can just say Zemp, my SQL.
Okay. Then I'm just trying to see where is
my SQL installed. Okay. And do we have my
SQL here? Yup. We have my SQL over here. Okay,
cool. Let me open, commad prompt . If I just
say my SQL.
Right? So to explain the concept, if I log
into my SQL as a, as authenticated user which
can be done by my SQL dash dash, you, which
is user user is root dash P, which is password,
press enter. Password is blank. Just press
enter again. Okay. I was expecting it will
clear the screen possibly. It doesn't work
like that. Okay. Anyways if we go there now,
if we, if we see show databases, okay. Show
data bases, you can see, these are all the
databases in my, my SQL server. Okay. Right
now I'm just trying to show you as a server
administrator. I'm the company right now.
There is a database called SDBA. If we go
to that database. So use SDBA okay. If I want
to go in that database, I'm using this database
now showtables.
If we see the tables, we have two tables,
login and reviews. If we talk about login
table. So select start from login. If I press
enter, this is the whole table in this whole
table. There is only one entry, which is user
ID is one. User name is sagar password is
bansal, but there is only one Id missing.
It let's suppose there are multiple users.
Doesn't really matters. It will give you the
whole table. But when website is testing one
single user, it is, it is testing the command.
So let's start from login where user name
equals something and password equals something.
Okay. If username equals sagar, sorry. Uyep.
Okay. If username equals sagar and password
equals Bansal, it gives me this. Yeah. If
I entered a wrong result here, if password
qual bansal123, it does not give me anything.
Can you see one row in a sec and empty row?
If my username and password is correct, it
will give me the, it will, it will return
me the entry. It will give me the row. If
my username and password is wrong, it will
not give me anything. Is this making sense
now? So that is how the database is working
in the backend. Okay? The website is working
in that way. So if the website is sending
this query, select start from login, where
username equals something and password equals
something. Now this something is given by
the user website is using the query, but this
some thing is what we control. So this sagar
and bansal, this is what we control by the
website form, whatever you entered on this,
it takes that input. It puts that in this
query and it runs that query. If the query
gives you a row here, if it is correct, then
it logs you in. If it does not correct, then
it doesn't log you in. That is how login and
logout works on most of the websites. Is it
making sense?
Right? Because you can control this, this
thing, right? This sagar, and this Bansal,
if you can control the input, can you not
try to do something malicious here? Can you
try to add a, add a single quote here? I mean,
if you are the one who is controlling everything
between these two quotes, can you say sagar
and then a single quote? You can. So if you
do this, what suddenly happens, this single
quote, which was supposed to be closed at
this single quote. Now it is closing here,
which you just added. Is it making sense for
the website? Username is ending over here
and suddenly you are in the control. You,
you can type anything here or one equals one.
You can type anything here, okay? And maybe
space as well. You can type anything here
because you are controlling it. So you basically
type with this, this sentence, you give this
as input, but for the website, the username
was supposed to be this one. But now it is
this one because of the quote, right?
Because of, because this quote and this quote
was supposed to be, whatever you entered in
between was supposed to be a value. But since
you had in this quote here, this, this user
name becomes this much. And you type this
extra material, all right. This is the extra
material, which was not supposed to be here.
I, as it's making sense, it was supposed to
be this much, whatever you went through, supposed
to be in this, and then further, it was supposed
to be, and password equals. But now, because
you closed the quote and you added some extra
material, this, this, this part is extra.
This was not supposed to be, but you did it.
Is this making any sense?
Yeah. Actually, if you can, you can go over.
Yeah. To me, it's not making sense, actually.
Okay. So if you can go over this again, that
will be great.
Right? Give me one second. Okay. Okay. So,
okay. So this is the query. This is the database
query, which the website is using to check
if a user name and password is correct or
not. Okay? This is what this website is sending
this, this query to the database. It is asking
select star from Login. Username equals something
and password equals something. Now this something
is what you have entered as username and password.
You enter something here, user name, ABC password
one, two, three. It will send that here. Select
star from something from login and username
equals ABC password. Equal one, two, three.
Is it making sense you now?
Yes. Right? So this is how website is checking.
That is a, is a user actually correct or not.
If there is the entry of that user in the
database or not. So if I entered a wrong username,
you can see here. If I entered a wrong password
or username, doesn't matter the wrong password.
Can you see what it returns? Data will says
empty set. There is nothing like that. There
is no user with sagar and password bansal123.
There is no user in my database. Okay. That's
what it is saying. Right? Right. If there
is a valid user, if you enter the right password
and username, right? This is the right one.
What it returns. It returns the row. It says
one row in this set, it says that yes, in
my database, there's one user like that making
sense now, because we are giving this username
and password.
What if we control it? You know, it is supposed
to be username equals something, a password
equals something. But what if we control it?
We control it by, you know, let's say we control
it by saying select star from Login. Where
username equal sagar and password equals this.
Right. And then maybe we can just say, we
can just say, okay, we can just say here or
one equals one. Okay. What does it do? It
is basically saying select star from login
where username equals sagar and password equals
bansal code one equal one. Just check. Either,
either check if sagar and password exists
or if one is equal to one, is this true? One
equal one? Is this true? Is this a universal
truth?
Why it cause one? Yeah. That's a universal
truth. Right? So we are just telling the database
that, Hey, can you check if one is equal to
one, if it is then let me in, if one is equal
to one, then just give me access. Let me log
in. That's what we are trying to get it. But
just saying check. If the username it called
sagar, check his password is bansal one, two,
three. If that's correct, that's fine. If
that's wrong, then you know, just the check.
This thing one is you got one, one, is it
called one? Then just let me log in. Okay.
That's what we're trying to say to the website.
Right? The problem here is you see, when something
in any single quote, you see the single two
single quotes here. When you give something
in these quotes, this is taken as an input
text. Okay? Let's take another text. Now here.
Username equals sagar and password equals
Bansal one, two, three, or one equals one
that is taken as a password. Not as a command.
You need to make it as a command instead of
a password to make a command. We need to close
this bracket. The single quote. This is closing
here. We need to close it over here. So that
bansal is, this. This password is closed here,
like this one. And then we get our command
running there, or one equals one. That's that's
what we want. That's why we put the quotation
Mark here. Okay. Now you can see select star
from login where user equals sagar other password
equals bansal one, two, three, or one equals
one. Is this making sense now?
Yes. It's making sense. But my question is,
so do we maintain our quote at the end?
Yes. That's a very good question. Because
here there is an additional quote, which doesn't
make sense. I mean, where is it opening then?
Right? Right. This is opening and closing
what to do. There are multiple options. This,
this, this semi-colon when you see the semi
colon, this is end of the command. This is
used at the end of the command. So maybe,
maybe we can just add a semi colon here. This
will basically end the command over here.
And this will be ignored. This will be the
first command. So this becomes our first command.
And then this becomes our second command.
And also to ignore the second command completely.
We add a hash sign. Now this has sign comments.
This, this is a comment, not a command. This
becomes a comment, which is, you know, just
completely ignore this. That is what it is
now. So we end the command here, be comment
it out. You know, this is our first command
and whatever is after this, ignore that. That's
what we are telling to the database. Making
sense now.
So basically if you, if you try to see, this
is what we have entered in the form, right?
From here to here, this is what we enter in
this form here in this password. We give this
thing, right? If you give this thing, the
code will pick up this, but because you have
added a single quote here, it will end this
here and this will be taken as a new command.
This will be checked and then further, this
will end the command here and it will comment
everything making sense. So in this case,
will it work? Who knows the second command?
Sorry, the second command. No, it will. It
will not execute the second command because
we have commented out it just, the hash is
coming. Ignore everything. After the comment
we have commented it. It will not check it.
It will not even run. This will work because
it is ending over here. Not here. Fine. So
what happens if we tried this? I don't know
if it will work in the first place, but this
is what we have to give as input. So let's
copy. And I will give this as an input. Okay.
Sorry. It was supposed to be in the password
username. I think I can give anything. Doesn't
tell any matters. I'll just say bansal. So
let's try to say login and you can say, I
successfully logged in. Can you see there?
Right. I successfully logged in no problem
at all. And that's, that's how you bypass
a whole login page by SQL injection. And basically
we were talking to the database. You are controlling
the database. That's what we were doing now.
Interesting question. Can you do it? You know,
let's, let's, let's not use one. First of
all, let's use something else. And also, can
you do it with the username field instead
of the password field? Who can do that with
the username? Let's let's let's give you guys
a try. So this is the field, which you are
controlling. You enter anything here. Let's
us sagar. Now, how will you control this field?
How will you ignore this part and, and establish
your command here. Let's control this field
and try to bypass it. Okay. What shall I type
that? Me? So the semi-colon right by doing
that, we closed this here and we got the control
here with ourselves now. Yeah.
But don't you think you need to give it a
condition like select star from Login where
username equals sagar or one to one, right,
right. Or one equal to one. Okay. And then
don't you think this part is a problem? So
you have to close it. No, but I have to close.
Okay. But still this is a second command.
This is the first command now, but this is
the second command. What to do with it? Put
a hash that's the comment right now, this
whole thing becomes a comment. This is ignored.
So if you take this part, okay. If you take
this part from here to here, right?
If you take, this part, it will press here
and password doesn't really matter. As it
is commented out, I can press anything there.
If I tried to login, you can see you guys
successfully logged inr. Right? Right. Now
you may be thinking then, but saga, I can
use the same thing and I can log into any
account then. Right? It doesn't, it doesn't
work like that. Where does the vulnerability,
where is the weakness? Did you guys manage
to find the weakness? Hmm. Do you think there's
a weakness in the code is because it's a easy
to manipulate the sql command. The, the database
command itself, this whole command itself
is a weakness. Basically the website, the
secure website will never allow you to give
the input and control the database. Okay?
What they should be doing is they should be
checking. They should be checking for special
correctors. They should be checking that a
user is not adding colon. As your user is
not adding the the pound sign. The hashSign.
The username is not adding a single quote.
They should be checking for this. Character.
They should be blocking them. Right?
That's the first way that is called blacklisting.
You blacklist these characters or second way.
They should be white listing some directory.
They should say that, listen, you can only
use numbers. You can only use alphabets. And
maybe you can use hash at the rate. You know,
the exclamation at the red dollar, you can
use some specific symbols. You cannot use
these symbols, right? I mean, you just whitelist
and don't blacklist simply by white list.
Just say that, see, this is what you can use.
Don't say, this is what you cannot use. That
says, this is what you can use. Because sometimes
when we say, when we do blacklisting, when
we say that, okay, this, this, this, you cannot
use this, this, this, the problem is we sometimes
forget somethings, okay? We forget that, okay,
this can be done in that way. Also it can
be done that way.
Also, they sometimes forget to blacklist everything.
That's the reason, the best way is white list.
White list, the characters, which are secure
these characters, this, the single quote,
this colon, these, this hash sign, these are
not secure. And that is one of the reasons
when you are making a password on some websites,
you will find that they will not allow you
to use these as usernames and passwords. Making
sense. Yeah. How do you do that? Tell me you
can just you don't have to do it. The developer
can basically add a line of code where they
will check. If user name contains exclamation,
Mark, it will block it. It will just say that
your username cannot have exclamation Mark.
Okay. That is what a website developer will
do. It's not our job, but our job is to understand
the problem and tell him that, Hey, listen,
this is the problem in this code.
I can send anything to the database. I can
send whatever I want to be database. I can
control the whole database. That's the whole
problem. Okay? We have to stop that. We have
to stop the problem we have to solve the problem.
And the problem is coming because you are
allowing this kind of characters. If you block
these kinds of characters, or if you whitelist
only selected selected characters like this
one, this one, this one numbers. If you white
list only specific things, it usually cannot
control the database. Right? That is what
you have to tell. You have to come up with
the solution, not the implementation, making
sense now. Yeah. Right now, let me give you
a very quick challenge kind of thing. Let
us say, instead of single quote, let's say
the code, the code of the website contains
this. Okay. It is very, very possible. Sometimes
the code of the website contains this kind
of thing. You can see it is working. This
code's working very fine. And this is very
normal. Okay. Let's say this is the code.
How will you bypass it?
We were not be different from I see right
now, if you add a single quote, any, we have,
let's say you add a single quote here. Is
it helping? Is it helping in any, any sense?
Is it doing anything essentially? Can you
see? I mean, this court is double. This is
double. So whatever you enter here is taken
as your password in the text, it is taken
as text. What you want to do is you want to
close this quote so that you are in the control.
So instead of adding a single quote, you have
to add a doube quote in this time, and then
you can write whatever you want, making sense.
Now you need to add the same thing with the
website is using. And there is no option to
find that it's you have to guess it. If single
is not working, single quote is not working.
Maybe you will use double quotes.
Okay. That makes sense. Right? So basically
that was the whole point. Sometimes developers
use double quotes and those cases always test
for double quotes as well. Okay. Now what
I was trying to do earlier, you know, when
I was trying to say that, always tried to
use single quotes and double quotes and try
to break it. So for example, this is, this
is what the code is. If I was, if I tried
to add a single quote here, suddenly this
quote becomes inconsistent. There is no reason
to have three quotes. It will throw an error.
Normally it will throw an error, in our case,
it is not throwing an error. If I just give
a single quote here and single quote here,
it is not putting another because we have
disabled that. Okay. We have disabled the
error reporting and as well, it's not throwing
an error, but normally on some websites, I
will throw an error when you add a single
quote and, and something like that, if their
website is not secure they are not white listing
or blacklisting.
You had a single quote, it will trow an error
because there is no sense of having three
quote in the quote. There is no sense of adding
that and it will throw error here. That's
basically the concept of bypassing login panels
or bypassing security with SQL injection.
Again, you can use the same thing on the homepage
here. Can you see, there's a, let's see if
I tried to open this here. So can you see
this URL, this, your listing ID equals one.
What else? I can control this ids, but you
know, it's not my log in panels. It's basically
it is about controlling the website, what
it is doing in the backend. Maybe it just
check in select start from some table where
our ID equals one. There our ID posts two
what happens if I, if I, if I try to save
it our Id equals zero.
Okay. You see we, we don't get, okay. We don't
get any, any response. Right? We don't get
anything. What happens if I say, sorry, what
happens if I say our ID equals Singapore?
Okay. You can see we've got an error, could
not execute. Select star from reviews where
ID equals colon see. I told you, this kind
of command is what it is using in the backend.
The website is using this command select star
from reviews. They will get the table name,
their ID equals something. Now what happens
if you start controlling this, right? What
happens if you control this?
Okay. Can you control this? I guess yeah,
you can try. You can try. So there are multiple
commands you can use. For example, I can say
union, U N I ION, right? I can say union,
let me show it in the, in the in this one
first in command prompt, it will be easy for
you to understand, and then we can take it
to the real level. Okay. For example, if I
do select, start from review where ID equals
one. Okay. Select unrecognized command as
the, Oh, okay. We are not in my sql. I think
I logged out. Yeah. There you go now if I
say so let's start from reviews. Database
selected
Now, if I say so let's star from reviews.
Can see. There is, there is the full table.
Now here. Command is using select star from
reviews, where ID equals one. That is what
the website is using. Where ID equals one.
This is what the website is using. But what
if I can modify this? I can say maybe union.
U N I O N union one, two, three, four. Okay.
One, two, three, four. It doesn't work. No.
Okay. I wasn't expecting that. Okay. Okay.
Select one, two, three, four. Yep. So see
what union does it combines? The output of
two commands here? I have run two commands
here. So let's start from reviews. Where ID
equals one. That is the command, which website
is running. I just added a union select one,
two, three, four. Now select one, two, three,
four is another command. If we run it individually,
select one, two, three, four. If you run it
directly, you will see the output is this
table, right? This is the table.
Is this making sense? This is the table, which,
which comes after running selects one, two,
three, four. But if you just do union, it
means combined both of them. And this is the
combined table. Is this making sense? This
was the default table. Select start from review,
where ID equals one. This was the table, which
comes to at one, two, three, four. We combined
both of them. So star start from reviews,
where ID equals one union selects 1,2,3,4.
We get a combined table. Right? What if I
run another command? Select one, two, three,
four, instead of three. If I add something
like @@ version, @@ version gives you the
version number you can see in the third column,
instead of three, we are getting the version
number, right? If I use the same command here,
if I take this union, this line, if I take
this, if I go on the website, okay.
If, if, if I add that here, you can see select
whatever. So our ID equals one. This is what
the website will put union select one, two,
three, instead of three, I'm giving @@ version
and then forward and then colon And if I press
enter here, you can see, we suddenly get one
more entry, which says one is ignored. I think
one is not showing here. But if you, if you
try to see on, on this thing, I don't find
one, but I see two here. I see four here.
And in third column, you can clearly see the
version number. Is this making sense? Right?
So I'm calling the database. Yup, yup, yup.
Using the word union. You combine the, they
have a new field, a new command, basically
a new command. So whatever you enter, the
check said true.
I mean I can enter. Sorry, what true, what,
What I'm saying is that using the union command,
you're able to like manipulate the data or
add something to it.
The whole problem is the union is not adding
commands. Union is not adding commands. Whole
problem is you cannot command. There is another,
another operator for that. We call these operators,
okay. Union operator. It does not adding the
command. It is combining the output. Of new
command ? There's not running the two commands.
It is adding the, it is combining the output
of such command. The first command was this
output of second command was this. So it just
combined the output and make a new table.
But that is what union does. Okay. It's not
running the command, it is combing the command
output. Okay. You can use some other operator
which will simply run, which will run the
second command. You can use some other operator,
but you don't have to learn this language.
That's the whole point. That is what I'm trying
to stress Now, you don't have to learn what
is union.
You don't have to learn the whole language
itself. You really don't need to learn this.
You can use automated tools. There are tools
to do it. You don't have to run these commands.
You don't need that. What you just need is
you need to understand how the concept works.
And if there is a possibility to manipulate
something, if you think that, okay, this is
a website, right? This is a website in the
browser, in the URL. I see that there is an
ID parameter. This is a parameter, which is
containing a value. One. If you see this kind
of thing or possibly this command is going
to the database. There is some command being
run in the background. There is something
going on in the background. Maybe I can modify
it. I can manipulate the database. And then
you just use a tool which can do it for you.
You don't have to try any tests. You just
have to use a tool. That tool there are multiples.
My favorite one is SQL map. Okay. Let's open
the kali linux and run it.
So, so what you're saying is that you didn't
have to learn , you don't have to know SQL.
Yes.
The tool can automatically run SQL commands
for you. It will ask previous questions, the
last few questions in English language, you
answered them in. Yes or no. It will make
commands and it will run them for you. But
why I showed it to explain you the concept
in the deeper level. Now, you know what is
going on behind the scenes, how tool is working,
who is also going to try these commands, this
random commands. Is it making sense now?
Huh.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's go in kali linux. It will
do everything for us automatically. We don't
have to do anything. Yep. Very well. It's
quite slow today. Let's log in.
Okay. let's open Firefox. Alright. Now in
Firefox, let us a assume. This is a real website.
So there will be IP address or the domain
name, right? So I will check my IP. So my
IP address is one nine two one six eight zero.one,
one two. If we go there and this works, my
website is in the folder of SDBA. Okay. You
can see this is my website. Is it making sense
to you guys? What I'm doing right now? I'm
just, I'm just opening this website in my
kali Linux. Right? Guys, I can just take this
URL, right? I can just take this URL and I
can open my terminal and I can use the tool.
Okay. The tool name is SQL map. So SQL map
that's URL. And you just give it the URL of
the, of the page where you want to attack.
I give this URL and I press enter and it will
start attacking it automatically. It will
start asking you questions that you have not
declared. Cookie server wants to set it own.
Do you want to use those or do you want to
use your own? Now we have no idea what the
cookie is. Really? We have no idea. Let's
just go with, yes. This go with their own.
Okay. That's why I just said yes. Here you
can see.
Am just saying
Backend database is my SQL. Do you want to
skip the payloads specific to other databases?
Now it is detecting that the, my SQL database
seems to the database seems to be my SQL.
Okay. Which is correct. We are using my SQL
list. If you go ahead and check your Zemp
panel, we started my SQL service. Some in
some cases, some companies will use Oracle
or some companies will use postsql or some
companies will use no SQL. There are multiple
versions of databases. In those cases, you
can use other tests. In this case, I will
skip the test for other databases because
we know it is my sql Yes. Here four remaining
tests. Do you want to include all the tests
for my sql? Yes. Include all the test. It
is now testing. Now you can see these things
where having order by the it is using different,
different codes.
It is using different, different things. Okay?
Yeah. This line is interesting. Get parameter.
Our ID is my SQL, this, this, this error based
where this close injectable, it found a payload,
which is working. It found a payload. Our
ID appears to be injectable. Okay. It has
found payloads. Yeah. Get our ID. Parameter
is vulnerable. There is a vulnerability. This,
this our ID. If you see in the browser, you
can clearly see this our ID here. This our
ID is vulnerable, right? That is what we were
exploiting ID. This is one vulnerable Do you
want to keep testing others. No. Why will
we keep testing others? If we have vulnerability?
No. So no.
All right. It just finishes. It suddenly closes
what happened. It closed because it found
some attacks. Okay. There are two. No, there
are multiple options. You can use this one.
Okay. Now what you can use and boolean ways
type where, or having closed, you can use
where you can use having something like that.
And this will be your, this will be your attack.
Parameter ID equals one and select something
from something count concat blah, blah, blah.
You don't have to learn this SQL. This is
the SQL query. It is going to use. You can
copy the same query. You can go to your browser.
You can paste the same query. It will give
you some information. Okay. Is this making
sense to now it's building the query for you.
You don't have to make the query yourself
basically made that query for us. Now, what
we just need to do is, I mean, it will, it
will automatically make queries.
This is another query which we can use. And
so this is automatically making them for us,
but we don't even need to. We don't even need
to, you know a care what it is making, what
we need to do is we need to extract that information.
I can just say that, that DVB, that that's
DBS. If I present it will give me the databases
and I can just specify there. It will give
me all the databases on that website. It has
run some query. This was the query it run.
Okay. This was the query it has used. And
it has given me the databases. Now I can use
a database SDBA. Maybe I can use that. I can
just say dash So small dash DBS for database
finding that's capital D to use a database
I'm using database SDBA And I want to find
tables that as tables, this tool will automatically
make some queries and it will automatically
bring tables. This was the query it has used.
These are the tables we have got. You can
copy this and paste it in the browser. You
will get the same exact, hutput, okay. This
is what it has done for us automatically.
You can see there are two tables. We can select
the table of login. So I will just say capital
T like level, table of login. Okay. And just
select T there. And now I can just say that
that's columns.
It will now make another query for us. It
will give us the columns. You can see, we
have three columns ID, username, and password.
Now we can dump it, right? This was the final
query we can use. We can dump this. We can
dump it by saying column names. So that's
column. I want username. So user name and
I want a password. So password, I want username
and password. And then show me what's there
in those entries. Give me the output. Now
it is going to dump that here. You can see
dump. Username is sagar password is bansal.
Can you see Danielle? How you dump things?
This is the final query, which it has used
in the browser. This is what it does. Use
union. Okay. Ready? You were using union.
Yes. It has used union. The union, all select
something here. And we don't even understand
what it is, but it has done it itself. We
have the output. That's what it is. Is it
making sense? This is making sense. Everyone?
Yes. It's making sense. Right? So let's have
the challenge, u,ur task. This is your query.
Let's say DBS is SDBA.
Okay. So, okay. Sorry. Give me one second.
Give me one second guys. What's the problem.
Oh, okay. I got the problem. Sorry.
Alright. So these are the two tables, right?
I just showed you how to extract username
and password. Now a few people show me how
to see the reviews in this website. How to
see the reviews. What are there in the reviews?
How busy are, can you guys show me? I'm just
trying but.WE have to go over once again to
use this, the two, two select what reviews.
Okay. Then you have to select a database.
It is dashed capital D. Then you have to select
a table. It is -T. When you have to select
the coloumn it is -C. Okay. The first letter
of capital and one single dash. When you want
to extract something, it is dash dash. And
the thing that you want to extract tables,
dash dash columns, dash dash DBS. Is it making
sense now? Can you, can you tell me what I
have to type here? Dash dash tables and then
what dash review review. Yep. So if I type
review, review or reviews, reviews. Okay.
Sorry. Yeah. Reviews. Reviews. You can. Okay.
What happened? Yeah. Sorry. Don't you. Think
we already have the tables. These are the
tables. So don't you think we have to find
columns.
If we have to find columns, we have to select
this and how to select it. Control, sorry.
Capital one,see P. There to select it, right?
They will. This is a table, which we are selecting
the table. Now
in this. We have to find columns. So dash
dash columns. So database is SDBA tables is
reviews. Now give me the columns. That is
what you see by dash dash columns. You see,
now this is how we get columns. These are
the columns. Now tell me how to select the
column of a review and country. How do I select
that review and country? How to select that
column? So you have to do dash SDBA dash G
reviews, dash dash. Then use dash dash for
country. Okay. Are you using that? That's
reviews here.
It is simply the name, right? So simply just
type country here. Right? Coma. I also need
review. So review after dump press enter,
and you can see, there is only one entry,
country is, India review. Is this a by the
way? Yeah. I mean, that is how you do it.
There is one more quick option, which you
should know that is OS shell. If you use a
option called OS Shell, it doesn't matter.
Just remove everything. Just type OS Shell
dash dash dash shell. If this command works,
it does, it does everything you need. You
can just, you know, you can just press enter
just press enter here, press enter there.
If this command works for you, it will be
great. Here. You can see OS Shell is working.
You got a shell. What is the os shell? It
is basically hacking the system without running
any command. It's just, just handle it.
Os shell is complete shell. You can type any
command. You can control that machine. Now,
if I say If config or IP configured, it's
a windows. If I say ip config , you can see,
I am controlling that machine. What is this
IP? This is machines, IP windows, machines.
I can just say dir you can see these are all
the files. Okay. So Zemp folder as SDBA , SDBA
as Sagar folder index, I can see these files.
I'm controlling that server. Now I can make
a new folder. Then. Okay. Again, there is
no folder like can here. Can you see? No,
I can test that and now I can do it again.
You can see there is a new folder. Ken we
just created that? Right. If I just go ahead
and show, you will see seen my C drive C in
C. Uokay. So if you see it in the SP docs
SD docs,
You will see a new folder here, which says,
ken, can you see Ken? Right. Okay. Yeah. Ken,
th that is how we basically, we have, they're
controlling that machine. Now we're controlling
my windows 10 machine because of this SQL
injection vulnerability. We got a os shell,
well, of course you cannot get os shell by
manually type in the commands, impossible.
But with SQL map, it has the ability to give
you the shell. Is this making sense? So by
using SQL vulnerability, you just got it,
complete access to this system, right? So
now what I want to show you today is kind
of, you know, just like you have auxiliaries
and metasploit today, we will be talking about
things formatting, you know, so we have apps
have web apps are not only limited to the
source code or, or the HTML files, which we
see.
There are so many other things like directly,
you know, that attribute first thing is, is
one of the important things to understand,
because normally it will happen. You know,
there will be a company, they have a website
hacker in the house.com. Now for employees,
they have a secret location. [inaudible] Dot
com slash secret. You know, those kinds of
things they normally happen. They, they normally
keep you know, nonpublic data there. Sometimes
you will find the retreats will have uploads,
upload, listing open. So [inaudible] dot com
slash uploads. Now you've got everything in
that thing. So they're actually listing is,
is kind of a important thing to understand.
And you know, it's, it's one of the best things.
If you can, if you can find you will get a
lot of data there. So if we become Suunto
S no, actually let's open a bar, let's open
their best. Their Buster is the software you
can use. That's the recommended one. There
are others as well. I will show you others.
You can press their Bester and here you go.
Right? So I was saying that this is the dermis
true console. It requires an IP address with
a port now, or, or the URL with the port,
same thing. So let us try HTTP. Let's say
we can dot hacker in the house.com. And we
know that the port is 81. Wait, it is running.
Okay. Now you can go ahead and increase the
number of threats. If you want to go faster,
I will not recommend it until required. You
know, in, in most of the cases, networks are
sensitive, they are firewalls. They will block
you. You really don't want that. Not lifts.
So this thing matters a lot. You know, you
can do a pure brute force in pure brute force.
It will go to [inaudible] dot com slash a
slash B slash C. So it will go to a, you know,
a land.
If I even select that, now I can select character
lists. I can select minimum and maximum land.
It will come up with every single possibility,
which is the most effective one, but it will
take a lot of time. That's the whole problem.
Now it's on you. If you do have that much
time or not, of course, in a normal pen test,
which is like, you know, one day, two days,
three days, you don't have that much time.
Okay. As well as in the LPD exam, six hours,
you definitely don't have that much time.
So you would want to do a list based book.
First in that list, you will already have
common places like slash login slash admin.
Those words you will have in that list, where
are those lists? They are already there in
the, their Bester folder. You can click on
browse. You can go to user.
So always go to the slash the slash the boot,
and then user uses the folder where you have
a lot of stuff share is default where you
have shared stuff of all the applications.
Now, here, you can find their Buster. So all
of these are apps you seek up is there are
a lot of apps out there. You can find her
booster in this list. That's what I'm trying
to do. There you go there, Buster. Okay. You
can double wait and you will have bird list.
So these are, there were lists. There are
alpha alpha user enumeration. So this list
contains a lot of users or sorry, Apache user
and admiration, these lists, and then a lot
of users. Similarly, you will have word lists
directory lists, Darlene. What we are looking
for direct list three is the latest one. There
are some, you know, small and medium lists.
Let's go with, let's go with the small one.
Okay. Small list let's click on and let's
go with the lower case, small list. It really,
normally it doesn't matter if you are going
with this small, you know, lower case or a
Perkins, but some config, you know, some websites,
they, they, they be smart. They become smart.
And they use uppercase directory in, in some
cases, normally it is always lower case, but
for a hidden directory, they can go with the
uppercase. So maybe you want to use these
ones. Maybe it's a big one, medium or small.
I would recommend go with small every time.
Maybe try medium. If you don't get anything
significant, I'm just going to use lowercase
small. Okay. Select list. Now here you can
be recursive. Recursive means. So for example,
you find a part like slash uploads. Now, do
you want to further go ahead and find other
things in that?
So slash uploads slash something, do you want
to find that as well? So that is what a recursive
means. You can be the person there, brute
force files. You can, you know, you can, you
can search for files. PHP is what we are researching
at the moment. You can, you can just go ahead
and add other extensions and it will, it will
start with 14 files as well. You can, yep.
You can always start with slash so you're
if you're starting with slash that means happened
in the l.com/it will start from that domain.
If you want to start from a specific sub domain,
you can, you can put that year, but I just,
I just like to put that in the URL itself,
you can just put that at the URL here itself,
and it will really just keep it default. Let's
go ahead and we can start.
And here you can see that starting getting
a lot of stuff. What to do. You can always
click on this preview on your is the one which
you should be looking at. And now suddenly
you have the information you can see very
clearly all of these files out there. So this
has even site, there is a file index dot PHP.
Then there are folders, icons, WP content,
WP includes. These are the folders in that
website. Soon after it will come up with many,
many such folders response court is something
you need to understand. These are response
codes here. Now, what are these? This two
zero zero means. Okay. Okay. Zero response
code means, okay, you go to this URL. It will
work. You know, it will work in one shot.
That is the Tuesday, the zero response score.
Three zero one is redirection. So you go to
this page, it will redirect you to somewhere
else.
You hope to index dot PHP. It will redirect
you some better. That is the redirection.
Four zero three is forbidden. You cannot open
this website. If you try to open icons, it
will, it will give you a forbidden error.
Again, two zero, zero is okay. Three zero,
zero one is redirect four, zero three is four,
four, zero four is not fun. And of course,
if it is not found, it will not give you in
this list, right? There is no point of having
it here in this list. If it is not fine, because
we're just trying to find the existing stuff.
One more thing. There is, there is one more,
which is called five zero, zero errors. So,
you know, five zero one five zero two five
zero three. All of them, our server failure
now server is failing. Okay? Server is having
problems. The web servers are not able to
handle your request.
It is crashing. So all of those errors are
500 cities. You see 500, maybe you are going
too fast. Maybe are overloading. The system
really depends. What is going on. Maybe there
is a broken application. The code on the website
is broken. Really depends how the, how the
server is, you know, facing those problems.
But anyhow, if you get $500, there is a problem.
Okay. To wonder, okay. Three, zero, one, redirect,
fortunately forbidden. Let's go ahead and
verify these kind of stuff. If we open Firefox.
And if we go to, we talked about how can we
be house pro proxy? That's remembered references,
proxy removal. There you go. Let's leave that.
This is the website. If I tried to go to icons,
ICU, NS, you can see, it says, not found I
C O N S but here it is saying four zero three
which we should be quite, you know forbidden
actually four, zero, three is forbidden.
It is giving a non founder that I'm not sure
why. Maybe the web server is not configurable
to give the right error, Mark. It is forbidden.
It exists. I mean, it exists. That's why it
is in the list, right? There is a reason that
is on the list. That's that's the whole point.
Maybe you can try one thing. Maybe you can
try with the IP address. Okay. Maybe you can
track with the IP address instead of the website.
So ten.zero dot hundred dot 10. If I'm not
wrong, that's the IP. Yeah. And slash iTunes.
Yeah. It's still not working, but if it isn't
the list, of course it exists. It's maybe
it's just forbidden. That's that's the whole
point WP content, right? So maybe WP content
will work.
So WP dash.
Yes. You can see it works. I mean, it's not
giving any other it's a blank page. So of
course there is, there is a blank page on,
on that, because it's a folder and there are
other folders. So this index dot PHP is the
blank page upload folders there. Right? You
can go to upload folder slash uploads.
You can see, we have low tier. And then further,
if you see there are all these folders and
this log file. So that's the whole point.
You can basically know what is there on the
website. And you can, you can try to find
the whole structure of the website. If I just
go to 2019, I have all these folders, but
there Buster has already done that for me.
You can see all of them are, are, are already
here, right? If I go to this one, zero seven,
if I open zero seven, here, you can see now
it doesn't give me anything. Why it doesn't
give me anything in zero seven. Because if
you see the names, you see, these are all
JPG files. First of all, we are not brute
forcing deputy. We are only group forcing
PHP files. That's the reason it is not giving
me anything here.
Second reason is these names are absolutely
uncommon, right? These names, I don't know
if these names you will ever get them in,
in any list. That's why you're not able to
group four steps at the end. What we are doing
is we are just reinforcing the directories.
That's that's the whole, that's the whole
concept we are using right now to get all
of these, all of these stuff you see. Now
we can even Brooke, first plugins here, right?
And you can see the blueprint light. We get
to know about that. And we can see there are
all these, this is the read me file. Maybe
I can just go in this direction, this location,
open this, and I'll find something interesting.
So that's what I'm trying to explain at the
moment, right? That, that is making sense
now how to do a brute forcing of directories.
Okay.
Yeah. It makes sense. Yeah. Right. So I click
on this. I mean, there are other structures
you can, you know, you can just go here list,
view results. It will quickly give you all
the locations. They can run their results
against the same thing. It will give you some,
if there is some error, it may show you over
here. Probably you can just ignore that visa
related to these are possibly related to the
website. Kind of you're getting all them.
What I'm trying to show you is if I stop the
scan.
Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Here, you can see, we have pause
and have stop. If I stop the scan, you still
have these results, so you can follow up.
But there is another tool which is very similar
to this one. Okay. There's another tool, which
is kind of quick, you know, quick, easy, and
fast.
Okay. Yep.
So there is one more tool which can be used,
which is their B instead of their Bester,
there is their been under visa, graphical
a is a, is a command line. So you can say
Derby dash edge. That's the shelf. Okay. yeah,
you can see it is actually giving users here.
It is. There'll be SGDP as RSVPs and host.
That's the only thing you need with Turkey.
Okay. It's that simple. So Derby STBV
And then we taught dot hacker in the house
and it will just start automatically and you
can see, it will come up with all the directories,
all the warnings, whatever it can find. Okay.
I'm just going to press control C at the moment.
Let's analyze. Okay. It automatically entered
here. It's not that efficient as their Buster,
but it is always recommended to try at least
two pools of the same nature before, you know,
before getting to a conclusion. Okay. Always
try to have the same nature. This will give
you some more information. If I'm not wrong,
you can see. So it scanned here and found
this at a code was three zero one redirection
service status, 4 million. So this was another
URL. It is forbidden. Then it found these
directories, which are working again four,
zero, five. I'm not too sure what this one
is.
Little five. You can Google, but it is XML,
RPC interface that I can tell you, basically,
XML, RPC. I think I have already covered it
is a communication interface for a lot of
apps. So it's that interface. You just need
to check these plus, okay. This is three zero
two three zero two. I think it is kind of
a D direction. Three, zero, two is also a
redirection if I'm not wrong. Okay. Internal
redirection three, zero, two, again, here,
then this plus this plus is 200, which is
okay. Yeah. And then do we have a warning?
Okay. This directory is, listable no need
to scan it. Right. So as soon as you see a
warning, of course, WP includes, wow, you
guys.
You got one, just open it again. There's a
warning for WAP admins. Lastly, it says you
got another warning here. You got another
warning here. So this is, this is something
which you should be, which you should be considering
when you're finding all of this stuff. WAP
content slash upgrade. They should not be
listable. Maybe let's, let's try to open that.
Let's see what is there? Yup. Here you go
upgrade is empty, but yeah, maybe it could
be used if it was already a website, making
sense.
How do you use Derby intercept now? That is
how you check for directories. Okay. That's
that's one of the extra things you should
be checking apart from the web application
vulnerabilities. One more is, you know, when
you are testing only the web applications
that is a limited scope, those web applications,
that's one attack surface, but think about
it. That web application is running on a web
server. Of course, there is a web server.
You can also go ahead and test that web server
for common things. For that you do have a
very cool Nikto . You can do that dash help.
It's quite a vast tool. Okay. nikto dash host
is what you want to use. Okay? And that should
give you a lot of, lot of information. You
don't even need to check other things. If
you have little dash Nikto2 dash host, if
you need to force the SSL, by the way, on
a specific port and it is giving error, you
know, like if it is giving you an error of
SSL certificate, not valid, etc, etc, maybe
just use dash dash SSL.
That was kind of something important sometimes.
But at the end dash host should be, should
be fine. That that should give you the, all
the information. If we go ahead and search,
Nikto dash host and HTTP, beta dot hacker
in the house.com. Now it will start scanning
this web server for us and we'll come up with
a lot of information. Let's see.
Okay. It's working. I tell them, I want to
show a few things, all of these plus okay.
I just, by mistake this all of these plus
are possible, you know, information here.
One thing is very important to understand.
No CGI directory is found. What is the CGI?
The CGI is a interface which Apache servers
use normally Apache servers. There was a very
common vulnerabilities called shell shock
shell shock was there. And then there, there
are two basic common vulnerabilities in web
servers, shell shock and Heartbleed Heartbleed
is the SSL vulnerability. Shell shock is a
CGI vulnerability It is the vulnerability
which can be exploited through CGI is the
most easiest one. So if you get CGI directory,
you should go ahead and use Metasploit and
search for the shell shock scanner. And go
ahead and test it.
Okay. Shell shock, scanner very important.
You should, you should definitely try that.
If you find a CGI director, it's definitely
going to help you. Here we got some information.
Okay. WordPress script reveals installed version.
So think about it. If this was not a WordPress
right before it was a custom app, maybe this
can give you the version of that custom app
Then licensed found, licensed, find a license
file. Maybe that is important. Maybe that's
why it is a listing here. It can be important.
A WordPress installation was found on this
directory slash right, so it can tell you
the apps as well. Maybe it is a Drupal WordPress
domain. I can come up with that technology
profile. Okay. A cookie doesn't really matter.
Upload a directory listing is open. So it
is giving you that a WordPress directory listing
as a browsable. So it is giving you that again,
WordPress login found it can find login pages
for you, right?
That's pretty much it found it. And this one,
sometimes it will come up and it will tell
you that, okay, we found this, this, this
HTTP metric, can you see this line webserver
returned a valid response with the junk recoganize?
In this case, this web server is safe because
it is giving you a response on every SDBA
matter. That's why it's not giving you any
information. In some cases you will find some
HTTP matters, like,, put or delete or, or
even trace. These are the three actually HTTP
methods, which can be dangerous. Put means
you can upload something on the web server.
You can upload something without any credentials
possibility. If you can upload, of course
you will upload a webserver delete means you
can delete something from the web server.
So that, that can be dangerous. In some cases,
trace means you can possibly trace the whole
web server.
You can trace the requests. You can trace
the directory listings. There is a, there
is a chance you can even place the passwords
of the Linux user or the web server user.
You can, you can go ahead and re reverse it
and find the passwords. I don't really think
that any, you know, LPT exam is going to be
that complex at any stage. But put is a method,
which you should be considering put is a common
method. A lot of people by mistake enable
that, and you should be checking off the port
if we try some other website, not sure if
it will give any response, but if we try something
like that, sorry, it is HTTPS. Now let's see.
Also side by side, let me open a few more
new tab. Let's possibly open HTTPS. And then
something like you know, the real website
hacker in the house. Sorry. I forgot the commadn.
Nikto nikto dash host. There you go. Now starting.
So we have two scanners running a, this one
is there and then this one is there.
Yup.
So I have one question. So how are you using
the tools and using HTTP and HTTPS? Is there
ever going to be a time where you use FTP
to run that command?
So FTP can be used, but you know, the problem
is this tool is a web server audit tool. Okay.
It's not a file server audit tools. So FTP
for FTP, you need to use any, any other tool.
And I'm going to show you how to, you know,
n map has scripts for that. Do you know how
to use n app scripting engine? Yes. Right.
You can use that n map scripting engine and
use the FTP auditing scripts and then, then
do it. Okay. All right. Thank you, All right.
Possibly the best shot will be okay. Let me,
let me, first of all, cover this one here.
You can see on my website, on my real website,
it says all CGI directories found, which I
don't understand what it is saying, but maybe
they saying it has found some CGI directory.
And I know my web server is not vulnerable
to shell migrate.
So even it is finding that it's a good, good
thing. It is finding. Maybe you can try, but
it does not give you anything. Error limit
reached 24, the host giving up last try. Right.
Okay. What is this? This is the firewall.
Now I am using it a web application firewall,
which will block the server or human or anyone
who tries more than 20 requests in one minute.
So in one minute, this has tried more than
20 requests. My website has blocked it and
scan has ended already. Okay. And in those
cases you may want to fine tune. You may want
to you know, you may want to put this thing
as let's see in the health. Hello. You may
want to total it so, Hmm. Let's see. Maybe
there is something, no one says, okay, no
its is important by the way, you want to disable
the SSL timeout for the request before 10
seconds. No, that's not the one for use which
host.
Okay.
Okay. Yeah, because then the target host allowed
ID a list, all available plugins right off
the file, disable plugins or prepare roles
port scan tuning.
Hmm. Scan tuning, maybe this is the version
of this is the option you want to fix. So
this time out, after 10 seconds, my website
blocks you for five minutes. It does timing
out after 10 seconds, of course, this will
close the scan. If you want to go with website,
maybe you can increase this to five minutes,
10 seconds. Then it will keep on working of
course, after getting blocked again and again,
but it will initially work. Maybe you can
do the scan tuning. You will have to check
on the Google or YouTube or, or maybe the
manual file how this one works. So if we see
Tuning, yes, this is the tuning.
Oh yeah, you can, you can even try for these
things. It can try it for file. Upload sql
injections. Okay. You can, you can try that
as well. That's something interesting, but
what I'm trying to see here was, you know,
how to limit, so I'm, I'm just trying to find
the limiting throttling basically. I don't
see any throttling here. You can possibly
Google that. You can possibly see how to throttle
the, the thing you should be looking at is
throttle. So that's something CGI bin. See,
this was, I was talking about I'm just telling
you, you know, if you have the CGI interface,
maybe you can, you can use these, these these
two options, either CGI bin or CGI app. And
that is an interface that can give you a lot
of information. And Metasploit, you have a
lot of tools for CGI.
If you find CGI, you can find all lot of stuff
there, user enumeration as possible. And then
after that, there, there is a lot of stuff
like, you know, as I said, a Shellshock vulnerability
is there it can be fatal. You can get full
system access if you find CGI listed there.
So that's one of the things, if I see this
scan, it's still it also got a limited out
after 20 requests because you know, it's the
same server, both of the websites, all on
the same server, that same stuff. And it just
got time out. Okay. That's one thing right
now I was talking about, I forgot what I was
talking about. Yeah. I think I was talking
about n map before this.
Okay,
Paul, I don't remember. I kind of went out,
but I don't remember. Possibly we can talk
up that thing later if needed. Okay. No problem.
Let's talk about n map then for a moment.
Okay. So if we say locate now, maybe it isn't
user share. So CV, every time you want to
access the tools for that, it normally is
in the user share. Yep. You can see. Now if
you do LS, you can see these are the n map
modules and all of OS database is there, payload
is there, protocols, blah, blah, blah. What
we are interested in this scripts, CD scripts.
These are the scripts. Okay. For every thing
you want to scan, there is a script. If you
see if you talk about FTP, if want to a test
and FTP server, you got subscripts. So FTP
founds, FTP, brute force, FTP, something,
I don't know, pro FTP backdoor, pro FTP pro
FTP was a, was a software,
The version of FTP. And that had an backdoor.
You can test that vulnerability with this
FTP system, maybe the system start something
like that. We VSFTP backdoor , yes FTP is
a very popular one. I am using vsftp. There
was a specific version, which was, which was
vulnerable. So that can help over there. Okay.
alone CV2010, 4221. You can go and Google
read what the CVE is, but it must be a significant
one to be in this list. If it is in this list,
it was a significant vulnerability. With a
mass scale vulnerability. You can most possibility
try that, that one with this as well. If you
talk about a web servers. So let's see if
we have some Apache. Yeah. HTTP you got HTTP
scripts here, right? HTTP malware host, HTTP
open proxy not sure, but you got a lot of
scripts. You can, you can try all of them.
SDBA, SQL injection, actually stored. XSS
you've got a lot of scanning scripts here.
You can, you can, you can search for, for
these scripts if needed what I recommend.
Yeah. This is what I was saying at that time.
What I recommend in case you feel stuck, okay.
Let us say you are in the exam. You have finished
two machines. Now you've got the third machine
to crack. I mean, you just need to grab two
machines in one challenge. If you do that,
you will easily pass because at the end, in
three challenges, two machines, you cracked
six machines. You need only five to pass.
But let us say you have time, right? Let's
say you crack two machines in one hour or
two hours. You still got four hours. Of course,
just try as hard as you can on the third machine.
And that is normally very hard. The third
one is always hard. But LPT exams gives you
professional tools in OSCP. You cannot use
automated scanners in LPT. You can use automated
scanners. Okay. the one which is covered in
the course in the LPT course is the is the
fork of nessus neseus professional one they
will not give you that it's a paid product.
They cannot give you
But there's a fork of that, which is called
openvas open vas. I'm not sure if openvast
installed in this, no open is not installed,
but you can, you can use openvas. And if I
show you and it's very easy, I mean, I literally,
I did not know how to use openvas. I know
how to use nessus, but openvas kind of, what's
kind of a cheap setup. The graphical interface
was very bad and I just went to YouTube. I
just went to, you know, I just saw hackersone
video. Like one, our video i's openvas so
how to use openvas
And I'm not sure if they will give you openvas
this time. I mean, at my time it was there
who knows if they will, they may change it.
Right? So you, you might be ready for scanning
and, and you know going on Google and YouTube
and trying to see, maybe they will give you
something like a Vega, right? They guys have
apps, scanner. Maybe they will give you something,
you know, who knows something like acuanetix,
okay. Or acuanetx, whatever you want to call
it. Or maybe they can give you something like
an arachni scanner. Okay. Now Arachni scanner
Vega. Both of them are covered in that web
hacking master class, which I showed you.
Open masterclass here, you can, you can see
this. What does 22 minutes? You can see this
22 minutes video. It will be quite, quite
good. Okay. You can understand how to use
it. I'm not saying you do it right now. I
mean, you can just do it in the exam itself.
You will have time.
It's not, it's never about the time that you
always have time. It's all about to know what
to do. You can, this is installing, 50% is
installing now from here after 10 minutes
its, starting how, we use, so here it is starting
to use it. You can, you can maybe just use
that. It can be helpful for detecting SQL
injections for detecting, you know, fileclone.
Possibly. This can help you a lot. I wasted
a lot of time. Maybe you can, you can just
not waste a lot of time. Just run the scanner.
But remember, this will take easily one hour
more than one hour to scan something, it's
a very, very slow, nessus. This is slow. It
can take more than one or two scan a target.
If you have like three hours left, then try
this, okay. And keep it running and still
start working on something else. So that is
a suggestion. Open Vas is a very powerful
tool. They will give it to you. I'm quite
sure they will give it to you nessus something
they cannot give. So this is what they will
give. So that,
So, so you're saying we can either get openvas.
We can get the other ones. How I guess we
have to know about names to search for it.
We can't just do like a search query to see
what scanners we have. Could we?
No, no. So that you can just click here and
you can just see what scans do you have. Right?
Right. Well, I guess, okay. So, because I'm
not familiar with those names you just mentioned.
So you mentioned openvas. What was the other
one? Vega.
There's Vega. Arachni let me try to spell
it or at least arachni scanner sagarbansal.
So if you tried that, here you go. I do have
a video. Okay. So I do have a video eight
minutes video. How to automate your work by
using an arachni scanner. You can possibly
try that video if you need. Right. Got it.
In the exam. If we tried to watch my videos,
maybe they will. They will question that.
Hey, why are you using a trainers video? Possibly
don't don't open my videos in the exam. That
will be a problem for you. Okay. But youtube
is kind of big, right? Every second person
is going to give you that. No doubt. That
was a arachni. That was Vega. That was open
vas Vegas VGA, right? Yes, yes, yes. VGA.
Sorry, what was the third name? Did you mention
a third name? Acunetix. acunetix. Got it.
Cool. Cool. Let's do one. It's kind of a good
product. They give you a free trial. It's
kind of a good vulnerability scanner, not
sure that they will give you my best guess
is that you will get a openvas and possibly
Vega. So both of them, my best guess is that
because most of them are open source Vega
is open source and open vas is, open source.
Okay. Yeah. It's a best short, but as I said,
guys, if you see this, if you see this video
and if we see if we have time stamps, I'm
not sure if I have made the timestamps. Yeah.
I haven't made it. But if you see, you will,
you will find some topics like this one, here
you go.
Do you see automate this using Vegas, scanner
whatever you did in this part, you can automate
that with Vegas, scanner. That's why I was
teaching in this, this part. So there are,
there are other, other stuff. So then there
is another video here automate this using
arachni scanner. I have taught all these scanner,
how to use them. I thought, you know, most
of these things, and and vulnerabilities in
kind of detail. So this video is something
which is kind of a, it must try if, if you
have that much time, so of course you should
be watching this, then you can see this one
demo of automated SQL injection. This is,
this is coming from the SQL map, which we
covered yesterday. So that is, that is what
it is then what is brute force attack, how
to do that, that is also covered there. And
you know, what to try to limit to the brute
force in the exam as, as much as possible,
you know, like webpage, if you have a list
then sure. Without list try limit yourself,
six hours is not a big time to make a custom
list. Right.
Right, right, right. Yeah. And there, there
are some popular web shells possibly see this,
this, this, this, this go over with the whole
video. So it will cover a lot of stuff, which
you should maybe knowing for the exam. Okay.
Alright. Is there anything else that we need
to cover possibly? I mean, n map servers or
webapps, do you guys think, is there anything
else and let's, let's talk about the HTTP
methods, corrupt ones I'm still, you know,
interested to show that it can be useful if
you find a method. I haven't find any method.
I think in, in my machines, I mean, I have
not included the methods. Vulnerabilties in
these machines, which I have but it's, it
will be good to have one. So it could way,
as you know, if I want to do a less, I can,
despite the output and I can grab the output
and then I can search whatever I want to search.
So I want to search something like methods,
There you go there are only methods. Scripts
HTTP methods. Okay. Let's try this script.
Copy. I will just do n map then HTTP okay.
Ubeta dot hacker in the House dot com dash
dash script equals this press enter. What
does it is unable to split net mask for target
expression.
Any spelling mistakes there. Oh, okay. Not
too sure what that means. Let's try with the
IP.
Yeah, it will. But it should. I want with
this as well. Possibly, because this is a
custom set up. Maybe we have done some mistake
while making it. So now here you can see the
support and methods are get, has had posts
and options. If you find put delete or trace,
that's your best shot, put, you can upload
it very easily. You can upload a website it
shell. It's your shot. Just go ahead and take
it. One of the tools for put will be one of
the tools will be I forgot the web may be
No,uw let's see how, what tools we have.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Maybe that is not
installed webAD It is a tool that you can
use or burp suite is one of them you can use
berp suite easily can bypass. UI will do that.
If you are interested, you can just go on
Google, very easy. You know, we just have
to intercept the request and put your, your
shell code in that request. That's how it
works. Uyou can easily do that. It's not a
big thing. I, I'm not sure if you will find
or these methods, but it's a good shot if
you find them. Okay. I have missed a few machines
in the exam. One machine I have missed it
completely. I'm not sure. Uwhat's, what's
there. Maybe there's a, there's a method HTTP
method thing. So that's something I would
recommend you to doing. Okay. Uany questions
on that?
So if I'm hearing you correctly with the put
method, we simply run burp suite. We captured
we run the proxy, capture it and then change
The request. So at the end of the request,
you can put the data, your shell code. Oh,
got it. It's kind of easy. If you want a practical
demonstration of that. You can, again, you
can go on the YouTube. No, I'm just showing
you where to find it. I have a video on that
as well. Okay. You can watch this one offensive
hacking. Yeah. Okay. Offensive hacking master
class. There you go. This one, this is a,
okay. This is an ad. I am quite sure this
is a four or five or six hours video again
its kind of a big video, but just go to the
end. The only last, the only last thing that
gets a bumper ad, we cannot skip it. I'm almost
done.
I'm making money here. All right. Okay. This
is the this is the shell code Where is that?
Okay. Possibly here. Yeah. This is the one.
This is the one here in the end. Yeah. And,
and last two or three seconds. Maybe you see
here, I was opening this burp suite. And so
it's like last five minutes stuff. You can,
you can see that here you can send this, this
request to repeater, right? Click. And here
you can put your code. This is the place where
you put your code. So it's very easy. It's
like five minutes where just maybe if you
are interested as well, and this one, this
will help you a lot. If you, if you cover
this whole stuff, it's a pre OSCP and LPT
core stuff. Okay. It's kind of OSCP, but LPT
stuff. It's a good one to have.
If you have time, like six hours, maybe 30
minutes daily. That should, that should make,
that should make a lot of, it's not, it's
not required again. I'm saying it's not required,
but it's, it's quite, it's quite good. Okay.
Okay. Now at the at least just watch this
last 10 minutes, which is the put operation.
Yeah. If you're not going to watch the whole
thing, just watch the last one. Yeah. I mean,
this one contains stuff like buffer overflow,
which is out of the scope of LPT. I mean,
you, you don't do buffer overflow in real
life. Possibly never in pentest. So that is
kind of out of scope of LPT. That is the OSCP
stuff. This is how you develop it. So you
don't need, you don't need that. This the
goal. Right. You don't need that. Just ignore
that part. Maybe just last 10 minutes as well.
Okay. Okay. Alright. So with that today we
have covered how to brute force the directories,
how to test the web server, using a Nickto
and possibly n map using scripts. That's what
I wanted to show you possibly just, you know,
what, what is the task you have to do? Just
watch basically, you know, just watch that
2.5 hours, video, web hacking masterclass.
Also watch that last 10 minutes part how to
exploit put operation. And if you have time,
then watch how to use open vas. Okay. That
is kind of what you have to do. Okay. Right.
And that should be more than enough for you
to do, you know, crack. 50% of the exam, believe
me, 50% because it's, it's a lot of web based
exam. Right. with that I'll end the class.
If you guys have any doubts, please feel free
to ask right now. Did you, I'm sorry, go ahead,
Paul. Oh, no. After you my bad. Oh, do you
say 50% is like directory busting or, and
servers, web apps. Web servers.
So like yesterday we cover an SQL injection
and if I upload and all of those stuff, you
will mix and match concept from here and there.
All right. Sounds good. Thank you. I mean,
I'm just trying to give you the importance
of all of this, right. It's kind of important.
Yeah. Yeah. The rest 50% is kind of, you know,
how to do network, pen testing services, how
to exploit services, run exploits out to you
know possibly how to do it's privilege, escalations,
all those kind of stuff. Is there often after
all of those and that's what we're trying
to do. Right.
So today we're gonna learn about network penetration
testing though. We have already done a lot
of it. And you know, when we were hacking
this windows XP we, we almost did it, right.
We know how that works. It's basically the
same methodology. You find ports, you find
the services, you, you know, try to see if
it service is vulnerable. Then you see if
the, if there is an exploit for that service,
if an exploit, just try that just try to hack
it. That's that's how the limited scope is
that's how pen-testing normally works here
we do have a server Vicky dot hacker in the
house.com. It started, yeah, that's a modified
version of another Lennox machine. So someone
else created it and we just modified that
because.
Because now that person is not continuing
the project. So it's going to take some time.
But I have done as see, this machine has got
two IP ranges. It's let me show you, so here
it is, this machine has portal. It has got
ten.zero.one 40 eight.one zero six and ten.zero.one,
one five one zero six. So this machine has
got these two IPS. Let's test it on this IP
148. I mean, of course you guys can route
through DMZ machine, you know, beta machine.
You can have this IP 10.100 routed to 148
and then test it this. Well, I will just avoid
all of that. You know, you guys know until
now you are already good at that. You can
do it yourself. I'm directly assigning myself
a range of 148. So you guys can, you know,
go here in settings and network and here the
adapter to just leave it as it is, it is,
it is fixed on hundred.
At that for one is something you can change.
I've just changed it from which to nat network
148. So I'm just assigning myself directly
a range of 148 you know, just to avoid that
routing. And it will save a lot of time. I
hope that makes sense. Right? Right. So we're,
we're basically pretend that we've already
pivoted So I'm until now everyone, everyone
can do that. I think. Right? So this one seven
four target is one 40 eight.one zero six,
but let's get in the action then. Uthere you
go. Let's try to see our IP address. It will
make you more clear. I have config. You can
see that this is the adapter one. We have
not touched it, but thereafter two, we have
changed ourselves to 148. So we are now in
one 145, right, right, right. Now,uthere are
multiple things you can start with.
I always like to do a ping sweep, right? So
ping sweep is something you should be, you
should be trying and there are, again, multiple
tools you can use. You can use metalsploit
uyou can use,uyou know, ping scanning tools,ufrom,
from different vendors or solar vend and all
of that. Or you can use n map and then n map
is I, you know, I'd say small tool to handy,
tool even big, you know, even big companies
like tenable. So if you think about tenable,
they got their scanner, which is Nessus, and
that's at a big scanner, one of the fast scanners.
So what they do is in the backend, they use
the n map databases. They use the n map service
n map databases, the port scanning database,
the OS detection database, all of that is
running through ata. And that is the only
reason.
And map is a free tool because it's a free
tool because these companies are paying for
that data. These companies are paying for
those databases, which n map has. So, n map
is quite a powerful tool. If these companies
were not paying n map will be at Pity at the
end, it's a free one. It's, it's something
you should be using. It's one of the most
powerful tools. That's why, when I want to
start with something, I will use n map. Now
LPT methodology, the license the license penetration
tester methodology says that you should always
start with a ping sweep. Then take those IPS,
which are alive. Then do a port scan. Then
take those ports, which are there, do a service
scan version scan, and finally start, you
know, gradually, you, you don't, you just
let me show you something. This is what most
of the people will do n map the whole range.
Okay? The whole range. And here they will
type something like dash a and maybe something
like script equals default. You know, they
are pushing the network. They are completely
pushing the Whole netwrok or you're scanning
each and every port, each and every machine
on aggressive mode with scripts. This is gonna
kill the network. Think about it as, as a
company, when you are doing it offline, you
know, with these virtual machines, that's
fine. That will work. But when you're testing
a real website or real company, real infrastructure,
they got network, which is limited. They got
like, they might have a, you know, a hundred
Mbps connection. They might have a, let's
say one GBPs connection. That's something
normal. I mean, I have normally seen one.
1Gbps a fiber optic cable. That's the maximum
I have seen in companies are normally. So
with that one GB line, they got like a hundred
people working in their traffic is coming
and out.
And even if you are pivoting, this will basically
kill everything. If you are pivoting and then
doing this kind of work, this is going to
kill the old, the old stuff. That's why the
recommendation is you always do a ping sweep
first. So to do a ping sweep, you can always
type the range, which was, let's say more
148./24, and then just type SP okay. We are
going to scan in the ping. Sweep mode. Okay.
P is that ping sweep you do a ping sweep and
it will come up with the IP's, which are alive.
Now, here, you can see.one is working .2,
who is working the three's working. And these
are probably the virtual hosts in our case,
these are not ping machines. 108 is there
and one, zero six is there right now. We know
that these hosts are up.
And for the example, I'm going to ignore these.
I mean, this is the router of course, for
the example, I'm going to ignore these ones
because it's not that these are not real.
I mean, I have created the network, so I know
these are, these are the two which will focus
on, okay, let's say that in our scan, we found
only these two. So now you know that you only
have two hosts to scan. Now you can just go
ahead and scan only these two. So I'll just
remove this and I'll just say eight and possibly
I can just add another one, 10, zero.one 48,
dot one zero six here. And instead of SP,
now this time I can do a support scan and
I can scan the ports in multiple versions.
Again, you can do TCP scan sin scan UDP scan.
A lot of options are there, right?
If you don't know about that, maybe you can,
you can watch my ch masterclass or something,
or you can go and Google it quickly. Or maybe
my CISSP master class on YouTube. I have explained
all of that very easily ports and different
different protocols, but you need to understand
one thing when you're doing pivoting normally
sin scans will break. And I think I have already
explained this in when we were learning that
windows XP sin scan will normally not work
in pivoting. That is the point. You might
want to do a TCP scan to do a TCP scan. And
Metasploit you have auxiliary scanners, a
fork scan slash TCP and, and, n map it is
ST scan, TCP S T. That is what you do. And
then if you want to do a sin scan in metalspoloit,
it is auxiliaries ports. Auxillaries sacnner
port scanner, sin scan in this one, it is
S S so you can do it with SS.
And what I recommend is, you know, just, just
try a just try with a sin scan, if that works,
that's fine. But TCP scan is going to be much
more reliable in terms of that. Uhere, we
got a report. None of the ports are open on
this machine. You see, all thousand ports
are closed in this. They got this one, but
this is the mistake which most of the people
do. This is the mistake which most of the
pentesters will do. And the mistake is these
people are only scanning whole thousand ports.
These are only top thousand ports. These are
not the whole network. Okay. You want to make
sure you also put a flag here. Dash P dash,
-p- means scan all the port. Now, if I press
enter, it's possibly gonna take more time.
But here you can see this time it's scanning
65,535 ports.
Okay. Instead of thousands, this will give
you a much more reliable results. Now this
will give maybe this saying everything is
closed. Maybe there is a firewall, maybe something,
but that's fine. But at the end of this saying
that, yeah, it has scan all the port and in
this case also it has, scan possibly all port.
Right. Making sense. Yeah. Right. So that's
what you do. That was the st possibly just
always try SS as well to see if you get something
again, nothing is found on this machine. And
I think port 2280 111 443. And this one, and
yes, that's exactly the same. So sin scan
is not giving us any additional information
possibly also do a UDP scan. So UDP is another
protocol on which connections work here you
can see on UDP. It is very you.
It is very, very surprising. You see, we got
a port on that machine, DH CPC, which is open
port filter. So there can be a firewall, or
it can be open. And there is 68 port number
UDP. So you get one more port there. And this
machine they're not easy to exist, but it
is possible that the port is open. It's not
sure it is possible. In the meantime, what
I'm going to show you is. So for example,
this is something we will be interested in.
Now, when you know that these are the ports
open, you will not be scanning all 65,000
ports. Again, this now, from now, from this
point of time, whenever you do a scan, you
do only these ports, 2281, one one one three
nine four four three. And this one, that's
what you do. Okay. You only scan these ports.
Let's keep this scan running until then. Let
me show you something which I like to maintain.
So let's see, there are a few reports, for
example, this was a pen testing project, which
I was doing. It's quite old project. I just
edited this today. So 34 minutes ago, this
is what I was doing by the way, when we were
late for the class, I was removing these IPS.
So this was a project for the client. It was
quite a big project. We had 44 IP's, okay.
44 IP's different network. These colors are
the ranges. So you see a common commodity
say dot something and then 74, then something
and zero eight and you know, something dot
95. So these were different, different ranges.
We were scanning. We had the last report.
It was quite, you know, a white box test.
I would say we had access to the last reports
and last reports. We found, you know, they
found these vulnerabilities in the new reports,
which we were making. We found these vulnerabilities.
So, you know last time, for example, in the
last month test in on this IP, there was a
high vulnerability this time they fixed that,
or maybe they didn't, but we found two vulnerabilties
one was low, one was medium. And the last
tester says it was a high. So not sure how
he got it. Okay. For example, similarly here,
there was only one high now, we say there
were four medium, vulnerabilties and some
low vulnerability. So when I removed the number,
it was the number four here as well. Maybe
it was too low or three lowe or whatever,
something, something low whenever it is here.
So that is something you might want to do
when you're doing a real life test, a white
box test create a sheet, you know, keep everything
organized, just to compare the results what's
going on. And why would this be a high vulnerability
last report? And we are saying there's a low
and medium, maybe, okay. This says that maybe
using that low vulnerability and medium vulnerabilties,
someone can make a new vulnerability which
can be high. Okay. Combining of them. Right.
getting, getting getting a combination. So
maybe think about those ideas. When you, when
you have such such sheets, of course, it is
possible that they have reduced the level,
or maybe they have been the risk assessment
and some other way it's always possible. But
when you're doing a real life test, always
think about this kind of things. One more
thing I'm gonna share is when you're doing
some tests, when you're doing a scan though,
you know, the n map, sorry, when you are doing
this, this, this thing, the same thing when
you're doing it in Metasploit, metasploit
keeps records of everything. You know, when
you are, when you're scanning, your port might
as well make a database for you, but when
you're doing it with n map, possibly just
make a target database. The target database
is it's a good practice when, and, you know,
in report writing, it will come handy. So
here if we take the IP one zero six, so the
target database works like this. You say IP's
or let me just type here. Ten.Zero.One, one
40 eight.one zero six.
Okay. That's the IP. We can format that later.
Let's say if ports found ports open, Oh, sorry
for that. Okay. ports open and here. And you
can, you know, start typing the ports which
you have got. So just for an example, 22 and
80, that's what I'm going to type 20 and 80.
And on this side, you can possibly say services
found, right? So then you can write services.
Then here, you can say vulnerability found,
alright. And then on the side you can say
exploits from, and possibly, you know, you
can even have links there. You can do whatever
you want to do analysis but what was the result?
Right. And finally, risk score. A risk score
is, you know is going to be depending upon
multiple factors, for example ease of exploitation,
how easy it was to explore it for you.
And then you know confidentiality, how much
confidentiality was exploited. So what are
you able to get full access? Where are you
able to see whatever you wanted? 10, if you're
able to partially see it five. So on the scale
of one to five, or preferably try to build
on scale of zero to eight, that's what we
use in ISO. So zero to eight, then integrity.
And then on the availability, that's what
you possibly want. And finally, on the basis
of these explanation, and NCIA, you can check
a table, maybe table six in the next year,
six ISO, 27,005. And you can assign this,
this score here, or maybe you can take NIST,
RMF risk management framework. You can check
these values in that as I need a score here
on the basis of the risk score, you can assign
a vulnerability level.
So is it a low level? Is it a medium level?
Is it high? So just always keep this kind
of target database when you are working on
a real project. Okay. We're not doing that
here because it really doesn't matter as we
are. We are already recording the video. First
of all, when you're that that's a pro tip,
always record your pen tests, whatever you
do, just record it. Even if you don't want
to make the databases, you know, you're recording
it. You can just view the recordings and come
up with the things. But when you're making
it on the spot, it gives you visibility. Now
I know, okay, port 20 is open in this machine,
maybe other, other data here, when you will
fill the sheet, you will have a lot of data.
And that will be kind of, you know, very helpful
at the later stage.
Making sense. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense.
All right, so one was make a target database.
Now here let's cancel the scan. It's not going
anywhere. I just manually cancel that. Let's
just focus on this for the moment that let's
say, this is our target. I mean, this, this
one, let's just ignore this at all. It's a
UDP on the one port and you cannot possibly
do anything on DHCP CPC. This is like a port
which you use for IP addresses. Possibly.
Let's ignore that. Let's say that our target
is one zero six in the moment. And that is
basically the IP of you know, of this machine.
If you see. Yep. One zero six here. That is
the machine. So that's good. We have the machine
now.
So what do you do? You know, when you have
that, you just start a scan on that, but this
time you don't scan all the ports, you scan
only the ports, which you found 22. Okay.
What'd I just did. Give me one second. There
you go. All right. So 22 80 111 139 443 32768.
What I want to do is I want to run this thing
in aggressive mode. Normally you would, you
would go with a version detection scan. Okay.
But here, I know that we have limited number,
of ports only selected ports. And of course,
services are already here. You know, as a
such, as there should be, be their, their
versions. We can get it, but let's run it
in the aggressive mode. So dash I will add
dash V to know what is going on.
You know, it will give more information. Now
you can see now it is giving more information
discovering open port. So this is what this
does, right? Sin scan by default is taken
the sin scan. Maybe if you give a STP, we'll
take the TCP scan by default the mistake,
the SS notice it does not showing you what
is going on. Okay. Operating system try and
are just trying to find the OS. And now NEC,
this is the n map scripting engine. So it
does also running some scripts, some default
scripts because our -a option. Okay. That's
that's the benefit of using dash a dash is
quite an intensive. Again, it may break a
lot of networks. You may not want to do it.
You may want to do it for by port. Okay? So
only scan port 80 and then work on it. Then
only scan port 139, and then we're going in.
So that's something you may want to do. We
are just running it. We are not carrying out
the network. That's fine. Let's keep it running
till them till then. I also want to tell you
one thing, possibly, you know, when you, when
you have these, when you are making this database
and his here is the part, normally you work
individually, right? You've got a team. When
you are in a team, of course you specify the
work. So in a project management software,
maybe your company will use Microsoft project,
Microsoft project, ms. Project, or your company
will use JIRA. So JIRA is a popular one. These
are possibly the two, two project management
softwares companies use. There are multiple
others as well, open project management, etc,
etc. They will give you, you know, they will
give you work. They will assign you work.
And normally they will do it on the port.
Once this discovery is done, they will, they
will start assigning ports. So port 80, who's
going to work on port 80 or port 22. Who's
going to work on port 22 and that's possibly
what you will be doing in future. Okay. Normally
you divide the work in teams.
So would you be dividing? So everybody's doing
the same kind of scans and attacks on those
ports or what could be running on it. So for
example, you know we might not be dividing
it at this time. I was just giving an example,
but think about it. Like, for example, this
scan has done. Let me tell you this scan right
now, here it is done. Now we know that, okay,
what are the processes? What are the services?
And doesn't, I'm trying to find SSH, right?
SSH version this. Now maybe I will divide
that work. And I will tell someone that, listen
on port 22 do all the tests now, which tests,
it really depends. You know, there, there
can be a lot of tests and you can find them
in the LPT methodology and, and you know depends
on the methodology again, but LPT methodology
has the tests.
If you check here, LPT master report templates,
these are the methodologies. So, you know,
for example, there is this one internal network
pen test, a firewall prevention let's see
web application. So for example, you find
port 80, right? And we also found 80. Let's
see here, we find port 80, which is running
apache. It, we know it's website, or a web
server, at least. So we are going to maybe
they're are going to tell someone that, listen,
go ahead and do all these scan, all the tests
given on this page. And let me show you one
thing. This is a 106 pages book, okay? These
are all the tests you see, these are all the
tests, fingerprint the application, you know,
maybe just perform website spidering . And
there are, there are different, different
tests that you can do perform banner grabbing
to identify the web server.
We just did that. We know that it is apache
and the version as well. We just did that.
But possibly these are the templates and you
normally, you don't do all the tests. You
have to look at the objective of the pen,
test, why the pen test is being done and what
are we trying to do? And on the basis of that
objective, you, you select some tests, you
know, you've talked to management, whatever
your client, you sell, you talk to them. And
this normally is done beforehand before testing,
and then you finalize the scope and then you
start testing and that's what you have to
divide. Right? You have to divide the work
into multiple people. That's normally in big
teams. That's what you do make sense now.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. Yeah.
Right. Thank you. Did we just close that?
Oh yeah, here it is. Now in this case we have
got these, these things, right? They got,
they got the versions and you can see, it
has run some scripts for us HTTP methods.
It does run some scripts now just to, you
know, go out of the topic in case we found
something like put delete, okay. Put and delete
are too dangerous options. Trace is also a
dangerous option because trace allows you
to do, you know, tracing, reverse tracing.
Maybe you can, you can open the password file,
or maybe you can find the location of some
things traces kind of risky option. It is
giving you that here you can Google it, how
to exploit traced, very easy. Get In, in terms
of, if you have the put option here in SDB
methods, you can upload a file arbitrary file
upload. Vulnerabiltiy comes in in the hand,
when you have put option, when you have delete
option, you can delete files in server
So maybe I will just go ahead and delete a
configuration file, or maybe I'll just go
ahead and take some, some important file,
which may give me some access. Most possibly
I can delete the firewall you know, all the
files of that firewall. So delete is a dangerous
option. Put is a dangerous option trace is
kind of risky option, or you, you know, it's
information disclosure kind of thing. So confidentiality
is violated with trace. Uso it is running
the script and that is giving you these, these
things, just telling you this red hat, Linux,
okay. These are the version of services, which
are running here. Uthis, this version was
not found. This version was not found again.
Okay. We found this version. We found this
version was not so, n map cannot do a lot
of things. Of course, that's, that's the limitation
of n map.
You know, not everything will have a banner,
but this is basically doing banner grabbing
in those cases. Again, we have to rely on
other tools and, and you know, what's more,
what's more better than using Metasploit,
you know, that's the professional framework
we will be using every time. So let's go ahead
and say metasploit before that service, postgreSQL
start, I'm starting a database service here.
Okay? Because I want to show you something.
UPostgreSQL is a database in Kali Linux. You
can use my SQL if you want, but postgreSQL
is by default install and MSF DB.
INIT a I'm telling meta sploit to possibly
just create a database or initialize a database,
whatever it wants to do. It says database
already appears to be configured. That's good.
If it was not, it will configure it automatically.
Now let's start it. MSF console. Now we have
just connecting a database. So everything
we do get stored in metaspoilt you know, everything
we do is, is, is going to be a part of it.
Now here, if you say workspace, you can see,
we got some workspaces. I created this one
while doing pen tests, or maybe another class,
a default is the one which you are in default
is a temporary database. It will go away.
What I suggest is you create a database here,
workspace dash a to add that need to be delete,
or possibly just try the help menu.
If you got confused here, we can say license
to pentest. I just added a database. If I
say a workspace, now we are in this database.
If I, if I want to change it, I can just say
workspace space, hacker in the house workspace
space, before I can change it like that. Right
now, we are in the license to pen test. Let's
create this screen. If I do host, you can
see, and Metasploit has got a full database.
It can create a target database for us. IP
address, Mac address, name operating system,
operating system version, operating system,
possibly special pack or service pack, purpose
info connects. It's going to do everything
for us. If I do ports NO, services. Yep. If
I do services, it's going to do IP address
port, not sure where it is, but name, state
info. Right? A lot of things it can do for
you, right? It's going to maintain a whole
database for you when you start doing some
things. You can, of course run n-amp in metsploit.
So I can just say a DB underscore n map to,
you know, to use n map, but to store everything
in a database of Metsploit DB underscore nmap
very quickly, I will do that scan. So dash
ss ten.zero.one 40 eight.one zero six. Right?
I hope that's the IP if I'm not wrong guys.
Yeah. Right. So I'm just going to scan all
the ports in it. Just to show you it's this
not the methodology, but I'm just showing
you, you can, you can do it. And then let's
say dash eight. So right now they started
a scan with all the ports on SS so sin scanning
on that IP, using aggressive mode, it will
take some time, but it will give us a lot
of information. Let me just cancel that and
add dash V as well so that we know what is
going on behind the scenes. Okay. There you
go. So it does a lot of scans RT scan, maybe
other TCP scan or something, and then it starts
a sin scan. It found these ports, and now
it is going to start the service can on these
ports, which have found, so let's let, let
us do it. Standing six services, a service
can be done. Opening systems can start. It
will start the opening system using the NSE
that has the n-map scripting engine, let it
do whatever it is doing right now.
And it's not going to take like more than
two minutes. So that's something fine. That's
the benefit of using the database. Now, everything
is finding will get stored in the database
and you can explore that database. You can
make XML file, HTML, files, PDFs. You know,
you can export that to other you know, you
can export that to other scanners like Nessus
or next post, right? You can, you can scan
all of these things, whatever you do, we can
send it to other scanners, automated scanners
automated pen testing tools like saint. So
you can, you can use this data and those tools.
I'm just telling you in the professional life
possibly in the LPT exam, you're not going
to go that deep. What you will be supposed
to do is you can use n map directly or in
the metasploit. It's your choice, but you
need to know how our scanning works. What's
the whole purpose of doing it. And that's
what LPT exams demands. So let's keep it running
and possibly we don't need it now anymore.
Let's, let's keep it though, as a safe option,
let's compare the results. All right. How
long is it going to take 227 and finished
out?
Okay. Two, 217 seconds lost then. So yeah,
maybe one more minute. There you go. Everything
got complete. We can clear this screen. We
don't need it. Now. Let's test hosts. We got
this steps. Okay. Let's let's do it again.
Maybe a little bit smaller hosts. You can
see it's giving us the IP is giving us the
Mac address. It's giving us.
There is a Linux, not exact version, but service
pack possibly version is this. Purpose. It's
a server. You can add these things so you
can add the name. If you get to know, you
can add some comments, you can add some info
and you can do that with a dash ad. So here's
the c-a and then you can add whatever you
want to add. You can write manualy let's check
services, so services, you can see this machine
has got this, this, this port open. Okay.
This was protocol. Okay. PCP protocol name
is this. This is the version. Okay. That's
what it is coming up with the versions, making
sense. Now that's what, that's what you were
supposed to make manually. Metasploit can
do it for you, right? And that's the, that's
the, one of the core reasons we use a framework
or a tool, which can, which can handle all
of this.
That's the main reason to use. Metasploit
one of the main reasons, because then you're
doing a big test. You know, it's one, two
IP, doesn't matter when you're handling like
40 IPS, which I was doing in that day, right.
That report, which I was just showing you
two minutes ago when we use 40 IP's, it becomes
a lot of work. It's going to take one day
in each IP. So 40 days project, it's like
a one month work. You cannot handle everything
manually. That's why you need all of this.
So anyways,ulet's try to see, we don't have
the version of this service. Okay. SMB, of
course we know that 139, 137 and 445 till
now. I hope you know, that is SMB port. We
have done it too many times now. So one 37,
one 39 SMB let's run SMB scanner. So,uyou
know, search SMB.
We have a lot of stuff there. And SMB as SMB
SMB and, I'm interested in SMB version, maybe,
you know, I need the version of that port.
So it will be an auxiliaries. Of course there
are the auxillaries, scanners, SMB enormous.
And we version, yep. This is the one. So possibly
let's try that. Copy here. Use this enter
show options, set r host. Now a good thing
is I can just press double tab and it will
show me all the r hosts in my target scope
in my database. I can just press double tab.
It is auto completing everything. Okay. It
is auto completing. I can just double tap.
It is showing me that they want to read for
the whole range or do they want to do it for
the selected host? Let's do it for a selected
host. That will be one zero six. So that's
the benefit. You know, it's going to take
everything automatically. I don't have any
other information. I will just run it.
Now here, it got completed. Host could not
be identified, but we got to know that version
is this right? That's something interesting.
We got to know that. The, the services running
desk services, we, you can see it automatically
updates. The, you see, it automatically updates
whatever you do. So now you have that in your
records. That's one of the beauty for, for
using this kind of thing. Similarly, you can
do same thing with RPC wine and this service,
we don't even know what service it is. You
can completely ignore that. Maybe it's a proprietary
service, whatever, but RPC wine, you can find
the version similar way. Just like I found
the SMP version similar. You can find it now
coming to the testing part. Okay. Coming to
the testing part. What is the next step? Let's
suppose just ignore this for a moment, but
let's suppose we got all the versions.
What's the next step guys. I'm asking you.
So we scanned enumeration. We found that exploit
it, find a exploit for it. Vulnerability before.
Yeah. Before finding an exploit, we need the
vulnerability. First of all, right? Because
maybe there is a vulnerability and there is
no exploit for it. But if there is an exploit,
there is a vulnerabilty So it's vice versa.
It's not true. So first of all, vulnerability,
how do you do that? Again? Multiple options
you can, of course you can just, you know
start searching off about these things in
Metasploit itself, you can start doing that
here itself. I don't see anything good here.
Maybe you can use this one in a users. It
will give you users on this SSH sports. But
at this time, you know, this is the stage.
When you have all of this, this is the stage
where you may want to divide the work, because
it's going to take a lot of time.
You've got a SSH, service, now you have to
do a lot of tests. We are just rushing it.
We are doing it very quickly, you know, just
to end the lecture, but in real life, you
may have to do a lot of tests. Maybe right
now, we are focused on getting access in a
real test. You don't care about access. When
you care about this vulnerability this enemy
user, if you are able to get a user name that
is a vulnerability that is affecting the confidentiality,
you are able to find usernames, which is,
which is not a good thing. You're compromising
the confidentiality. So maybe you will exploit
this service. Okay? You will run this exploit
possible. Similarly, Apache, you got this
one let's copy as clear, right? And similarly,
okay. There's a lot of stuff. Possibly all
of this stuff is coming because you know,
the version number is somewhere common here.
So two is here. So that's where it's coming.
Maybe I can just do apache. Now these are
the Apache exploits. Possibly I can just go
ahead and you know, it takes time. Okay. It
can take easy. It can take three to four days
in a normal work. If you are doing a pen test,
which has got a lot of, you know vulnerabilities,
ia lot of ports, a lot of services running.
It can easily take two to four days to complete
one or two IPS. Okay. That's the real life
experience in our cases because we know LPT
exam is six hours. And we know that, you know,
we are doing only one machine, I mean three
machines in six hours. So roughly you get
two hours on one machine. It's not going to
be that hard. You will easily be able to find
vulnerability
It's not going to be that hard. What they
want to check is the methodology, what we
use and how you do it. So once you found the
services, it's possibly easy for you to go
ahead and Google these versions. Just maybe
you can just Google these versions. I can
just go on Google and I can post them to try
to find the Versions. There you see vulnerabilities
and you will see this version is having some
vulnerabilities, possibly 3.2. Okay. And then
you can see, we have some, some things here,
a 7.5 is the score. You can read about it
again. It's gonna take time. Right? so that's,
that's something you, you may want to do.
What I am interested in is the Samba, because
I know this is vulnerable. Okay. because I,
I am the one who has created the whole infrastructure.
So I just want to show you very quickly. For
example, if I search for this again, we've
got a lot of options. Okay. Once you do some
research, you know, once you go on Google
and you search about it and you do some research
you will, you will get to know that this,
this specific version it was quite vulnerable.
Okay. For example, 9.3 here you know, execution
code overflow. So you can overflow, eh, something
over there. There are again, a 10 out of 10,
there's a execution code, overflow DOS denial
of service. So when you do some research,
you will get to know, okay, when you do some
research. You will get to know that this thing
here SAMBA trans through open overflow. This
is a vulnerability, which is affecting this
specific version SAMBA. But once you do some
research, you will get to know that this,
the Samba trans open this affects any SAMBA,
Version, which is I think, which is less than
2.7. And in our case, it is 2.2. So this is
possibly going to affect it. Once you know
that we already know it's a Linux, so we will
use this possibly you can use it in this way.
Okay. Sorry. Copy.
And it's all about research. That's going
to take time. So let's say we know that there
is a vulnerability overflow is there. We found
the exploit similar way. Okay. Let's press
enter. I will share the screen. And I can
hear by do show options. When I have to set,
as r host said, r hosts and one zero six port
is 139. You can change it to four 45 or one
37, depending upon your target and just run
it. And you will see, it will not work again
telling you it will not work because you see
here meterpreter session, one open, but then
meterpreter session. One closed reason died.
Your shell is dying again. And again, this
can be due to two reasons. Either you're pivoting
is not working fine. In our case, we are not
even doing pivoting. Right? We are directly,
we are assuming they're doing pivoting, but
right now they're directly connected. So it
is not the problem. And the problem is with
the exploit. Okay?
Okay.
Why? Because if you do show options. Yeah.
It's not showing, yeah. This is using meterpreter,
reverse TCP. And this meterpreter is a stager,
right? What is this stager again? In a stager,
it will send a small payload, maybe 300 bytes,
400 bytes, whatever. Let's see if we can see
that here. Sending yeah. Sending stage. This
was the size of stage. Okay. It sends the
stager. Okay. The first stage, that is a payload.
That is a code. What that code will do is
that code will fetch the remaining code. That
code is going to fetch the remaining code.
That is what we are sending. We are not sending
the actual code. They're sending a small piece
of code that fetches the remaining code. And
then it executes. That's where we are. We
are sending in a state, but this sometimes
involves having a lot of session dies. That's
the problem. We can change it to a non stage.
We can change it to a single, okay. Single
set payload. It's an, linux/86 double tab
to see all available payloads. These are all
stagers. We need a single, this is a single,
but I don't know what this will do. So I'm
not using it. Shell is a very common one.
Meterpreter and shell are the two very common
ones in shell. These are again stagers, but
this here is a single so reverse. TCP is the
one which I prefer. I will just use this one.
So shell reverse TCP. Okay. That's what I
want to use. Let's run it this time.
And you can see this time. It says command
shell session three open, and it doesn't die.
Now we have it, but this is not meterpreter.
You cannot do pivoting. You cannot do porting.
Literally. You cannot do anything specific,
which Meterpreter brings you right now. You
have a shell, right? When you type shell meterpreter,
that's what you have. You can type IP config.
Okay. That even breaks it. I cannot trust
that. Okay. IP IF config, right? That doesn't
work. Maybe you named that you named dash
a yeah. That works. So it telling us we are
in the Linux. This is the host name or possibly,
this is the version of the Linux. This is
the time and date. And, and I'd say 32 bit
architecture. Okay. Something is unknown.
That's, that's possibly, it is telling you,
but you cannot do a lot of things. You don't,
maybe you don't have privileges. You are not,
you know, root user. So you cannot run high
config. It's, it's kind of a limited shell.
That's what you can do. And in this case,
you can do one thing. You can try to background
it. Control Z. Okay. why enter? Background
it You can try to search for two . Meterpreter
metER PRETER two. Meterpreter. And it doesn't
work. Okay. So 2 underscore meterpreter. Now
you search STAICH. [inaudible]
Yup. You can try this you know, you can try
this post exploitation tool. It's a post exploitation
tool sessions. I have session number three,
running, which is a shell. Possibly. I can
run this post explotation and I can upgrade
myself. It's very difficult, but sometimes
it will work, set session two, three that's
basically what I need. I can just run it.
Okay. Sometimes it will work. So it's worth
a try. I mean, that's the whole point. It's
worth a try here. You can see it. It just
failed right. It opened it, it opened it,
but at the end, again, it failed forcibly
because this, this machine does not accept
stage payloads. Okay. Stagers. It doesn't
accept due to that. And it doesn't work. And
some cases it will work and it will work very
nicely. So it's a good handy tool shell to
meterpreter and it's post exploitation tool.
Always do it whenever needed by the way. But,
you know, at the end we made it, I mean, we
got the access. The reason why we are not
able to maybe run meterpreter or run any command
is, are, are, you know, privileges are kind
of limited. So we may have to, you know do
privilege escalation. That is something we
will cover in the next class. But what I'm
trying to show you is forcibly. We can run
post exploitation. We can can do it. Then
we may have to do you know we may have to
do privileged escalation. So who am I here?
You can see, I am root. Okay. That's kind
of interesting. I'm root, but still I'm not
able to run the services which is quite amazing.
Why is that not working? If config no PSSWD
can I change the password? Oh, that's good.
I can change the password. Let's say bansal@123.
There you go. That's fine. So now I just want
to, you know, you can btw , you can connect
with SSH or whatever you want. I will directly
try that here. I will directly try that. We
just changed the password. Right? So root
bansal@123. Oh, there you go. You can just
log in and now you can do whatever you want
from the shell. So yes, I can do whatever
I want from here. This is the, the command
it's working properly fine. So you can now
connect with SSH maybe. Right. SSH and I'm
sorry, you can possibly connect with SSH,
because we know that there is assistance running.
So that's possibly right. Making sense. What
we just there, what are we trying to do creatively?
Right. Uso the whole point here, which I wanted
to show you was services.
Yep. The whole point I wanted to show you,
what was that? You know, I knew that, , this
version is vulnerable. And that's why I just
did it now in this machine, there is this
version, okay. This version opensl. This is
also vulnerable Right? And, and there is no
exploit in the Metasploit. There is no exploit
about it in the metasploit. You have to do
it manually. That's what this, this, this
whole thing is all about. If I show you more
a I think this is the part, which is vulnerable
let's see. So in metasploit you won't find
an exploit. But if I go out of metasploit
if I do something like search sploit here,
nothing found, okay. Nothing found, okay.
SSL.
Oh, sorry. While I was using search it'll
search. So I search spolit another tool, here
you go. No result Yep. Here you can see. So
more or less, a less than 2.8 0.7. We have
2.8 0.4. Right? So all of these three will
work and these are basically, you know, a
version, maybe zero version one or version
two. So I think they did a mistake in typing.
This must be version one. This must be version
two. So you can use this exploit. Okay. It
isn't your kali Linux. You can just, you know,
copy this. You can just copy this one. This
part, last part here. Control C. You can just
save search spoilt. Let me just first go to
desktop search exploited dash M middle, it
is m middle and paste that last number press
enter. And here you will see, it will make
that exploit come on your desktop.
Now, this is the exploit. You can open it
with something like leafpad. And normally
you will find, you know, this is a C file,
right? C language written code. You will,
of course have to compile it, make a, make
an exploit out of it, which is software. There's
a code. You have to make it an executable
file. So that's something you may have to
do. Of course, sometimes good author. So this
one is a good author. You know, he has added
everything version is this, you have to have
this package You can run this command to install
that package, compile it with GCC. This is
a compiler. This is the full command. You
can use this command. You can do it. Yep.
That's, that's basically it as right. Or you
can then run the, run the file once you get
it, though, I think, I mean, this is something
I can leave on you as a homework, I have done
it.
I will send you the video that you can refer
to do it. There's something i can leave as
a homework for you. But the whole point was
sometimes you don't have exploits in metasploit
and tried. You will not find any exploit for
this specific version in metasploit. Then
you have to use these public exploits. In
Professional tests. You may do not. You may
not want to do it. Okay. Maybe this code is
not accredited, right? I don't know who has
written this code. I don't know who is this
person who is this person of whatever the
author is. And I don't even see the author
name now. Okay. I don't know who made this
and who he was. What was his environment when
he was making this? So in those cases, you
may want to, you know, stay away from it,
this kind of thing, but completely possible.
Really. You know, if the scope allows, if
the management says that, okay, we are okay
with it. You can run it. We have the backup
of the system. Then you can, you can run these
kinds of things and you can try to, you know,
run this command and then, then finally compile
it and do it. I will send you a video, how
to do that. I'm not a problem. Or maybe you
guys can try it first. It's very easy. Just
try it first. And if you still face a problem,
I will even help you out. Or maybe in the
next class, we can do it live. If you guys
want, however you guys prefer. So that's,
that's something you, you need to learn the
public exploits. These are the public exploits.
What we use in metasploit are the commercial
exploits. Okay. That's the different public
versus commercial. Any, any note, any doubt
there? No, not sounds good. Right? So I will
be sending access to this machine, this Vicky
hacker in the house.com. I will sending this,
this machine to you guys at least, first of
all, try the metasploit version and then try
to do the, you know, the nonsploit version.
The public has tried to do that. If you are
able to do it well, very good. If you're not
able to do it, we will see what we can do.
Right?
Make sense? Any questions? Sense? Any questions?
None at the moment. So privillege escalation
again, it's all about you have the machine,
you got some initial access. Maybe you got
a user access. Now you want to become root,
right? Or you want to become anti-authority
in case of windows, the admin access. How
do you get that? So that is what privilege
escalation is all about. And again, that is
a specialized field because privilege
Escalation is not limited to network pen testing.
It can be done anywhere. It can be done in
IOT, IOT devices. It can be done in Android,
it can be done in Java languages, Python,
interpreters, and then iOS. And, and then,
you know, routers firewalls. It can be done
basically every single layer. Can you hack
a motherboard like software, actual have a,
physical software, like motherboard CPU. Yes,
that is called hardware hacking, there is
a whole big industry in hardware hacking.
You can even have cars. You can have planes.
You're going to, whatever car hacking is a,
car hacking is another field. And if you remember
Tesla, Tesla, every year, Tesla gives you
a big bounty plus the car that you have. So
a supercar, you can win a super car if you
have their car. So car hacking is a big thing
in your hand.
Sorry, can you hack that car? I know. I don't
know car hacking. So as I said, you know,
pen testing is, is, is just like an ocean
that you cannot bring the whole ocean. You
cannot be everything. You need to select a
very specific niche and then come out and
be an expert in that niche. That's the only
thing you need to do for me. It's mostly does
a risk assessment. So even I, I'm not a, I'm
not, maybe I'm not the best person to do the
pen testing, but I'm the best person to take
that pen testing result and then assign the
risk values and tell the company what they
have to do now, you know, that management
level stuff. So maybe I consider myself the
best person in the risk management, in pen
testing and management apprentice. How do
you manage this? How do you manage the budgets,
finance?
How do you manage people? How do you distribute
work? How do you take control of all of that?
You know, project management. That's one of
my core competencies and I even have my executive
education, project management. That's one
of the reasons I did that because I just want
to be best in, in one single field. If tomorrow,
if tomorrow there is a, there's a multibillion
company, they want to do a pen test. They
will not call me because I'm the best person
to, you know, to, to exploit the system. They
will call me because I can manage the people
who are best in and doing their stuff. Right.
So that is what you need. You just need to
be best in one specific field privilege. Escalation
is one of them. You can, you can be a privileged
escalator, one of the best. But as I said,
it's a highly specialized field.
Yup. But go on, on your website, pen testing,
you said like in it, you know, like we have
pen testing. So, so say example good on network
pen test. You wanna become network pen tester.
So you say, if you don't know how to, website
pentesting that the company, they're not gonna
teach you for the job that most likely does.
He said, no. I said that pen testing is a
basic field, which companies will be looking
for. I'm not saying you have to be an expert
to get a job, but the basic level of the pen
testing is quite necessary. If you want a
job in, in pen testing general testing. So
even if you want to be a good network pen
tester, you still need to learn the basics
of the pen testing because sometimes you will
find port 80 is open port 443 is open in network,
but not, then that is a big port, right?
So you have to relate to development. That's
been there. That's the one point. But again,
if you become very good in, in weapon testing,
there is a whole big field, right? Companies
will, will invite you in private programs.
There are bug bounty programs. You can give
a bounty on there. You can be a source code
review expert. That pen testing is again,
very big field. You can, you can do a bug
bounties. You can do black hat testings. You
can do. You know, you can do security testings.
You can do functionality, testings. You can
do a lot of stuff in weapon testing. So it's,
it's kind of a very big field again. So at
the end, you just need to bring down to one
specific niche, one specific niche, which
you want to be an expert and just be an expert
in that specific thing.
And companies will be calling you and inviting
you as an expert. And that's what happened.
I'm not sure. Like I feel like or I would
network testing that was on the reason is
because you have not seen on the fields. I
mean, in the course itself, we have not focused
on everything, right? We did not focus on
hardware hacking. We did not focus on bio
hacking. We haven't focused on social engineering
because this course is not meant to teach
you everything. It's, it's meant to give you
that foundation, which you need to be the
person you want to be. You are actually getting
the foundation. Now, you know those things,
which no one else knows. Right? So 90% of
the people, that one was confused. You go
to any, you go to any senior pen tester in
any big company, they will not know the clear
purpose, what they are trying to do.
They are there to do their job. Nothing else.
They don't know what they want to be. They
don't have any big goals. They're their maximum
goal is a hundred thousand dollars salary.
Oh, let's say $200,000 salary. That's the
maximum, right? They don't think about that.
How will you buy it? Okay. That's the simple
question. How will you buy a private jet in
that $200,000 salary? That debt is going to
cost you $50 million? How will you get $15,000?
How will never become a millionaire? If you
go ahead and run behind that salary. That's
more thing, right? You need to build your
own business someday. That is the, that is
the only way you can, you can achieve those
numbers. And I mean, I have done that. I have
been a millionaire, right? I have done that.
And that's why I am eligible to tell you.
So at the end, you, you need a business. Of
course starting a business is not a game.
You, you never want to start a business in,
you know, in, in your starting phase, you
always want to do work. You want to be getting
trained by some other companies use their
money, resources, sorry, but I don't like
actually business. You cannot just say that
I don't like business. You have to do that.
This is the necessity. And you can hire business
experts. You cannot have business experts
who are going to run your business and you
can be good at your field. You can just be
a best pen tester, and there can be other
business experts. You can just go ahead and
hire some Harvard, , Harvard MBA or something
like that. You can just, you know, find people
at the end it's delegation. You can find people
and get things done that you can, you can
maybe come to me, right?
And I can help you up to settle your own business.
But at the end that that's like four or five
years after things right now, the goal should
be, get a job. Maybe it's a junior job, whatever.
Get a job. Anyhow, get a job, learn how to
do, how to work in the industry for maybe
one year or maximum two years, two years is
the maximum. After that, maybe just quit the
job or start doing freelancing. So working
on pen tests for companies, right, just to
start working, anyhow, maybe money will be
less, but you will get experience and reputation,
right? Your, your goal should be at that time,
making your reputation. Once you get the reputation,
you start taking big clients, you start taking
joint programs, you start getting into government
work. And once you have that reputation, you
open up a business. You open up company, you
open, you hire 10 people.
You are 20 people. You are a team. That's
how you scale your business. And not that
that's what you have to do. So again, you
mentioned, you know, of course, or risk assessment
is kind of a completely different topic. I
will be happy to send you lectures on that.
So I have two different courses on this management.
One is the, the nest, risk management framework,
which is used in government, which is open
source. One is ISO. So ISO 27,005, which is
a proprietary paid framework. I cannot show
you the paid one because it's, again, they
will, they will Sue me in the court. So I
only do that in the live, but I can send you
the nist one. So NIST, RMF, I'll send you
the recordings. It's very easy. It's not that
hard to do this management. The difference
at the end is, you know, basically it's maths.
So you have to do maths. That's one of the,
that's one of the problems critical thinking
about, so I'll send you, I'll send you. Thank
you. Thank you. Right. All right. So let's
come into the class, then play with escalations.
As I said, it's completely specialized field.
You don't have to learn it, but basically
everything, you know, you need to learn basics
of everything,. That's the whole point. You
just need to know what it is. For example,
if you need to get an idea for any time idea.
So if you search for help and I'm just showing
you some resources where you can follow, because
there is no specific methodology for risk
management, sorry for privileged escalations.
If you go to bot milk privilege, escalation,ulinux
privilege, escalation, you can follow this
online guidance. It's kind of a good guide
and there is windows privilege, escalation
here. So you can just, you know, go ahead
and.
And then find things, that it is one of the
good ones. And then they tell you, you can
do an enumeration. So it's basically the same
cycle. You do enumeration, you find the weaknesses
and then you find an exploit and then you
exploit it, right? It's the same cycle. The
differences, you will enumerate a lot of stuff.
You will see what is already running on this
system from inside. They'll know you are doing
it from outside, right? Port scanner, service
scanners. Now you are already inside the machine.
So you can run the commands like cat hc issue,
cat hc release. So you can now try to open
the files in the system itself. That's the
whole point, right? And then you can maybe
find applications and services. What is running
in the machine? You can maybe use PS box,
right? These are different, different commands.
Now you are in the machine, you have the access,
you are in the machine. So now you start finding
these, these different, different you know
commands , you start running these commands.
You can, you can check has been, I have config,
basically running. I have configured. You
don't need to put as many there, but they
just put it that you can run. If config to
check the IPS from inside of the machine now.
Right? All of those stuff you do enumeration.
You find what is running on the machine. What
kind of directories are there? What kind of
is there any device, exploit, device connected
to machine. You do all of that. Then you try
to find exploits right on the basis of those
things. It's basically the same stuff, whatever
you do. But now you are trying to find the
privilege, escalation exploits, which are
basically same thing.
They are also exploits, but they help you
to increase the privilege, right? And that's,
that's one of the, that's basically the smaller,
am sorry what was this foot line, sorry, is
it for after hacking or privilege escalation.
So for example, you got a user account hacker
in the house user. Now you want to become
a root without password. How do you escalate
your, your, your privilleges right now recommended,ustuff,
which I can teach you here. I mean, what you
should do if you want to be in the industry,
the recommended way, which I can show you
is,uOs boxes OS boxes.org. That's the website.
Osboxes dot org. Go there and download as
many as operating systems. You can just download
the operating systems and try to have those
operating systems. Every system is different.
That's why I cannot basically teach privilege.
Escalation on every system, you go here, virtual
box images, right?
Virtual box images. Vmware is also there.
And then they give you a lot of operating
system. They will not give you a windows because
of course, that's a paid software.windows
is not open source thing. They cannot give
you the windows, but they give you Linux and
windows. You can arrange yourself. I don't
know how, but you can arrange yourself from
Microsoft itself. You can download windows.
So you just start downloading these opening
systems. They are prebuilt free install. You
just download and set up and how to set up.
It's quite different than what I give you.
So let me just set up one of them so I can
just send you. And I said, yup, we need you
pen testing. What's
The most hack. Did you hack like a example,
did you have most of the time windows 10
It's basically ubuntu and cent OS as not only,
they are always using Linux. Windows is very
rarely found in and most of the companies,
because again, it's a paid software. How many
licenses will the company buy for employees?
It's always windows. It's most of the times
that windows, Mac iOS has always also found,
but still it has windows in most, most employees'
computers, but servers are always either ubuntu
or cent OS So, for example, if, if you go
and maybe open ubuntu here, and then you say,
download VirtualBox image, it will give you
the versions, different, different versions
of ubuntu, but just try out, randomly take
any of them and try to follow this guide.
This guide tried to see. So if we see, for
example, you see all of these out there, the
easiest one of course will be the most outdated
one. This one.
So I have downloaded this one. I mean, I think
I have all of these, but let's, let's start
with this one. They can just download from
here. And let's say, I want to set it up in
virtual box. You click on new and then you
give it a name. I just gave it a name. It
doesn't matter what you put. You just have
to give it a name and then you have the choose
it it is Linux and it is right. So I'll say
32 bits because I have downloaded a 32 bit
version next, give it a ram. Let me just increase
the Ram or something else. So let's say, let's
say 2448. 2GB RAM So two, zero, four, eight
should be fine next. And then you can say,
do you want to create a hard disc or not No,
we downloaded the hard disc from this website.
So I will say, add, use an existing harddisk.
Okay. And then you can find the harddisk so
add, and you can find the harddisk. And I
can basically go in my ISO files or media
files, whatever, and then you can open a harddisk.
So ubuntu 12, that is what I'm going to open
up and just say, choose create. And now your
machine is created That is what you have to
do. Basically as i start this machine. It
should work.
And by the way, be forgot to add a network
adapter, sorry. We forgot to add a network,
You know, last time I had the issue with the
machine, like it doesn't show up the IP address,
Sorry, man. Oh it was some misconfiguration
with, with your virtual box.
I find like I've downloaded another machine.
I think I sent you a picture. Yeah. That machine
is that happened exactly. Same issue. Like
if you download the new new machine on,
On the virtual box, like it doesn't show the
machines which you download from internet
will not work with my setup. So these ranges
like in these like these, you know, one dot
ten dot hundreds range 148. They will not
work with these ranges automatically because
I, I have created these machines, myself,
to take those ranges. Now I'm creating a range.
Another one for just that machine also needs
to be configured to pick, to pick that range.
Right? So normally you would, you would want
to keep them on bridge nat. In this case,
I will put it on that bridge dot, nat as the
default, when you, you may want to put it
on, let's add this machine. I'm just going
to show you a rough demos of how privileged
escalation may look like,
Starting up
And let's start kali linux. And I will put
my adapter on that. So i wll add this is adapter
on that.
Okay. So start.
So ubuntu is opening here. So a password is
normally always, always osboxes.org in their
website. You can find it on the page itself
osboxes.org. It's a very nice website. I mean,
it's say it's a free project. None of that
would use a name. Username is also osboxes.
A password is also osboxes. Let me try to
increase the resolution. It's going to suck
them. So how do I increase the resolution
system settings, resolution and resolution.
Okay. Let me increase it to 1080p. Do you
see any 1080p1920? Wait. No. All right. Let's
let's just take this one then apply. Yeah.
It's cool. Keep this configuration it's big
enough. I think we can read everything here.
Right? So this is out of this one ubuntu right?
And then you have terminal in the menu. So
I'm just going to open, terminal.
There is the terminal and I'm trying to increase
the size, but I cannot do. And that's fine.
And does it really happen? Right? You can
read it right. Okay, cool. So let's check.
Ip if config, you can see my IP address is
10.0.2.15, which is the default nat. Right?
Whenever you add a range, it always pick 10.0.2.
That is the default. Okay. let's go ahead
and say root licensed to pen test. And by
the way, you can, you can put it in any range
if you want. I mean, I can literally, I can
just go there a network and I can change this
to nat network. And I can actually go ahead
and put anything here. Range hundred. I can
put a hundred. It will work because the ranges
which we have chosen are DHCP enable, and
this machine is also gets enable os boxes.
All the machines are enable. So if I do the
exit line, the exit line -r to release the
ip address and then again, DST client to get
the IP address. Okay. Not permitted. We are
not root. Of course. So Sudo su root, uh OS
boxes. In real pen test ,Do you get the IP
address? You may get the IP address. It sometimes
happens, they will give you IP, or they will
give you a URL. You can just ping the url
to get the IP. So at the end, yes, you get
the DNC client, that DHC client.
Okay, come on. It's taking time. I don't know
if it's even working. So now, if we check
the IP, you can see my IP is ten dot. It did
not change. And I was expecting it will change,
but I'm not sure why let's leave. DHC client
is universal command for most of the Linux
distribution. So Kali Linux is basically based
on Debian. Debian and ubuntu share very similar
architecture, whatever you run in debian is
the same in ubuntu, right? So at the end,
both of the Linux systems are working similar.
There is something called red hat, Linux,
which is a different architecture. It will
probably not work in red hat and red hat.
Linux, examples are cent os, cent os is, is
the operating system, which is in the category
of red hat. And then there, it will not work,
but ubuntu and debian are same family. And
in that family, Kali Linux is based on Debian.
So it will work osboxes.Org. Excellent. And
now we should have something.
There you go, terminal , and let's check IP
now, and this should be 10.100, Right. As
I said, we changed the range. So this will
basically pick up any IP you assigned it.
It's basically taking the IP's of HCP server
ten.zero dot hundred, dot eight, right? That's
the IP we have. In Kali also, I think I have
a hundred IP. I think I have, If config. You
can see, I have access to a hundred IP. No,
I don't. Okay. Yeah. This one. So I have access
to a hundred IP, 10 dot zero dot 109. If I
try to ping that machine. So paying 10.0.100.8,
you can see, I am getting replies, which means
I can communicate with that machine right
now, for example, you are being privileged
escalation, right? So for example, you are
trying to do privilege escalation and think
about this terminal in your kali linux.
So in your kali linux, you hack the machine,
you get the terminal, right? So things are,
this terminal is in your kali linux right
now. And you're trying to do the escalation
and, and we are not root user. We are os boxes
user here. Right? First thing I always liked
to do is you name dash a, you name dash a
when you do you name dash a. It tells you
what operating system with what release you
are using. So here you can see a this i, whatever
that name was, and you can Google it. It will
tell you it is 12.04 version. So this is the
code name of ubuntu that is the operating
system. So here, this is the Kernel version.
And one of the ways to be privileged, escalation
is technical version. So now I have this information,
right? I will take this information, go on
Google and try to find if this version is
exploitable or not.
Is this vulnerable or not? That is one of
the ways. Then I can maybe also do something
called a DP, KJ, TC kg , dash L. So DPkg -l
so DPkg is the package manager dash L basically
lists everything that is installed on kali.
So now these are the software's. These are
the packages that are installed on this kali
linux. So these are all the softwares that
are installed. Okay. So maybe I can now just
take these versions right here, these versions,
these softwares, and try to see if they are
vulnerable or not. So these are different,
different things you have to do. And again,
this guide has explained most of that, all
of these commands, you have to try, you have
to get all of this information, then do your
research, and then do the escalation. And
that is the reason it is a .
Very, very specific niche. Specialized skillset
is not an easy task is a very difficult task,
but that, that is the reality that is what
you have to do. You can do name dash r. It
will just show you the kernel itself. You
name dash a. It gives you the full information,
the same thing. I'm just going to give you
an example, how, who hack by a kernel version?
So let's say you name dash r. I have the kernel
version here, 3.13.0-12, right? Maybe I will
go in my kali linux and I will tried to find
it exploit for this. I can maybe say it search
sploit. Or you can do it in metasploit? But
searchsplit is a good tool, searchsploit.
And I can just say, Linux kernel, sorry, spelling
wrong. And now you can see there are so many
Linux kernel exploits sign.
So you can see every kernel has got some kind
of exploit there, but I have a specific version.
So I will maybe just say Linux kernel, which
one? We have 3.13. So let's say 3.13. We still
have a lot. So what is the full version 3.1.0
dash 32. So 3.1.0 - 30. Not that that dash
32 that does'nt matters that this specific
release but this is the, is the main version.
Now we got to two different exploits here,
right? So similarly, now this one is a C exploit.
This is written in C. This is a text file.
Text file. Normally contains how to use the
exploit, how to make your own expert C is
the one which is already made. So I will basically,
for example, I will copy this exploit. So
copy, and I will basically copy this on my
desktop. So maybe I'll just go to the desktop
and I have folder called exploit there. There
are some things there. Let me just remove
them very quickly.
So this is folder is empty now. So I will
just search search sploit - m and I will paste
that link, which we copy and press enter.
And it will now copy that exploit in my kali
linux. Now, if I do LS in this folder, we
have this exploit. Now this is the exploit.
Let's read it. So more, three more. This is
one of the commands you can use to read the
files. First few lines here. We read it. And
I would say exploit, title something, something,
something, it works. It works on ubuntu 12.4,
14, 14.10,15 a lot more. Right? So it is going
to one. So now kernel, sorry. Kernel plus
operating system should match. Yeah. So here
operating system is matching. This is the
opening system is already match. Now how to
use it. Do they have something I don't see.
So these are all commands, right?
They all commented out. So this is a user.
They are given an example. You check you name
dash a, you check it like that. You get the
version, right. Then you say GCC the file
dash o the output file. So input file, output
file, right? And then once you check your
ID, you will see it is the username. But once
you run this expert dot slash, run the exploit,
it will do something. And finally you will
have the hash sign. So this hash sign means
your root. When you check the id again, it
will show you root. So they have given the
full example there. So basically I need to
run GCC. GCC is the compiler, the whole problem
with Linux exploits. This is the biggest problem.
You have to transfer the exploit to the machine
which you want to hack. This is not a remote
exploit. This is a local exploit right?
This is a privilege. Escalation exploit. This
is a Local exploit local exploit needs to
run on the target machine itself. So we need
to transfer this exploit in that machine and
then run it. Okay. So I will just say a quick
here cube, easiest way to transfer the exploit
is to set up a web server in your machine
and you download then the exploit in that
target machine. Now how to set up a server,
easiest way Python. You just say python dash
n, python dash n and then simple HTTP server,
simple HTTP server simple HTTP is capital,
and then server S is, capital simple HTTP
server and then give it a port. I will give
port 80 and press enter. Now it will start
a python server on port 80 of your machine.
Once someone go to your IP address, it will
open a folder which will contain all the files.
So I have started a server in this location,
but if I open my IP, you will see. So if I
open my IP, I go to Firefox. You can see what
happens. So for example, ten.zero dot a hundred
dot nine, which is my IP. You see, if I open
my IP address, it will show you a directory
listing. And here's the content of the folder,
right? That does. That is what I do now. Assume
that I am in the terminal of my machine, which
I had, this is that terminal. I can now download
that exploit because of course it does now
hosted on internet. So I can download that
exploit for that. You need some, some way,
right? You cannot just run Firefox because
mostly you will have a terminal Access. So
you need to download things. From terminals
two famous commands are wget and curl both
are same, both works very well.
Both are installed. And windows, you will
mostly find wget is installed, Sorry curl
is installed and, and in linux you will find
them, wget is also installed. So it doesn't
matter. Whatever is installed in, whichever
machine, you know, Wget HTTP and the IP address.
So ten.zero dot a, let's say a hundred dot
nine, which is my IP address, right. And then
slash, and then the file name. So I can then
again, a C so I can actually just say, right
click copy location. And then I can just paste
it here. And this is the full location. So
basically slash file name, right? So three
seven two nine three seven two nine dash three
seven two nine two dot c. Right? I can do
that. I will not do it right now because we
may not have permission to do this kind of,
okay. Sometimes you cannot turn the wget and
you can save files when you have restricted
user.
So always, always, always go ahead. And first
of all, go to temp for them. Cd slash temp.
Okay. Because temp folders always writable
you can write whatever you want in go to temp
folder and then download. I just pasted that
command. You can say, you can see save file
has been saved. If I do LS, you can very well,
see, I have downloaded that file, right? That
has the file in the corner. Now, once you
have the file, you need to compile it to compile
it. You need a GCC. So as you see here, so
I can just close it and you will see in our
Python server, there was a get request coming
from this machine dot eight machine, right?
The last request, which came, which is a vulnerable
machine and download it, I'll just cancel
it. I don't need it. If I do more on the file,
we can see, we need to run a GCC.
But the problem is GCC is a software and it
is not installed on the machine. There can
be very easy case. GCC is not installed on
your target machine. You cannot, you cannot
do anything. Basically. You, you literally
cannot do anything in that case. The only
option you can use in that case. So for example,
GCC is not installed here. What you can do
is you can make a virtual machine, and this
is the practical thing that you will do. You
will make a virtual machine with the same
operating system, with the same kernel version,
same operating system, same kernel version.
You install GCC in that you compile the exploit
in that. Then you transfer that compiled exploit,
right? That, that file, which you compile
after this command, that file, which you get
you transfer that file them. But so, because
compilation is done in this same environment,
you compile it manually into a simulated environment,
which is the same version of the operating
system, same kernel version, which is kind
of a big challenge to find that same thing.
And again, it's very expensive stuff. So your
client's budget needs to be kind of expensive.
In that cases, it will take easily one day
for the whole day to make all of that. So
one day extra buget. So that, that is something
that you may have to do, but let's, let's
try to see if we have GCC in this machine.
So I would just say GCC, I would press enter
and you can see GCC error no input file dound
basically we have GCC. That's why it's giving
the error that no input file was found So
we said GCC, and then we just give it to the
file name, which is three dot. Something we
didn't say dasd o output. We need the compiled
output file.
We need it. Just give it a name. I will just
say exploit. I will just make a file. Whose
name is exploit, press enter it has been compiled,
now you can see if I do LS again, you can
see we have a new file. Now which is exploit,
right? This is the new file And this is the
exploit This is the real exploit, which you
have to run. And now this is in the green,
green color, but you always should check LS
dash lh. And ls is the list dash lh human
readable, always check here it should have
X. Okay. So for example read write? And then
this one is X execute the right execute. You
should always have execute permissions. Otherwise
you will not be able to run it in this case.
We have it by default in case you don't have
to do ch mod.
So ich mod CH MOD +X, which is execute. You.
Just add the executable permission on the
file. Once you do that, you will have the
executable permissions. So if I, if I tried
now again, you can see we still have the same
permissions, but if it was not there. So just
to show you, if I remove the executable permissions
by doing minus X, if I remove them, and then
if I show you, you can see now we don't have
any executable permissions here. It does only
read, write, read, write, read, write. So
we need executable permissions. That means
you cannot run it just say plus X again. Sometimes
it will automatically come with the exploit
compiling sometime it will not consult. Always
check that first in this case. Now we again
have it. So now we can run it again, we are
not root user, I'm going to run it To run
it simply just dot slash exploit and then
press enter.
And you could see we are root this hash sign,
this, this hash sign here. If you're don't
believe you can just say who I am or who am
I sorry? Who am I? You are root. That is how
you do privilege. Escalations. That is one
way to do privilege escalations in one operating
system with one specific kernel version. That
is very small thing, which I just taught here,
but it's a specialized field. It's very big
field. Again. It's all about finding the exploits,
the same methodology, right? You cannot say,
I am. I'm going to learn pen testing. You
need to be specific. What you want to learn
privilege escalation is the same field. It's
a very big ocean. You cannot bring it completely.
You need to be specific what you are going
to do in privilege esclation. Is that making
sense? Any doubt? Any comments?
Oh, it's fine for me, but check the steps
again.
Of course you need to review the video and
you have to do this.
Yeah. For me does make sense. Yeah. It makes
sense when they say you need to compile. So
what did we do in the compile? Right. Okay.
So we don't compile it? And I mean, is it
not supposed to show something like kind of
essential or something?
Okay. Yeah, it really doesn't matter. It will
not show the extension in some cases it may,
but normally it will not show the extension.
It really doesn't matter if it is having extension
or not. And in case of windows. Of course.
I mean, in Linux, it doesn't matter in case
of windows, you would want to have the exe
extension, right? The EXE in Linux, it was
just a dot slash tar and windows, you may
want to have the EXE extension and then run
it. And then it's your choice. I mean, I'm
just going to exit it, exit that PX ID. I
just exited the root shell. I am back as user.
Okay. So if I,udo that GBCC command again,
here, I can just put DB. So exploit don't
DBB DB is the format we use in Debian, and
ubuntu I can put it in. Now you will have
a file called exploit.DBB. You can see exploit.dbb,
right? So it's really actually your choice
if
you want to put extension or not at the end
of year, running it as a, as a script, the
terminals os not required. Right.
All right. Yeah. That makes sense. Well, the
original file, what extension is in you file
what's was the extension for that dot c.
The original was a dot C. So it's written
in C language C language
Okay. Okay. Now that's just that's okay,
Right? That was the source code of the, of
the, or of the actual file. Right? So whatever
software you use it, it has been written in
some language. So the source code of that
thing,
Right? And the good thing is C Python, Java,
Ruby, these big languages, you know, the famous
languages. They are cross platform languages,
so they can work on Linux. They can work on
mac, they can work on windows. That is why
we have to compile them in the same environment
that we want to run it. So I can take the
C code and I can compile this code in windows
machine And it will, it will compile it, but
it will not give me anything because this
exploit is not made for windows, but I can
compile it in windows as well. I can compile
anything okay. Ubuntu is different,Kali Linux
is different. Operating system is different.
It is Debian. Kali. Linux is Debian, but I
can still compile it in Kali linux as well.
So let me show you.
Okay. So, so that means, that means if you
need to run that the windows. So you need
to compile it to dots, to have dots, c extension.
I mean, it's not required again. If you're
going to run it from command prompt from terminal,
extension is not required.
Yeah. But like I have the mastery of Python,
but what I'm saying for you to run it, I know
there are like, if you, for you to run a Python
script, you can only Python script. But I
mean, only window you, I think you need to
compile it. So for that, for that, for that,
for that program to run, let's say you create
a program with Python. I think you need to
compile it for it to run on the window. If
I take am I think that's how it works.
Ya that was the compiling stuff that does
what you're doing compiling.
Yeah. Okay.
So if I try to do a here, you can see, I try
to compile that same script. It should have
worked. The only reason it is not working
is there is some problem in the function.
It can be because my GCC is new. And the GCC,
which this, this source code has been written
is old one. Right. So maybe I can downgrade
my GCC to the old previous version of this
PC. GCC is a software by the way to compile,
right? So GCC is a compiler. I can download
the older version of GCC and then run this,
this same script and I can compile it in kali
linux as well. So at the end, you can compile
it, whatever operating system you want, but
it will not work if the operating system and
kernel do not match for what it was made for.
Right. Making sense.
Yeah. Yeah, it does. So does this only affect
I mean what's it called C language .I think
in Pikeville when you compile it, you can't
run it in any, any platform. I mean, any platform
you don't need to look at the con the Cornell
I mean, you can run on any.
You have to run python on any version of window.
So in case of window, but that is still windows,
right? Operating system is windows. It is
just different version,
Right? Yeah. That's not what I mean, like,
like windows seven, windows 10. I think it
can. If you compile with Python you can run
it on windows seven, windows 10. That's what
I'm saying. So is it just, is it because this
is just a Unix or Linux system as well? We
have to choose the kernel that this will run
So I can still compile that in kali linux
and then run it in a window. It will run,
but it will not work
All right.
The exploit will not work.
All right. Yeah. I get that
Because i will even show you, because if we
read the exploit code, let me show you by
reading it. If you read it, the exploit code.
Okay. What is the three, right? Yeah. If we
read this code. Okay. Just scroll down and
see the code here somewhere.
Mmm.
I don't know where it might be. I mean, it's
a might be somewhere you have to see, but
it will, it will tell you that this code is
actually taking the version number, where
it is being compiled and then putting different
variables. If I am compiling it and it will
make a different product. If I'm compiling
it in ubuntu 16, it will make a different
exploit. So these kinds of codes, they are
always made for different, different versions,
right? So whatever version you compile, it
will make exploit for that version only. And
the tested version are only these 12, 14,
14, and then this one, these four are the
tested ones. So that's the whole point you
can of course try it. So that's why I showed
you that OSboxes right now, go on os boxes
and, you know, just, just try to try to attack
multiple Linux kernel versions because kernel
is kind of the first thing you always try
to do.
I mean, if you can get it if you can get the
escalation through kernel, that's the best
thing you can get because that's the easiest
one to find programs. And then finding expeloits
for programs is kind of a big mess. So a kernel
versions exploits are very easy and they are
recommended once. If you can get them, that's
the best thing you can happen to you? One
more thing I want to show. Okay. One more
thing i want to show. So I want to show windows
as windows one as well, let me just close
this up. I mean, similar way, you can find
for windows as well. How does escalate? But
I want to show the automatic way as well.
So for that, let me power on the windows,
I guess. Sorry, virtual box. There you go.
I'm gonna power on my windows. Whereas windows,
hereis the windows
And there are multiple ways you can do this
automatically through metal spoilt. So that
this kind of a thing, you should try it. So
let me change my network adapter. I want to
be in the range of 148 so 148 Nat network,
148. And let me refresh my IPS DHC client.
That's r oops, r host capital. Here we go
DHC client. Clear IF config. Alright, there
you go. So we got 148 IP. Okay. Let's see.
And windows is powered on let's log in. What's
the password, anyone licensed pen testing?
Hmm. So this is a non root user, right? This
is, this is not anti-authority. This is, this
just hacker in the house. This is just the
admin user. It's not a anti authority. Anti
authority is the top user in windows systems.
Ulet's make a payload, let's make a payload
and let's hack it very quickly. So I'm going
to say MSF,uMSF. I mean, I can actually do
it using that. UI can do it using that eternal
blue exploit, which we have, or I can create
my own. So let me actually create my own MSF
venom. MSF venom is used to create your exploits,
thats the payload, and then you can give payloads.
So I don't know the payload, so I will search
for it. - L is the list list payloads. Uhhere
you go. I am just finding payloads. Hmm. Let's
see.
It's taking time. And he goes, these are all
windows those payloads we have. So I will
go with a payload which is x86 because our
target is x86, a windows and meterpreter a
reverse TCP. Reverse TCP. Yep. That is the
one I want to choose you. Go copy clear. So
now I will say MSF venom dash p the payload
and then dash dash list. And then dash options
. So this this MSF venom is the part of metasploit
framework. It's another tool just like MSF
console is the one of them. So it is also
a part. It is used to create payloads and
just creating one. Here are the options of
that specific payload I can say l host right.
So yeah, that's good. Um host is going to
be my IP and l port i can choose whatever.
So that's fine. Let's do that. So I'm going
to just say clear again, the thing they come
on, I don't need this options. I just need
L host equals now my IP, what is my IP? So
let's see. So I can just find my IP. If config
my IP is 10 dot 11. Yeah. So that is the 11.
So I'll just paste it here and L port. I want
to open a port, which will be, het's say seven,
six, seven, six, randomly . Just did for right.
And umo we can save it. So format format will
be exe and they can save it on my exploits
folder. So the default that we created on
desktop, sorry, desktop. And then exploit.
And then the name of the file will be exploit
dot EXE. So that is how I'm goining to create
this exploit. Umsing MSF venom.
There you go. We created a file. So if they
go to CD exploit, what the hell? Okay. we
are not on the desktop Right. And that was
the problem. Okay. Let's let's do one thing.
Let's let's manually go there. So here we
have this exe file. This is a virus file,here
is the payload in social engineering. You
know, you normally create your payloads and
then you send them, I can just copy this and
I can just paste it here. And my Oh, I think
I can do that. Okay. Okay. I thought it was
possible directly. Can I do that?
Hmm. Okay. I cannot do that, but again, I
can, I can set up a I can set up a Python
server here and, and import it using that.
So I'll just quickly set up a Python server
CD. The desktop exploits, clear the screen.
And then I can basically set up a Python,
python server dash M modules simple HTTP server
simple HTTP. Server e was missing on port
80 i want to run a server So i just started?
My IP was if I'm connected on my IP, I remember
that. And now in this machine, I'm going to
download that file. That infected file I'm
using internet Explorer because that's the
only thing we have to go.
Okay. No HTTP, ten.zero.148.11. Then you go,
we have the exe file. Let me download that
and let's save it on desktop saved. There
you go. That old sound heard after long time.
Now this is the, this is the exe. And so we
downloaded that now, because if I open this
thing, if I open this file as a user, it will
send a connection back to my machine on port.
What was the port guys is anyone remember?
It was six seven, six, seven, guys. Anyone
remembers? Yeah. Six, seven, six, seven, six,
seven, six, seven, six. So I need a listener.
I need to start a listener here. I can listen
to that connection. Multiple ways I can do
Netcat I can use metaspoilt. Like, I mean,
there's not a split, so MSF, venom, sorry,
MSF console. I'm just opening msf console
there. And I will listen. I'm on seven, six,
seven, six, four. So I'll say use exploit
multi handler, multi handler clear this screen
show options and set. Yeah. I mean, it doesn't
show anything because we need to send the
payload as well. Set payload windows meterpreter.
Come on. Met. meterpreter reverse TCP, here
we go clear the options. Show options again.
Okay. Now set l hosts
Okay.
And my l host am going to put zero zero, zero,
zero. It can listen on any, any interface.
I really don't. Yup. Set. Um l port will be
seven, six, seven, six. That is the port where
we are going to receive the connection. And
now clear the screen, run it. Now we are running
a handler. We are listening for any connection
that comes on seven, six, seven 6. If I double
click here, if I run this, if I run the software,
nothing happens. But over here we get a meterpreter
session. Right? So we basically brought a
session, not if I, if I do shell the, we have
the session. But if I try to do Sys info system
info.
Oh, a lot of information there, right? Yep.
You can see it been Microsoft windows XP,
right? So you can just see that,ulet's just
do help. And these are all the options. The
first option for privileged escalation is
always get system get system. How do you get
the system will automatically do privillege
esclation for you? This is not available in
all the meta in all the payloads. If you are
hacking the machine using meterpreter also
only in case of windows, you have get option,
get system option. Yeah. Get ribs. Is that
working? Yeah. So for example, get ribs. We'll
show you what privileges do you have in, in
my case, I have all these privileges and sometimes
they are not enough. You will find very small
little privileges and those cases you may
want to go in and, and find other,uyou know,
you may, go and try ahead and try to escalate
to esclate your privileges, okay.
One thing I want to check is net user. So
net, user, yeah. You can see, these are all
the users, which are available on my machine
and I am logged in as hackerinthehouse.com
by the way. But there are other users as well.
Right. I can escalate. I can escalate right.
And the authority is not given there, but
that is the highest one. So to do escalate,
I will actually go ahead and say, get system,
press enter it will try to get the privilege
escalation. And here,it automatically says.
You actually got it. We actually got it. Okay.
But sometimes it will fail. Okay. That is
something you should always try. It may get
it. But in most cases it will fail 40% chance.
It will get that's the one thing you always
want to try, but this thing will not work
on every, every single operating system.
I believe currently it is only supported on
windows in meterpreter, shell. I think I closed
this session. Now I will run the I will run
that. I will run this again. I'm running this
again, session and I will get the, get the
session back again here. Okay. So we've got
this session two now again. Okay. In some
cases you would want to use a local privilege,
escalation post exploitation. There is a post
exploitation here. If I background the session
background, and if we search for search for
suggester. Okay. So there is an exploit suggestor
it's a privilege, escalation exploit in metasploit.
Okay. This is what I was trying. I can use
this, use this, and I can just show options.
This will require you this session number.
Okay. So I'll just say a set session and session.
Number two is the current one and show descriptions.
Do you want to, if you find some exploit,
do you want their descriptions and additional
information? Do you want that? No You can
make it true if you want, let's keep it false.
Doesn't matter. Let's exploit. Now here, it
will collect a lot of information. It will
do everything. It will collect the currently
installed programs, service, patches, currently
kernel version. It will take a lot of information
automatically, and then it will try to generate
a report and then maybe suggest some things.
This is again, because it is automatic. It
will not be a hundred percent correct. It
will. It will miss a lot of things. It will
take a lot of things extra here. In this case,
you can see 29 exploits have been found so
we can escalate using these 29 different exploits.
Okay. But at the end, if we see 29 exploits
I've been trying, sorry, checking different
29 exploits based on the information it got,
it collected the information.
It made a list of tasks. It tried 29, different
tasks 29 exploits And then these are potentially
possible. So this can not be validated. This
is vulnerable. This is vulnerable. So you
can use this one, right? Trap popup menu.
Very, very common. Okay. In windows, windows,
server, windows, XPS, all of the windows.
One. This is very common vulnerability, trap
menu open. So randomly, it's just showing
that there is this one, a client copy. This
is also very common one. You can take any
of these really doesn't matter. I'll just
randomly just take this one. Yeah. I'm randomly
doing it. I have no idea of this at the moment.
It will work or not. And this is the first
time I'm teaching on this machine. By the
way, on XP. I have, I have shown it on windows
10, earlier of other batches. So use this
show options. Again, it will require a session
number because it's a local exploit privilege,
escalation as well. So session number set.
So set session true lets us exploit it.
Once you do exploit, you will see you get
another shell. Okay? You see meterpreter shell
session three open why three, because you
were able to escalate. Now you are anti authority.
If you see here a process has been created,
injecting the code, whatever it did exploit,
finished waiting for hopefully privileged
payloads. So maybe this is privileged. That's
what it is. Trying to tell you. So this does
not exist, actually my process, okay. I am
running here as a mocker.exe. So that, that
trap popup that has launched this, this process,
which is a not mocker.exe. This is my process.
If I, if I close this process, my shell will
die. I am running as anti authority at the
moment. If I close this shell will die and
I can prove that I can go here, I can go ahead.
And maybe just not sure if I can cut it from
here, but let me try.
Notepad. So where is notepad I can go here,
right? Click end process. Maybe I will not
be able to. Okay. I ended it. Let's go back
and let's see if we have the Shell or not
and you can see meterpreter shell session
three closed, why it was closed because I
ended up process, which was running as anti-authority.
So I had anti-authority access. That is why
this was a running at, notepad the first shell,
which I have the session two, which I have
that does running at exploit dot exe at the
moment. If I close that as well, it will,
it will close my normal shell as well. If
I just say exploit already exe if I end this,
you will be able to see one more shell will
die, shell
Two has also, die Right. So that one was running
as a hacker in the house user, the second
one, which I escalated, which was running
as notepad, which was running with anti authority
privileges. Now that's making sense. Is that
clear now? Yeah. Right. So with that, I hope
you enjoyed privilege. Escalations. It's quite
important. So the part which we covered today
is the base and that is at least I expect,
you know, as a hacker, as a pen tester, at
least you should know that much, if not more
than atleast that much, maybe, you know, just
go on botmill that website, just go ahead
and read these, these commands atleast. Just
try to see what you can do with these commands.
Right. This what was that website got milk.
So it's a very famous one, got milk. Just
like got milk and then just say privilege,
escalation. And that will be the first, the
first lane. Right. Got milk privilege. Escalation.
Yep.
All right. Any doubts? Anyone, if you don't
have, I mean, if you don't have any doubts,
then what I am expecting now is that since
we are at the end of the sessions, what I
expect is we should do a report writing session
tomorrow. And the next week we should do a
real life test where I can maybe invite some
of my client. They will give you a project
and you will have
to work on that. On that, that fields. That
will be cool. That would be cool. Right. Maybe
have a small project. I mean, I don't expect
them to give you
a $10,000 worth of project, maybe one machine
or two machines, a real machines, where you
can possibly try to hack them
you have to sign a lot of paperwork, but let's
do that next week. We can, we can hopefully
get it if not next week then after that next
week, I mean, I just need to talk to
my clients and get you a project, but we will
definitely do
a live project tomorrow. Let's let's plan
the, the report. I think
that
is very, very easy work report writing. And
I can
then explain that right.